All right. Good morning. That lovely cool jazz that you heard playing may make you think
we're having a relaxed board meeting today, but we have a lot to do. So seeing that the
board members are now present, I hereby call the September 2023 meeting of the State Board
of Education to order at 8.33 a.m. And I'd like to commence by saluting the flag. Member
Rodriguez, will you please lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance?
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America, and to the republic for
which it stands, one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
All right. Thank you. Okay. I have a bunch of announcements. I'd like to welcome board
members, staff, and members of the public who are attending this board meeting in person,
and I encourage everyone in the board room to wear masks. We appreciate those who are
doing so. There is a surge going on, and we've had exposures in three of our last four board
meetings, but no transmissions, so we want to be sure that masks are available for those
who need one, and thank you for your consideration. In terms of the meeting, we'll be taking up
item one, state board projects and priorities, and then we'll be clearing the room to adjourn
for closed session. The proposed waiver consent items are W1 through 14. The proposed regular
consent items are items four through seven. There is one public hearing on the agenda.
Item 10 is the appeal of the denial of a petition for the establishment of a classroom-based
charter school pursuant to California Education Code Section 47605K2. It's the review of the
appeal and documentary record and decision to affirm or reverse the Los Angeles Unified
School Districts and Los Angeles County Board of Education's determinations of the Vista
Legacy Global Academy petition. We will reopen item one later today to take action on the
preliminary report of actions draft July 20, 23 meeting minutes, and to report on our
liaison assignments. Public comment will be accepted either in person or by phone. Members
of the public wishing to call in for public comment should view the live stream of the
meeting to know at what time public comment will occur for each item. Public comment may
be provided by dialing the phone number, entering a participant access code, and then following
each of the operator's prompts. Upon dialing in, callers will be added to a caller queue.
The operator will notify callers when it is their turn to provide public comment and will
also ask callers to please turn down the speaker volume of their computers if they are following
the live webcast to avoid an echoing effect. Members of the public wishing to provide public
comment in person should sign in using the binder at the table just outside the room.
The binder is on the table with separate pages for each item number. This will help ensure
that staff is able to track the in-person speakers for a particular item. Public comment
is limited to one person, one minute for each speaker. When speakers require interpretation,
two minutes will be provided. Item 11 is the general public comment item during which members
of the public may provide comment on matters that are not specifically listed on the board's
agenda. I will now open item one, which is our state board projects and priorities item.
I hope our state superintendent, Tony Thurman, is able to beam in at this point. He is, he
is in Southern California for multiple board meetings that he has to attend today. And
he should be beaming in just about now.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond and members of the board. Good morning. I am ready
when you all are. And if, if, if folks can help to enable my camera, I'll be able to
be on camera any moment.
We appreciate the very busy day you have ahead of you, Superintendent, with CSU and, and others.
Do you think he might, do you think he might need to turn his camera on or?
I think we should go ahead with audio.
Okay, Superintendent Thurman, we think at this point, maybe it would be great to go
ahead with just audio. If we are able to solve the video problem, you'll pop onto the screen.
Happy that President Darling-Hammond, I am transitioning to an audio only presentation.
Good morning, Madam President and members of the board. As President Darling-Hammond
indicated, I am at the Cal State University headquarters. Today is an important discussion
about revenue needs for the CSU system. And there's a vote today about a potential
tuition increase. And I want to just say, as difficult as these conversations are, we know
that our institutions need revenue and that our students often struggle when there are increases.
I want to acknowledge everyone who I've had a chance to speak with these last two days
on this subject. First, our students who have been very passionate about the challenges
that they experience. I've also heard from other CSU trustees and staff that these are difficult
times. You know, while there are no easy answers, one of the things that I'm proposing is that we
work to find new permanent funding sources and new revenue that allows us to support our CSUs,
our UCs, and our community colleges. And I want to thank all the educational partners who have joined
in those conversations over the last several weeks to continue looking for new revenue sources
as we try to figure out a way to build a new way for the CSU and the UC and the community college
system. Many of you know the CSU provides us with many of our teachers who come through the teacher
credentialing programs. And so it's exciting to be thinking about what we do in the future if we can
work through these big challenges. As we get underway, I also want to recognize our new student
board member, Anya, who began her term on August 1st. Welcome, Anya. Anya is a senior at Dr. D.
Valley High School currently taking courses in economics and political science at Diablo Valley
College. Anya is sure to be a stellar addition to our team. In addition to serving on the state
board of education, Anya will be serving her second term as a student board member of San
Ramon Valley Unified School District, a role in which Anya co-leads the student senate,
a district-wide student advisory group consisting of reps from all secondary sites. Anya also serves
on the school district's committees, including the OCAP committee, grading reform, equity and
steering, and facilities master plan. Anya, thank you for your time and service, and we're so pleased
to have you here and look forward to listening and learning from you. I also want to just
acknowledge that this week we mark the anniversary of September 11th, that a difficult time when we
lost many. I had an opportunity this week to speak with someone who lost a family member,
and again want to acknowledge the family members who lost loved ones, our first responders,
many of whom made the ultimate sacrifice, and as they say, that we should never forget,
and that as we work with our students, we mark things that have happened in history that we
should never forget, so that they may become civic-minded and be the leaders who will help us
to make the right decisions going forward for how we promote democracy and justice and freedom
and safety for all, and so we're grateful to all of our students as we share what is a difficult
time, but we look for the learning on how we never forget these and other tragedies that have
impacted the American people. Coming back to the CSUs and teachers, I want to report,
Madam President, and thank you for being a part of what was the first ever that we've convened,
a statewide teacher summit, teacher recruitment summit. I want to thank you for your remarks and
being a part of that on that important day, hundreds of individuals across the state and
some right here in the state boardroom who participated in our conversations about how
we will recruit more teachers. We had some great breakout groups that are focused on how do we
recruit from families of our military personnel who are stationed in California, someone who has
a loved one who has teaching experience from another state. We had a very robust conversation
about how do we bring retired teachers back into the classroom so that they can help us on a short
term way and in a way that does not impact their pension benefits. We talked about how classified
staff and expanded learning staff can become teachers, and we will continue to do this important
work. Many of you know Karen Sher, who is a teacher on loan to us now at the Department of Education,
who will be helping to lead some of our statewide work around teacher recruitment. We know there's
a lot of work to be done. We've got a public service announcement and other efforts, but
we are leaning in and I'm hopeful, and I think that the state of education is hopeful, but we've
got to find ways to recruit more teachers and classified staff and administrators and others
who will work in our schools. Many of you have followed that we've been engaged directly with
school districts about issues of cultural conversations and issues about what kind of
education students should have access to. We've been talking about inclusive education. Of course,
we have an ethnic studies graduation requirement, and we put on a number of webinars in the last
few weeks to support ethnic studies, including creating a new certification so that someone who
wants to become able to train school districts and how they create their ethnic studies curricula,
that they will have access to how the model curriculum that has been created and approved
by the state board can be available to them. We continue to encourage our districts to work
with someone who has experience working through the model curriculum. It has ways to really bring
us the most robust conversations about the groups that have been part of ethnic studies
and to leave out anything that might create division in our communities, and so we're excited
that we had a few hundred people who actually participated and have received the certification
and are now available to work on ethnic studies for our school districts.
As we continue the conversation about inclusive education, I do want to let you know that
we're standing up for students of color and for LGBTQ plus students. We have said that books
should not be banned anywhere in the country and certainly not in California. To that end,
I've sponsored a bill, AB 1078, that simply says if you ban a book with the intent of discriminating
against students of color or LGBTQ students, that you will experience a fine for that to mitigate
the impacts of those bans. We have engaged in deep conversation with school board members and
students and parent groups about the importance of respecting the needs of students and protecting
their privacy as it relates to their sexual identity. We've heard from many students who
have said that they feel uncomfortable and worried and anxious about some of these new measures,
and so I just want to remind students anywhere in our state, if ever you're feeling anxiety about
anything, you can reach out 24 hours a day, seven days a week, to get help through what we call 9-8-8.
9-8-8 is a number where you can text and call and you can talk with a counselor
at any time who will be able to help you as you deal with whatever anxiety or other concerns
that you have. I'm excited, Madam President and members of the board, to share with you
some new work that we are launching to look into how to create more paid internships for California
students and to link those internships to career pathways. I was honored to join the governor and
President Darling-Hammond in a press conference last week where the governor announced a new
executive order that will be very focused on pathway development and creating a new master
plan on career education and how we prepare our students for the jobs of tomorrow. We have worked
to create some paid internships that we'll be rolling out and meeting with those who work
in CTE and youth development to show young people how they can earn and learn at the same time,
how they can learn about different careers, whether that be in health care or
biotech or technology, or if they want to learn about being in the apprenticeship training programs.
We have trade programs that are looking to seek the next class of those who would work in our trades,
and so we ask you to stand by and to join us in our summit on paid internships and preparing
students for the jobs of tomorrow on October 10th, and that will take place in the state boardroom
at 11 a.m. Finally, I'd like to just mention that we're approaching, in the month of September,
voter education week, and we use that as a time when our schools remind our students that they
can get registered to vote and provide them with all the important information about civic
involvement. We know that we've provided now more than 10,000 seals of civic engagement over the
last several years, and this is very much important and linked to voter education week.
September the 18th through September the 29th represents voter education week, an important
time for civic discussions and civic engagement. Finally, I just want to close with saying
congratulations and welcome back to all of our schools who are now back to school, and we've
had wonderful, wonderful visits with districts all across the state where families engage in
attending classes, and we're so excited that we can welcome everybody back to school. We're
hopeful for an exciting year. We know that there are challenges ahead, but we're prepared to help
our students get better in all subjects and to engage families and to work to make this
a great school year for all of our students. With that, Madam President, this concludes my report,
and I will remain available if there are any questions for me.
Thank you so much, and good luck on your very busy and important day ahead.
I would like to shift now to welcome our new student board member, Anya Ayyepan,
who is here to be sworn in for her very first board meeting. So Anya,
we're going to do this right over here in front of the flags.
So if you could raise your right hand and state after me, I, Anya Ayyepan,
will solemnly swear that I will support and defend the Constitution of the United States
against all enemies, foreign and domestic, that I will bear true faith and allegiance
to the Constitution of the United States and the Constitution of California,
that I take this obligation freely without any mental reservation or purpose of evasion,
and that I will well and faithfully discharge the duties upon which I am about to enter.
Congratulations, Anya. I know your parents are here also.
Please come up and get a picture with everyone. Congratulations. Wonderful.
Thank you, and we'll hear more from you about our liaison reports.
We always love these moments where we're joined by yet another brilliant member of our
student body in California, and look forward to hearing more from you during the liaison reports.
And with that, I'm going to give my report, and then we'll go into closed session. I, too,
want to congratulate our teachers, principals, staff, students, and families on the start of
the 2023-24 school year. I know months of planning go into these successful fall openings. There's so
much excitement in schools around the state. I want to thank everyone who worked so hard to
get our schools ready and to welcome back students. I especially want to welcome our
youngest learners, our new transitional kindergarten students, who will be joining
us in greater numbers than ever before as we launch the second year of transitional kindergarten
expansion. Yay. And I cannot tell you how many excited children and parents and grandparents
I have spoken to about TK, and we know that strong kindergarten readiness is essential to
overall school success. We're excited to have our four-year-old students and their teachers
embark on a year of fun and learning. This year also marks the first year of the full implementation
of the expanded learning opportunities program. We expect that this program will bring access to
after school and summer school enrichment opportunities to more than one million elementary
school students across the state. These programs increase school engagement, stem summer learning
loss, provide students with learning experiences in the arts, in STEM, sports, and other activities
that spark joy and learning. And this is a program that is sort of baked into our
ongoing school budget, so it's not something that's going to come and go, but it will be a constant
reality for families and for children. Our teachers will also enjoy more support in literacy
instruction this year, building off of the $250 million provided in the 2022 budget
for reading coaches and literacy specialists in our highest need schools. We've added another
$250 million to that program, and the budget also provides funding for a literacy roadmap
to provide LEAs and schools with the resources that they need to effectively plan and access
resources for literacy instruction for both native English speakers and multilingual learners.
You know, we ground our work in California in the ELA-ELD curriculum framework that was passed in
2014. We were one of the earliest states to basically adopt the science of reading and
to do so with the needs of multilingual learners in mind as well as native English speakers,
and we have been building upon that ever since. Instructional continuity is also going to be
an issue that we need to pay a lot of attention to, and it's a key to academic success
for children. Already in this school year, we've had school closures due to fires in the
north of the state and storms and flooding in the south and inland portions of the state.
Last year, in addition to the ongoing challenges of COVID and other viruses, we lost
millions of school days to natural disasters that either close schools or prevent students
from reaching them. So as the climate continues to evolve, our schools will need to adapt
to these emerging conditions to ensure that even when students can't physically attend school,
they can continue to learn. And during the pandemic, we did learn many lessons about
how to support continuity of instruction through remote and hybrid learning. We will seek ways to
support schools to build on that knowledge to make sure our students can access education,
even when they cannot physically access a school building. Now switching gears to the state board
business, we have several advisory openings with applications due September 29th, and I know our
screening committee is looking forward to receiving those applications. We are looking
for qualified educators for the Instructional Quality Commission and for a student IQC member.
There are also openings on the Advisory Commission on Special Education and the California
Practitioners Advisory Group. We are also accepting applications for next year's student
board member, which seems a little premature, but it does take a long time to find these amazing
students and those applications are due September 22nd. You can find out about all of these
opportunities on our website. Finally, I need to make a bittersweet announcement. It is my honor
and privilege to announce that Janet Weeks, the State Board of Education's Communications Director,
has retired as of August 31st. We are very happy for Janet, but we are very sad for ourselves.
Her retirement is a huge loss for board members and staff.
Janet was appointed by Governor Brown in 2016. She was reappointed by Governor Newsom in 2020.
Over the course of her career at the state board, Janet has been a key player in every important
decision that has come to the board. She helped lead the redesign of the dashboard. Anyone who
has been around a while can remember the trivial pursuit pies, and thanks to Janet, they are gone.
She has helped navigate the board's work on many of the difficult issues that have come our way
especially curriculum frameworks in history, health, ethnic studies, and most recently
mathematics. And while she is brilliant with the media, Janet has been far more than a
communications director. I think it's fair to say that without her policy expertise and media know-how,
those framework adoptions would not have happened. Prior to her appointment at the board, Janet was
a reporter at USA Today and then TV Guide. She would often regale the staff with funny stories
about her interviews of TV celebrities back in the days when there was a printed TV Guide,
including her visit to Australia for the filming of Survivor. Upon leaving journalism,
Janet and her family, including her husband Rocky and daughters Rose and Lily, relocated
to Sacramento where Janet became an English and journalism teacher at CK McClatchy High School
in the Sacramento City Unified School District. She left the classroom for the district office
where she was communications manager for six years, and in this role she wrote the Sacramento
City Unified Weekly Newsletter, the speeches for the superintendent, supported principals,
and district staff with media relations during times of crisis and otherwise. She developed the
SCUSD's Community Guide to the LCAP, which was later praised by my colleague and former state
board president Mike Kirst as a helpful tool for engagement. In late 2016, she joined the state
board of education as communications director, and replacing Janet is really not possible.
I doubt there's anyone else in the state who has interviewed TV stars, managed high school
journalism students, navigated local boards, state boards, and state government successfully.
More than anything, Janet has been a great colleague who brings a sense of fun to every
meeting, whether it's decorating her office with pictures of Ryan Gosling or giving
colleagues gifts from her storage unit. Talk about regifting. Janet brings a bit of joy with
her wherever she goes, and on a personal note, I really need to thank Janet for all of her
hard work, her support. I've relied on her every day on her skills, her advice, her dedication
during my term on the state board. So during her well-deserved retirement, Janet plans to
travel with her family, plan her daughter's wedding, and attend a lot of concerts with
her friends. We wish her well. We will sorely miss Janet's presence, and we do have a certificate
for Janet, a small token of our deep appreciation. Brooks, would you do the honors?
It doesn't take long.
Now, can you hear me?
Some communications director, right? Just proving wrong everything Dr. Darling-Hammond just said.
Thank you so much. I know I've had a really weird career trajectory if you go from TV Guide to the
State Board of Education, but I feel like being yelled at by Adam Sandler and Kelsey Grammer at
different moments sort of prepared me for public education, so it all makes sense if you think
about it. So anyways, thank you so much for your kind words. It's really been an honor of lifetime
to work for you all, and I miss you all already, and it's so lovely to see you here today, and
thank you so much. It's been a privilege to learn from Dr. Darling-Hammond, from everyone here,
and from the amazing staff at the State Board of Education, really the smartest and exceedingly
kind people you could ever want to work with, and the support of the CDE colleagues. I mean,
none of this happens without them, and so it's just been great, and you know, public education
is this great big thing in California. You know, there's 5.8 million kids, 10,000 schools,
1,000 school districts, 58 county offices of education. It's this huge thing, but for people,
it's a very personalized and individual experience, and so the work of the State Board is to navigate
that really strange space where you're working with a giant system that is deeply personal
to each person that goes through it, and you guys do that work so deftly and so sensitively
and so smartly, and I'm going to be rooting for you from the sidelines, and I will be watching
The Wire because I feel it's important to watch it, and everybody tells me it's the best television
show. I've never seen an episode, but between episodes of The Wire, I will be rooting for you,
and I just wish you all the best of luck, and thank you so much again. Thank you.
Thank you so much, Janet. At this point, we are going to move to closed session where the
board will discuss or take action on the following legal matters, MSC versus State and Mark S versus
State. We'd like to ask members of the public to please leave the room at this time.
All right. Welcome back. In closed session, the board discussed and took action on the
following legal matters, MSC versus State and Mark S versus State, and we will move on to item
two, which is the local control and accountability plan template, revision drafts consistent with
California Education Code section 52064. This is not an action item, but we are providing feedback
regarding the draft LCAP template and instructions that incorporate the requirements outlined in
Senate Bill 114, and the CDE also recommends that the State Board take additional action
as deemed necessary and appropriate. This item will be presented by Nancy Kim Portillo
and Josh Strong of the CDE. Please begin. Good morning. You all can hear me? Wonderful.
Good morning, Board President Darling Hammond, Chief Deputy Nicely, and members of the board.
My name is Nancy Kim Portillo, and I'm the Deputy Superintendent of the Student Achievement Branch.
I also bring you greetings from William McGee, Director of the Student Achievement and Support
Division, who is currently in Washington, D.C. on behalf of the department. I am here today to
introduce item two, local control and accountability plan template, revision drafts consistent with
California Ed Code section 52064. On July 10, 2023, Senate Bill 114 was signed into law.
Among other things, Senate Bill 114 amended California Ed Code section 52064, which requires
revisions be made to the LCAP template and instructions for the 2024-25 school year.
Item two will provide the board with a summary of revisions to the LCAP template
and instructions required by Senate Bill 114, as well as additional revisions being proposed by
the California Department of Education, consistent with the direction provided by the board at its
November 2021 meeting to identify opportunities to streamline the template. At this time, I'd like
to introduce Joshua Strong, the Administrator of the Local Agency Systems Support Office,
who will be presenting item two. Thank you.
Thank you, Deputy Superintendent Portillo. Good morning, members of the board,
Chief Deputy Nicely, President Darling-Hammond. As Deputy Superintendent Portillo said, I'm Joshua
Strong. I'm the Administrator of the Local Agency Systems Support Office here at the department,
and I'm here to talk to you about the LCAP template and instruction revisions
that are being proposed at this point in time. Just some brief grounding and background for
all of you. As all of you are most likely aware, the LCAP, the Local Control and Accountability
Plan, is a three-year plan that describes the goals, actions, services, expenditures
that support positive student outcomes to address state and local priority areas.
The LCAP development process is intended to serve three related functions. The first of
which is comprehensive strategic planning, and within Senate Bill 114, the following phrase was
added, particularly to address and reduce disparities in opportunities and outcomes
between student groups indicated by the California School Dashboard. That's a new addition to statute.
And so, as you'll see throughout the template and the instructions, we really tried to highlight
that particular piece around addressing and reducing disparities in opportunities and outcomes
as part of the instructions in particular. Another one of the three roles that it plays
is that of meaningful educational engagement of educational partners, and then accountability
and compliance, because there's elements of that accountability and compliance system
that live within the LCAP. As you've already heard, Senate Bill 114 amended Education Code
Section 52064 in order to require some specific revisions be made to the LCAP template and to
the instructions. Those are summarized for you in Attachment 1 of the item.
Education Code Section 52064 is the piece of education code that specifically outlines what
is required to be included within the template and the instructions. And as part of that education
code, just as a reminder, it outlines that the LCAP template itself is to use language that's
understandable and accessible to parents to the greatest extent practicable, and that the
instructions for the LCAP are allowed to contain more technical information for LEAs and for those
that are writing the plan. For that reason, you'll see a difference between the template and the
format of the template and the instructions within the template. In terms of our revision
timeline, at this point in time, we have brought the LCAP template and instructions, our initial
draft, we took them to the LCAP advisory group, which is an ad hoc group of technical experts
and partners throughout the field that we bring together any time that we need to make revisions.
The role of the LCAP advisory group is really to identify areas of fatal flaws or things in the
initial proposals that we're making, because they're folks from districts, county offices,
advocacy groups, and other statewide educational partners that will be able to point out,
here are the major holes or the major issues with what's being proposed initially.
After we get feedback from them, we make revisions, and we've taken that statewide.
We had a statewide webinar to solicit input. That webinar was attended by 800-plus individual
attendees. Of that, we received feedback both during the webinar, but then also via email
following that. We took the template and the instructions to the California Practitioners
Advisory Group, received input from them, and we're bringing it to you now.
Following your recommendations, we will make adjustments to the template and the instructions.
We'll again take that to the LCAP advisory group, take that out to another statewide webinar,
and bring it back to you in November. Statute allows you, allows the state board until January
of 2024 to adopt the template and the instructions. However, in practice, we found that if we can have
the board adopt that in November, the additional two months provides a lot of valuable time for
LEAs to be able to get trained on the new requirements, to be able to make adjustments,
and have that information in hand in concurrence with the release of the dashboard so that that
aids them in having the time that they need to craft plans that are going to really make a
difference for their students. That's especially critical when we're talking about the 2024-25
school year, as it's the first year in the next three-year cycle of the LCAP. They'll be making
their plans for the next three years, and so having that information available to them is critical.
We've provided you with five different attachments within the item. Attachment one is the summary of
required and proposed revisions. Attachment two is the current LCAP template and instructions.
Attachment three is the proposed revisions to the template and the instructions using track
changes. Attachment four are for those of you that look at track changes and your heads explode.
It provides you with the opportunity to compare attachment two and attachment four and see
where the changes are and what it looks like without having to deal with all of the red and
blue and strikethroughs and underlines. And then attachment five is the proposed
LCAP annual updates template and instructions that's referred to in attachment one and that
we'll speak briefly about. So I want to take some time to go into a summary of the required
and the proposed revisions. These are revisions that are being proposed by and large based on
the requirements of Senate bill 114. There are also some additional revisions that we're proposing
in order to help the readability of the template and the instructions as well as to shorten
the template in response to the board's direction at its November 2021 meeting to identify
opportunities to streamline the template and the instructions. So all of this information is
provided for you in attachment one of the item. So I want to start off talking about the intent
of the LCAP development process. As has already been identified, the addition to the education
code section 52064 relating to addressing and reducing disparities in opportunities and outcomes
between student groups indicated by the California school dashboard is one of the key pieces of new
legislation within that ed code. And it really kind of seeks to draw together the dashboard
and the LCAP into a cohesive improvement system to allow LEAs to look at what's going on in the
dashboard, address those things through the LCAP and be able to make substantive change
for those student groups and those schools that need that additional support within their plans.
So this shows up within the instructions for the LCAP template.
The remainder of the proposed recommendations, we're just going to walk through
in order of how they appear within the template and the instructions so that it doesn't necessarily
follow the order that they appear in law, it follows the order they appear in the template.
So statute requires that the LCAP include a plan summary that provides general information
about the LEA and highlights of the LCAP, including reflections on the LEA's annual
performance on the dashboard as well as local data, so both state and local data.
Senate bill 114 adds the requirement that LEAs that are eligible for technical assistance
are pursuant to education code section 47607.3, 52071, 52071.5, 52072, and 52072.5
must also include a summary of the work that's underway as part of that technical assistance.
Now, the within those sections of education code, the most common form of technical assistance
there is frequently referred to as differentiated assistance. However, it's important to note that
that is not the only option for technical assistance that exists within those pieces of
education code, which is why within the instructions, you won't see it referred to
as differentiated assistance. It's referred to as technical assistance because it also includes
instances where an LEA has actually requested to receive technical assistance
from a county office of education or instances where a county office of education
has been unable to approve a school district's LCAP on or before the statutory deadline of October
8th and has to work with that school district, provide them with technical assistance to ensure
that the LCAP reaches an approvable state. So those are other options for technical assistance
that exist within these sections of education code. To address this, we're proposing some
revisions to the instructions. In addition, we're also proposing to consolidate the prompts within
the template itself in order to condense the information that's there and streamline what
LEAs are asked to provide initially, while at the same time providing LEAs with the flexibility to
continue to call out those areas that they want to highlight for the public within the planned summer.
Moving on to the engaging educational partners section, education code section 52064B10
was amended to require that schools that generate LCFF equity multiplier funding
must include a summary of how they're consulting with educational partners at schools generating
those funds in the development of the LCAP. And this ties in with another requirement that
we'll speak to more in a little bit, but that is the requirement, the new requirement that
for each school that's receiving LCFF equity multiplier funding, there be a specific focus goal
within the LCAP for that school. So in order to ensure that the development of that goal for that
school includes the educational partners at that school, we're proposing to include within the
instructions based on ed code the requirement that LEAs that have those required goals
need to include educational partners from their LCFF equity multiplier schools in the process to
develop the LCAP. So again, when we're talking about educational partners here, we're talking
about students, parents, teachers, other school staff, local bargaining units, and the community
in general. So it's really the intent here is to really get the input from the entire school
community in terms of developing those specific goals for those specific schools. In addition,
we're proposing the department is proposing to remove one of the prompts within the engaging
educational partners section of the LCAP because it's not explicitly required by statute while at
the same time preserving the flexibilities that LEAs have to be able to provide that additional
context within the engaging educational partner section if they want to. And we'll look at that
a little bit later in the presentation. Within the goals and action section, education code section
52064E4 was amended to specify that LEAs must consider their performance on the state and local
indicators included within the dashboard in determining whether and how to prioritize the
goals, specific actions, and related expenditures within the LCAP. Up until this point, it's simply
that LEAs should do this. Now they must do this as part of the consideration of how it is that
they're prioritizing their goals. And so the LCAP template instructions have been amended to reflect
that particular requirement. In terms of measuring and reporting outcomes, which is where the metrics
and outcomes for the goals live. Senate Bill 114 added education code section 52064E3,
which requires that for each action and budgeted expenditure that's provided to all students on a
district-wide, county-wide, or charter-wide basis, we otherwise refer to that as LEA-wide,
pursuant to education code section 4223.07. One or more specific metrics to monitor the intended
outcome of that action and budgeted expenditure must be identified. All of you at this point in
time are probably aware of the requirement within both LCFF and the LCAP to increase or improve
services for low-income English learner or foster youth students. What this particular piece of
education code, this addition, has done is to require that any actions that are being provided
LEA-wide within the plan and are identified as contributing towards meeting the requirements
to increase or improve services for those three student groups has to have at least one metric
identified, called out within the plan of how the LEA is tracking the performance of that particular
action within the plan. Prior to this, there hasn't been a requirement for any sort of one-to-one
correlation between specific metric and a specific action. This is the first time that this exists
within the plan. It doesn't limit an LEA from being able to say, okay, we're going to use
several metrics to assess the performance of this particular action. But at a minimum, an LEA has
to include one metric for each contributing LEA-wide action within its plan. So that's
been called out within the instructions as part of this new requirement. As part of that requirement,
we've also provided LEAs, at least the proposal at this point in time, is to provide LEAs with
flexibility on where in the template they address that requirement. Within the template and the
instructions, there are a number of places that an LEA might choose to place that just based on the
fact that it's a metric, it's addressing an action, and it's related to increasing or improving
services. And so the three places that LEAs are currently being provided flexibility to address
this is within the description of the metric itself, within the description of the action,
or within the first prompt of the increased or improved services section of the LCAP,
which is the prompt where LEA-wide actions are addressed within the plan.
So that provides LEAs with the flexibility to be able to call out what the metric or metrics
related to that action is within the plan in a way that best suits the needs of their community.
Required goals. Education code section 52064E5 and E6 previously required that an LEA
include a specific goal within its plan if it had consistently low-performing students
or consistently low-performing schools as identified on the California school dashboard
within the LEA. Senate Bill 114 amended those two pieces of education code so that those required
goals are no longer required. So that piece of the instructions is being removed from the LCAP.
However, in place of that, education code section 52064E7 was amended to require that LEAs that are
receiving LCFF equity multiplier funding include one or more focus goals for each school within
the LEA that's generating that funding within the plan. It's important to note here that
LCFF equity multiplier funding is obviously not going to be received by all schools statewide.
It's specific targeted funding that's going to schools that meet certain eligibility requirements.
And so as part of this requirement, one of the things that you'll see is that the instructions
have been amended. However, other than amending the instructions to include this,
we're not calling out LCFF equity multiplier goals in general on the template, in part because they
don't apply or won't apply to the vast majority of LEAs statewide. Now, some LEAs statewide,
this is going to have a significant impact because if you have an LEA that has 15
LCFF equity multiplier schools, that means they will have 15 required goals within their plan.
So for some LEAs, this will have a significant impact on their plan.
For other LEAs, this will have no impact on their plan.
Now, in terms of required actions, Education Code Section 52064B2 was added the requirement
that an LEA that's eligible for technical assistance, and I won't read the Ed Code sections
again, we've already done that, must include actions within the LCAP that address the work
underway as part of that technical assistance. So this is a specific requirement in addition to
the requirement that we discussed earlier to include a summary within the plan summary of how
that technical assistance is going on. This particular requirement requires that specific
goals be provided within the LCAP to implement that work that's going on as part of the technical
assistance that's being received. Those actions will obviously be integrated within goals.
Sometimes those actions are going to be integrated within the specific goal LCFF equity multiplier
school goals that we just talked about because part of the requirement within those LCFF equity
multiplier school goals is that they have to address any schools that are receiving the lowest
performance level on the dashboard as well as any instances of teacher assignment,
teacher preparedness, teacher misassignments in comparison with the rest of the LEA. So to the
extent that there's a significant difference between the staff that's providing instruction
at the LCFF equity multiplier schools and the remainder of the district that the LEA seek to
make progress in ensuring that those teachers at the LCFF equity multiplier schools are better
trained, better prepared, and that there's less of a discrepancy between the teachers within those
schools. In addition, education code section 52064 E6 was amended to include the requirement that
LEAs have to include specific actions in the LCAP to address all instances where a school or a
student group within an LEA or a student group within a school in the LEA receives the lowest
performance level on one or more state indicators on the dashboard. So for example, an LEA is going
to have to include specific actions within the LCAP to address instances of say their English
learner population scoring in the red on an ELA indicator on the dashboard. Okay, they would have
to have one or more actions that are included in the plan there. In addition, education code section
52064 E5 has been revised to specify that LEAs that have a specific English learner student group
or a numerically significant long-term English learner student subgroup must include specific
actions within the LCAP. Education code section, one of the things that Senate Bill 114 did
was to revise education code section 52052 to include long-term English learners as a numerically
significant subgroup for purposes of the dashboard. One of the things to note about that
is that unlike the majority of the student groups which have an N size of 30, the N size for LTELs
is 15, along with your foster youth and your homeless youth. So what this particular required
action is putting into place is specific actions when an LEA has 30 or more English learners
and or 15 or more long-term English learners. And we'll talk about that a little bit further on in
the presentation. To address these requirements, we've proposed some additions to the LCAP template
and then a couple of changes within the actually more of the changes in the instructions
and a couple of changes within the template itself.
Moving on to the goal analysis. The goal analysis is required to be included as part of the annual
update of the plan to reflect on how an LEA has implemented the goals and actions throughout the
preceding year. And so currently or previously, education code included a requirement that LEAs
assess the effectiveness of a specific action. LEAs are now, based on changes to ed code,
required to assess the effectiveness or ineffectiveness of an action. So to what
extent was an action effective? To what extent did the action help the LEA to make progress towards
achieving its goal? Or the action didn't make it have any substantive impact on the LEA making
progress towards achieving its goal? Obviously, in order to know that, an LEA is going to have
to ensure that it's got sufficient metrics in place to address whether an action is effective
or ineffective. And so that's going to be a major focus of the statewide training that my office is
going to be doing beginning in November and running through December, maybe early January. We'll see.
In addition, Senate Bill 114 amended Education Code Section 52064
to include the requirement that LEAs, I just said that, apologies.
So Education Code Section 52064E8 specifies that LEAs must change actions that have not
proven effective over a three-year period. This is a new requirement. Previously, there was a
requirement in the transition from the 2019-20 to the 2021-22 LCAP that an LEA assessed the
effectiveness of its contributing actions, its actions that were used to increase or improve
services for its low-income English learner and foster youth students. This is the first time
that an assessment of the effectiveness of an action over the course of three years is being
required for all actions within the plan. So beginning with the development of the 2024-25
LCAP, LEAs will need to assess whether or not the actions within the plan have proven effective
or ineffective towards meeting that requirement, and if they're ineffective, they have to change
the actions. Now, it's important to note that doesn't mean they have to stop doing an action.
It means that they have to change the action. The action needs to be revised in some way,
shape, or form to allow it to be effective. And so as part of this requirement,
there has to be a description of why the action didn't have, why there was a lack of progress
related to the action, and it also has to include a description of how the changes to the action,
or the new action, is going to result in a strengthened approach. So there's an articulation
of the thought process that's gone into that change that's been made. It's not just something
that's being done in a vacuum without any thought put into it. So the instructions for the LCAP
template have been amended to address these new requirements and include that. In addition,
the department is proposing to move the location of the goal analysis prompts from where they
currently reside in the template, which is following the actions and services, to a new
position following the measure and reporting outcomes. And the reason is because when an LEA
is coming in to develop its next three-year plan, it's looking at, okay, what are the outcomes
that we've seen over the last three years related to our desired outcome, where we want to be?
Then we're looking at, okay, how did we implement those actions? How effective or ineffective were
those actions? And then that's going to drive the changes that are made to the actions within
the template. So by moving the goal analysis piece from following the goals and actions section
to preceding the goals and actions section, it really gives readers of the plan a more holistic
look in terms of what thought process and what analysis went into the development of those
actions that are then included in the plan. And then lastly, in terms of the goal analysis,
the department is proposing the inclusion of a stand-alone LCAP annual update template for use
when developing the 2024-25 LCAP. And the reason for this is because as part of the annual update
process, LEAs are having to go back and to report out their expected outcomes for the 2023-24 school
year. They're having to report out on the goals and actions that are included within their
2023-24 plan. And so my office put together some mock-ups of what this might look like
within the current template. And we came out with a lot of confusing and really ugly things.
Because you'd either have to post the 2023-24 LCAP with your 2024-25 LCAP so that folks could see
one plan and compare it to the other plan. Or you would have to transition the goals and actions
that were implemented in 23-24 into the 24-25 LCAP simply for the purpose of providing the
annual update before getting rid of them the following year. And none of that made a whole
lot of sense. So the cleanest option that we've been able to come up with at this point in time
is to propose this stand-alone template that would be utilized as part of the 2024-25 LCAP
and then following that would go away. LEAs would then go back to reporting their annual update
within the LCAP template beginning with the 2025-26 LCAP in the way that they have consistently for
the last two years. This is also an approach that's consistent with the process that we used when we
transitioned from the 2019-20 LCAP template to the 2021-22 LCAP template. We used a stand-alone
annual update template to transition between those two. And it worked fairly well.
We've gotten a number of pieces of feedback on the proposed template. And so there's potentially
some things that we can do in order to kind of further streamline that particular annual update
template. But at this point in time, we feel that that's going to be the most straightforward
way to address that annual update requirement in transitioning between the two, three-year cycles.
The last section of the LCAP is the increased or improved services for foster youth,
English learners, and low-income students. As was previously discussed, Education Code Section
52052 added long-term English learners as a numerically significant subgroup. As part of that,
Education Code Section 52064B3 was amended to clarify that when it comes to the requirement
to increase or improve services for low-income English learner and foster youth students pursuant
to Education Code Section 42238.07, or sorry, .02. No, I was right the first time. It's .07.
Long-term English learners are part of the English learner subgroup, which means
it's perfectly fine for an LEA to have actions that are increasing or improving services
for long-term English learners, in the same way that it's perfectly fine for an LEA to have
actions that are increasing or improving services specifically for homeless students
who are automatically identified as low-income students. All of that is perfectly fine.
So as part of this new requirement within Ed Code, we've taken the opportunity to call out
a couple of times some specifics around long-term English learners also being part of the English
learner student group when it comes to this requirement to increase or improve services
for low-income English learner and foster youth students.
There's a couple of additional proposed revisions that we're proposing, one of which is to
consolidate the data entry table and the total expenditures table within the LCAP action tables
to reduce a little bit of duplication of effort. It just consolidates things a little bit better.
We're also proposing to revise the wording. If you've looked through the draft in attachment
three, you'll see some instances where we've broken things out using bullet points, whereas
before you had a bunch of paragraphs of text, it was relatively easy to lose track of what
the different requirements or what specific student groups were being referred to.
By revising those instructions to break things out into bullet points, we're hoping that it
will not only help to improve the clarity for the readers, but also ensure that everything is being
addressed in the way that it's supposed to be. At this point in time, what I'd actually like to do
is to switch gears and pull up attachment three itself and kind of walk through some of the big
picture or high point items that are in there. For the sake of brevity, I'm not going to go into
all of the individual proposed changes relating to wording or things like that, but I want to
make you aware of and draw your attention to a number of things. You can follow along with
attachment three. Again, if the track changes scare you, you can look at attachment four,
but this will allow us to kind of walk through and allow you to visualize
what these changes are within the template and the instructions.
So beginning with the plan summary, you can see that our proposal here is to change the reflections
for successes and reflections on identified need into the reflections on annual performance
and the reflections on technical assistance. This is consistent with education code.
Annual performance will be where an LEA will describe both successes and challenges. It will
also describe the particular connection between the performance on the dashboard and also including
local data and identify how the LEA is doing overall. In addition, there's some additional
things that we're calling out as part of the instructions, and so I'll save that for later.
Reflections on technical assistance is what we're proposing in order to address the requirement
that LEAs that are eligible for technical assistance specifically summarize how that
technical assistance is being provided in the process that's underway there.
For LEAs that are not eligible for technical assistance, they're simply going to identify
that this is not applicable and move on. And you can see that we're proposing to
remove the LCAP highlights prompt within the plan summary piece. This does not remove
an LEA's ability from calling out or highlighting particular things within the plan. They still have
the option based on the flexibility of the template to address, to call out highlights,
things that they really want the community to know about either in the general information section
of the plan or within the annual performance section of the plan. They can call that out.
What this is doing is it's simply removing one more place for LEAs to have to provide verbiage.
It's seeking to streamline that requirement within the template.
Moving into the engaging educational partners section, here our recommendation is to remove
the second prompt, the summary of the feedback provided by specific educational partners.
This is not specifically required by statute. As part of the requirement in the third prompt,
description of how engagement with educational partners influenced the development of the
adopted LCAP, LEAs still have the flexibility to be able to call out specific feedback provided
by educational partners and how that then was used to make changes or additions to the template
and the instructions. It allows them to be able to continue to do that if they want to.
In terms of the goals and actions section, one of the proposals that we're making is to add in
a field to identify the state priorities that are addressed by the goal. It's required that an LEA
address all applicable state priorities within its LCAP. This simply provides a place and a mechanism
for LEAs to be able to identify for their educational partners what state priority or priorities
they're addressing within a particular goal so that folks can see, okay, within this particular
goal, they're looking to address parent and family engagement, they're looking to address
school climate, they're looking to address student achievement, and to be able to make
those connections with a particular goal. As has already been noted, we're proposing to move the
goal analysis to follow the measurement reporting results section. And then within the increased
or improved services section, we have a couple of minor wording adjustments adding the word total
so that it's clear that the total projected LCFF supplemental and concentration grants includes the
projected additional 15% LCFF concentration grant. And you can also see there under the first of the
required descriptions that long-term English learners have been called out as being part of
the English learner student group as relates to the requirement to increase or improve services
for low-income English learner and foster youth students. So those are the changes that are being
proposed for the template itself. So then moving into the instructions, and again, the instructions
are where the vast majority of the meat of the LCAP is, if you will. So the other thing that I
want to point out here is that the template itself, this word document portion of the template itself
is not changing size. It remains seven pages. There's no changes to that.
What is increasing in size are the instructions. And part of the reason that the instructions are
increasing in size is not due to additional requirements that are being added. It's due to
the reformatting of the instructions to include bullet point lists or bullet points rather than
paragraphs. So obviously, inherent within that process, you're going to add space to the document.
So when you're looking at, oh, the template's increasing in size,
it's not increasing in size due to an increase in the content. So the first thing that I want
to draw your attention to is the comprehensive strategic planning and this inclusion of this
new phrase related to addressing and reducing disparities in opportunities and outcomes
between student groups indicated by this California school dashboard. That's, again,
a new statutory requirement as part of the LCAP, the template and the instructions. That's something
that we've woven in a number of times throughout the instructions to ensure that it's clear to
LEAs that there needs to be this focus on addressing and reducing disparities based on
dashboard performance. Moving further down, you can see that long-term English learners have been
called out, again, similar to what we just talked about in the increased or improved services prompt.
Also, we've added this specific note within the piece on establishing goals,
supporting actions, and related expenditures that address statutory priority areas and statutory
required metrics to identify that long-term English learners are a new numerically significant
subgroup within education code and that that subgroup is 15 students. So identifying that
clearly within the instructions. And then also adding that there's needs to, that the template
and instructions, the LCAP, needs to ensure that those increased or improved services
that are described within the plan, that all of those are reflected within the LCAP.
I'd also like to note just briefly here the inclusion of the word must and the deletion
of the word should. Again, this is getting back to how LEAs must use the dashboard data
in order to help prioritize how it is that their goals, their actions, their services within the
plan. So then moving to the plan summary and specifically within the successes on,
the reflections on annual performance. Here you can see that LEAs are being asked to reflect on
the annual performance on dashboard and local data. And LEAs are also, again, provided the
flexibility to address successes and challenges that are identified. In addition to this, LEAs,
the proposal here is to require LEAs to identify any school in the LEA that's received the lowest
performance levels on the dashboard, any student group within the LEA that's received the lowest
performance levels on the dashboard, or any student group within the LEA that's received the
lowest performance levels on the dashboard. The other thing that you might notice here is that
we specifically refer to the 2023 dashboard. This is not because we want to bring this back to you
every year and have you revise that year. This is because the statute requires that those actions,
that the actions that are driven by these three identified groups be consistent for the three
years of the plan, acknowledging the fact that it takes a while for change to be accomplished
within an educational system. And so not wanting to have an LEA implement an action one year,
then based on changes on the dashboard to have to then change that action,
get rid of that action, add in new actions the following year. The statute has outlined is that
based on the performance on the 2023 dashboard, LEAs are going to create specific actions
for the student groups and schools that are lowest performing. Those will be implemented for three
years, unless the LEA as part of its annual update process, as part of its goal analysis,
determines that those specific actions haven't been effective. If they determine that the actions
haven't been effective, they can then revise those actions to ensure that they are being effective.
Because at the end of the day, what we want to see is actions that are being effective in helping
students make progress and helping LEAs to achieve their goals. So these actions would be in place
for the next three years, 2024-25 through 2026-27. And at the end of that, there would be the
assessment of effectiveness to see, okay, have these been effective? If they haven't, then we
have to change them. If they have, we can continue to implement them and maintain them.
Again, that does not get rid of an LEA's flexibility to be able to change them
midstream if they identify that the actions have not been effective.
You can also see as part of that instruction that LEAs are encouraged to highlight how they're
addressing the identified needs of student groups and or schools within the LCAP as part of the
response. In terms of the instructions related to the reflections on technical assistance,
LEAs need to provide that summary of the technical assistance that's underway.
Again, there's specific requirements in here if an LEA is not eligible for technical assistance,
identified as not applicable. So then when we get to engaging educational partners,
here's one of the areas that you can really see how the formatting has changed, specifically
calling out the specific student groups that school districts, county offices, and charter
schools need to consult with as part of the development of the plan. It also specifically
calls out both for school districts, county offices, and charter schools that for those
schools receiving LCFF equity multiplier funding, they have to consult with the educational partners
at the schools that are generating those funds in the development of the LCAP and specifically in
the development of the required focus goal for each of those applicable schools so that it's
clear to everybody that the educational partner voice from those schools needs to be reflected
within the development of that particular goal. One of the other things that we're proposing to do
is to add in some hyperlinks to information for folks. So we've added in three hyperlinks
for school districts, county offices, and charter schools to link them specifically to the
requirements for the process that the LEAs have to go through prior to the adoption of the LCAP.
This is different than the legal requirement for LEAs to consult with certain groups in the
development of the LCAP. These are additional opportunities for engagement and for input from
the local community prior to the adoption of the LCAP template. Then within the engaging educational
partners section within the prompts, you can see that within prompt one, there's again a reminder
about consulting with the educational partners at schools that are generating LCFF equity multiplier
funds. And then we're proposing to remove prompt two. And then prompt three is describing how
engagement with educational partners influence the development of the adopted LCAP.
As part of this, there's one thing that we need to revise, which is to remove this piece that says
described in prompt two, since prompt two is going away. Basically, what this provides LEAs with the
opportunity to do is make those connections between the feedback that's been provided
and how that has helped shape the goals, actions, and services within the LCAP template.
LEAs continue to maintain the flexibility that they have to call those things out within this prompt.
So then moving on
specifically here to the required focus goals for LEAs receiving LCFF equity multiplier funding.
So these are the instructions that we're proposing to add related to this new requirement
that an LEA that has LCFF equity multiplier funded schools having to include a specific
focus goal within the LCAP related to those schools. It calls that requirement out and then
it goes into what those goals must address. And as previously stated, all student groups that have
the lowest performance level on one or more of the state indicators within the dashboard
has to be addressed as well as any underlying issues in credentialing subject matter preparation
and retention of the school's educators if it's applicable. So both of those aspects need to be
called out. One of the things that's important to notice here is related to the underlying issues
of credentialing subject matter preparation and retention of the school's educators is the phrase
if applicable. The intention here is not to put everybody in the state on the same level and
specifically when we're talking about our court and community school programs that are operated
by county offices of education. If you're probably aware, the majority of those programs use local
assignment options. So those local assignment options within that LEA are going to be comparable
between the different schools that that program operates. It's not saying compare your program
to a regular K-12 program and explain any discrepancies that are in there. It's looking
at each LEA on an LEA by LEA basis looking at each school within the LEA on a school by school basis.
You can see here that this is the area where there was the previous requirement for the
required goals for consistently low-performing students and consistently low-performing schools.
That's being taken out because of the change in ed code. When we get to the measure instructions
for the measure and reporting results piece, you can see the required metrics for LEA-wide actions.
Again, these are for those contributing actions that are being provided on an LEA-wide basis,
how they have to be specific metrics, one or more specific metrics to assess the progress and the
effectiveness of those actions. This is one of the three places within the instructions
that this is called out. Again, providing the LEAs with flexibility of how this is addressed.
We have also added in a we're proposing to revise the definition or the description of the metric
to specify that we that LEAs need to identify the standard of measure that's being used to
determine progress towards the goals and or to measure the effectiveness or one or more of the
actions associated with the goal. We feel that that's more specific than
indicate how progress is being measured using a metric.
So, then the goal analysis piece here is largely unchanged. It's been moved, obviously, but the
changes that come within this are specifically within the third prompt and where we're describing
the effectiveness or ineffectiveness of the specific actions in making progress towards the
goal. Effectiveness means the degree to which the actions were successful in producing the desired
result. That would be that expected outcome that's there. Ineffectiveness means the actions did not
produce any significant or desired result. Then going into LEAs assessing the effectiveness,
that assessment of effectiveness can occur based on one metric or it can be done based on a group
of metrics. But there needs to be metrics that are associated with the actions within the plan
so that folks are able to track whether or not those actions are being effective in making
progress towards the goal. And then also adding in the new requirement that beginning with the
development of the 2024-25 LCAP, LEAs must change actions that have not proven effective
over a three-year period, including the description of the reasons for the ineffectiveness
and how the changes to the action will result in a newer strengthened approach.
When we get into actions, we're adding in again the instructions related to
how an LEA that wants to identify those specific metrics for contributing LEA-wide actions would
do that. And then we've added a new heading in here for required actions because previously
there were required actions for 30 or more English learners. Now there's three different
types of required actions. The first of which is LEAs with 30 or more English learners
and or 15 or more long-term English learners must include specific actions within the LCAP.
Those actions have to at a minimum relate to the English language acquisition programs provided
to students and professional development for teachers that are working with those students.
And then we're also proposing to add in the additional instruction that if an LEA has both
30 or more English learners and 15 or more long-term English learners, the LEA must include
actions for both English learners and long-term English learners. And that's because, as we're
all aware, English learners and long-term English learners have different needs. And so it's important
to address the needs of both groups in order to improve outcomes for both groups. So that's
specifically in there. The second type of required action, as has already been
spoken about briefly, is that for LEAs that are eligible for technical assistance
and how they have to have actions, specific actions in there to implement the work underway
as part of technical assistance. So really drawing that connection between the work that's going on
as part of the technical assistance process. And again, most of the time, that's going to be
differentiated assistance with the things that are being done within the LCAP in order to achieve
the goals that the LEA has developed. And then the third type of required goal are for those LEAs that
have the lowest performance level for a school within the LEA, a student group within the LEA,
or a student group within a school within the LEA. And again, going back to what we discussed
earlier, these actions are intended to be in place for three years unless the LEA determines
that they've been ineffective. And those actions are going to then be assessed at the end of that
three-year period. And then the last of the changes within the instructions that we're proposing
is this note related to long-term English learners being part of the English learner student group
for purposes of increasing or improving services and that requirement. And so that particular note
has been added again to help LEAs remind LEAs that those actions that are being used to increase or
improve services for English learners can also be used to increase or improve services for long-term
English learners. And then the last, again, this is just the third and final place where we're
providing instructions for an LEA to identify if it's choosing to identify the specific metrics
that it's using for those contributing LEA-wide actions. This is providing them with the
instruction of how they would do it within this section of the plan. That really brings us to the
end of the major revisions to the template and the instructions. And so with that I will see
if there are any questions.
You're not allowed to ask a question.
No, I want to thank you so much, Josh. That was very clear rendering of a very complicated
situation. So we're going to open the phone line for public comment queue. And we'll put up that
slide if we can. Then I'll get comments from our liaisons. If there are clarifying questions,
we will take those. Before we go to public comment, I'm going to call a break so that we
can really be alert and ready to listen carefully to our public comment because this is a long item,
as you know, and an important one. And we thank you very much, Josh, for all of the work that
went into the revised template. We know it was an enormous undertaking. So we're opening the phone
line for public comment. Members of the public wishing to provide comment can do so in person
or by calling the telephone number and using the access code provided on the slide that's shown now.
While we're waiting for members of the public to queue up and get ready to speak,
I do want to ask our liaison, Vice President Glover-Woods, if she has any initial comments
before me, then if there are clarifying questions, we'll go to those before we take a quick break.
Thank you. And thank you, Josh, for just a very thorough walkthrough of all of the changes. And
I know there were quite a few changes that had to take place as a result of the legislation and
other pieces. And again, thank you for the walkthrough as well as the markup and non-markup
versions of the attachments. I think just in my general framing comments, and I'm going to save
other comments after we take a break and come back and hear public comment, but
I think what is quite evident is there's been a lot of work reiterating this particular document.
And as it has evolved, if you will, over the time period, I think what we're seeing is that there
are more pieces that have been included to really ensure LEAs take the time necessary
to address the very specific student needs in their population. And as a result of legislation
and other pieces, there are areas now where it's very, very clear that these areas do have to be
addressed and called out in goals, actions, and services. And while it creates quite the robust
document, and again, I'll save my comment on that after we come back from break, I hope that it puts
to bed kind of some of the myths that may have been out there on what student groups can be
addressed or cannot be addressed in the LCAP, particularly African-American students or others,
because again, it's very, very clear that if student performance on the dashboard is not at
the level that is what we would all expect, there has to be something addressed in here.
Outside of that, as I said, I'll hold some of my other comments until we come back,
but I again thank the department for the work that has been done. As we're in iteration, I'm
not sure which of the LCAP template, and let's see where we may need to go going forward. Thank you.
And I'll just add to that that I appreciate that you've done a wonderful job of being on a tight
rope between simplifying and trying to shorten the LCAP. We've had a lot of requests for that,
you know, from the field to make it understandable and useful as well as doable, while also diving
in on long-term English learners and students who are in need of particular supports of various
kinds. And so, you know, I think that we're all appreciative of the work, and nobody's head exploded,
so that's a good sign that we're off to a good discussion shortly. Yes.
Yes, and I am going to go now to clarifying questions, and then we'll take a little break
before we hear public comment. Yes, go ahead, please.
Thank you. Josh, just one clarifying question at this point. As it relates to the LCFF equity
multiplier goals, I know that it's very clearly stated that there do need to be goals in the
template for addressing the schools that are receiving those dollars and individual goals
for each school. Okay. Is there a specific way that has to be identified in the template? So,
for an example, if I'm a member of the community and I open the LCAP for a particular district,
can I easily identify in the goals section which goals are specific to the LCFF
equity multiplier funds and which goals are not specifically tied to those funds?
So, can I take down the public comment slide?
Do you need to put up another slide? Yes, you may.
So, if we go back to the instructions as part of the plan summary within the general information.
Josh, can you tell me what page you're on so I can follow? Thank you.
Let me. We are on the top of page 22.
So, as part of the requirements within the general information section, we've added the requirement
that an LEA needs to identify any schools within the LEA that's receiving LCFF equity multiplier
funding. So, first of all, as part of the plan summary, it's going to be clear to everybody
who's reading the plan what schools are receiving those funds. That way they'll know what schools
there need to be specific goals for. Then, when it comes to the actual goal itself,
as part of the description of how the LEA or why the LEA has developed the goal,
the LEA would be identifying here that this particular school is receiving LCFF equity
multiplier funds pursuant to, I can't quote the education code off the top of my head,
but, and so this goal is specifically addressed, is specifically being included to address that
requirement. Okay, and that's clear in the instructions as well, that they need to use
that language in that box. Thank you. Are there any other clarifying questions?
We're going to have discussion questions later. Yes, Member Tauri.
Thank you. I have a clarifying question on something sort of related to what you asked.
On slide 15, you mentioned section 52064E7, which was the equity multiplier list of schools
needing to have that focus goal. Is anything in, to clarify, is anything we put in the LCAP template
an interpretation of that ed code, or do you feel that what's in the template is
purely specified in the statute? And I'm asking, you gave the example of a district that has 15
schools. There are bigger districts that have more than 15 schools that are going to have to add,
you know, several schools in here. And each school does their school plan,
single plan for student achievement, which most people in the community and family members
are going to be interested in one or two schools or three schools that their individual children
are at, and would want to look maybe more closely at that particular school's goals.
So I'm asking the, just clarifying question, whether it's interpretation or...
So currently what's included within the template and the instructions related to the
LCFF equity multiplier goal requirement is only what is required in statute.
So there is a specific requirement that says for each school that is receiving LCFF equity
multiplier funds, there must be a goal in the LCAP. Thank you.
All right. Member Olken, did you have your finger up for a moment? Or are you going to save it till
later? I can save it. Thank you. Any other clarifying questions? All right. Let's just
take a five minute break so that we can be fresh and ready for our public comment. We'll return at
10 47. We will now take public comment on this item. Are there any speakers signed up to provide
public comment in person? Yes, we have five people who are signed up to provide public
comment in person. Could we have the following people please line up at the microphone in the
back of the room? Kimber Sargent, Shelly Spiegel Coleman, Shannon O'Brien, Jessica Sacco, and
Lindsay Tornatore. Thank you.
Yeah, please begin and please be sure and give us your name and affiliation for the record.
Is that mic on?
Just be sure you use your outdoor voice. Okay. Kimber Sargent, San Bernardino City Unified
School District. Good morning, President, Dr. Darling-Hammond, and members of the board.
I'd like to express my gratitude to the state board's commitment for improving and refining
the LCAP template to meet the requirements of the statutes. I'd also like to thank Mr.
Joshua Strong and his team for the support and improvement of the refinement process.
For the support and improvement of the refinement process, I asked the board to consider the
methodology for including equity multiplier funds as individual goals. As Mr. Strong mentioned in
his presentation, some districts will be heavily impacted by this requirement. For our district,
this will take our plan from three goals to 21 goals. Further, we ask that you consider the
methodology of including actions for each area, demonstrating the lowest performance on the
California dashboard for the district and at the school level and at the school level and the
student group level. Your time is up. Thank you.
Good morning, board member, President Linda Darling-Hammond, Chief Deputy Officer Mary
Nicely, and board members. Shelly Spiegel-Coleman from Californians Together and a grateful member
on the LCAP advisory group. There is a sentence in the LCAP template which has not changed from
the last three-year LCAP. The sentence on page 27 reads, LEAs are encouraged to identify metrics
for specific subgroups as appropriate, including expected outcomes that would reflect the narrowing
of any existing performance gaps. Californians Together and the Center for Equity for English
Learners have read LCAPs four times, and in our last report, we found that only five districts
out of 26 had included desired outcomes for English learners. Just encouraging districts
to have metrics to close gaps is not enough. We urge the board to follow the governor's intent
in SB 114 to address disparities and go beyond encouragement by inserting the word shall
so that metrics with aspirational growth are there for all districts. Thank you.
Good morning, and thank you to Board President Darling-Hammond and members for the opportunity
to comment. I'm Shannon O'Brien with Alameda County Office of Education. We review and approve
LCAPs for 18 districts in our county. I want to highlight a few key points from our written
comments. First, we believe that narrative response boxes could be replaced with tables
in some sections of the LCAP. Narrative makes the LCAP longer. Tables would help summarize
information and would also be more reader-friendly for families. Second, like others, we recommend
deleting prompts not explicitly required by statute. We also believe there are some areas
where fields could be inserted to highlight student outcome gaps, lessen the administrative
burden on our LCAP writers, and support new requirements in SB 114. Lastly, we recommend
that key requirements be moved out of the instructions and into the LCAP template itself.
Doing so will help improve LEA responses to the prompt as well as accessibility. Thank you.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond, Chief Deputy Nicely, and members of the board. My name
is Jessica Sacco and I'm here on behalf of Children Now. I would like to thank the CDE
and state board staff for their engagement with Children Now and the LCFF equity coalition
throughout the revision of the LCAP template. And I will refer you to the coalition letter
for our complete comments and recommendations on this item. Specifically regarding the plan
summary, I urge the board to restore the LCAP highlights section to serve the purpose of an
executive summary and take up the recommendation of the California Practitionary Advisory Group
members to include a word limit to avoid making this section too lengthy. Regarding equity
multiplier funding in schools, we recommend the inclusion of a reminder that equity multiplier
funds must be used to supplement and not supplant LCFF funding. We look forward to
continuing our dialogue with the board and department as we work on template revisions. Thank you.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond, Vice President Glover Woods, and members of the
board. My name is Lindsay Tornatore on behalf of the California County Superintendents. We would
like to share our strong support for the CDE's thoughtful recommendations that streamline the
LCAP. We see this streamline through the removal of prompts and tables, reorganization of content,
and amendments to semantics and the instructions that will increase clarity. Each of these changes
to the LCAP are improvements that will help LEAs develop a clearer, more concise, and more
meaningful document to be shared with families and communities. There is a universal theme across
LEAs that the LCAP in its current form is too complex and redundant, and this redundancy takes
away from the important information that the LCAP provides, what is actually driving improvement for
students. In closing, as those who are closest to the work of the LCAP, we ask you to please support
the CDE's recommendations that will streamline this very important document. Thank you.
That's all of the in-person comments.
That is the case. We'll move to the comments on the telephone.
Okay, I will open the phone line now. Good morning, caller ending in 5596.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning, Chair Darling-Hammond and members. Liz Guian with Public Advocates. We appreciate the
process and timeline that the department has led for public input. As Josh stated, the budget
trailer bill makes addressing and reducing disparities a new requirement, no longer an option.
For us, this means that the LCAP template and instructions should be more helpful for LEAs
on how to report on specific focus actions along three dimensions, read by district,
read by school, and read by student groups at a school site, in ways that we've recommended
in our comments with the Equity Coalition. For LEAs receiving new equity multiplier funding,
the template and instructions should help them by calling out directions to clearly outline and
explain focus goals, actions, and spending, and should remind LEAs that equity multiplier funds
supplement and not supplant other funding. These points are not clear at this point,
and this was asked for repeatedly, this clarity in the department's webinar. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, ending in 5116. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now. Good morning, Connie Choi with Public Advocates
on behalf of the Equity Coalition. Meaningful community engagement is a core mandate by statute
that must undergird the entire LCAP process. I'll echo my colleague at Children Now regarding
re-instituting LCAP highlights in the plan summary. We also recommend enumerating applicable
committees under engaging educational partners. All LCAP consumers should clearly understand who
is required to be engaged. This includes parent advisory committees, district English learner
advisory committees, as well as student committees for district serving middle or high school
students as now required by SB 997 by former Senator Pam. Restoring the insert instruction,
summarizing partner feedback will also ensure that engagement activities are not simply boxes
to check. Nearly providing flexibility for LEAs will not suffice. Parents and other stakeholders
want to see themselves in the document and show that they were heard. Thank you for your consideration.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 3004. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning, President Darlene Hammond and members of the board. Carlos Machado with
the California School Board Association. CSBA supports the changes recommended by the CDE
that help make the LCAP less complex and more accessible. These changes are identified in a
letter sent to the board by coalition that includes CSBA, other statewide organizations,
and more than two dozen districts and county offices of education. The proposed changes
include consolidation and flexibility that together would take an important step in
streamlining the template. By making the LCAP more accessible, these changes would help improve
transparency and make the document more accessible and lead to greater local engagement. We ask the
board to incorporate the CDE proposed revisions into the final template. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 3809. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning, President Darlene Hammond and members of the board. My name is Kimberly Graham
from the Kern County Superintendent of Schools. Today I voice our strong support for the CDE's
thoughtful recommendations to streamline the LCAP. The LCAP is a critical tool for our LEAs to provide
transparency and clarity to our educational partners around goals and priorities. As it stands,
the LCAP has become overly complex and at times redundant, making it challenging to navigate
effectively. KCSOS supports the recommendations put forth by the CDE, including consolidation
of the data entry and total expenditure tables, relocation of the goal analysis prompts, and
increased clarity in the LCAP instructions. These changes align with the core intent of the LCAP,
which is to drive improvement for our students through local control based on the philosophic
principles of subsidiarity. In conclusion, we urge you to embrace these recommendations from the CDE.
Let's work together to make the LCAP a more efficient and effective tool for the betterment
of our students and the communities we serve. Thank you for your time and consideration.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 8169. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning, President Darlene Hammond, Vice President Glover Woods, and members of the board.
I'm Jessica Bonduras from the Santa Clara County Office of Education, here to illustrate that the
SCCLE supports the CDE's recommendations that streamline the LCAP. The Santa Clara County Office
of Education is committed to quality supports, programs, and services of students, and streamlining
the LCAP will allow our county office and the districts we serve to better assess and present
the actions and services supporting all students served. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 8744. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning, Dr. Darlene Hammond and board members. Diana Zhu on behalf of the Association
of Calgary School Administrators. Access appreciates and supports CDE's recommendations
to streamline the LCAP. We believe that the edits, such as removal of the prompts not required in
will help provide increased clarity for readers. Moreover, we strongly encourage further streamlining
and simplification of the LCAP so it offers greater flexibility and greater accessibility
and transparency for communities and education partners. I actually look forward to collaborating
with the state and other education partners on long-term solutions to the LCAP that will result
in a meaningful plan to enhance student achievement and increase community engagement. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 7995. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, good morning. Patty Chavez from SEAL, a statewide organization partnering with hundreds
of schools to center ELs and multilingual learners and here today with a collaboration of partners.
Thank you for your dedication and enhancing ELs in the LCAP template. It doesn't look scary.
Josh and team, great presentation. It looks wonderfully enhanced to respond to the needs
of our students, families, and schools. I'd like to uplift specific language in page 22
under section reflections annual performance, which was highlighted in the presentation.
We very much appreciate the first three bullets that line out requirements.
I'd like to focus on the sentence just below that reads encourages districts. That word
encourage gives the sense that they don't need to necessarily have to highlight that the actions
actually respond to the need. If we are required to identify groups, which is wonderful,
we should also require that their actions actually address the needs. It goes hand in hand
and creates a holistic solution. We urge you to substitute the word encouraged to required
to read as follows. LEAs are required to highlight how they are addressing.
Thank you. Within the LCAP. Thank you.
Next caller ending in 6764. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one
minute. Your time starts now. Good morning, President Darling-Hammond and members of the
State Board of Education. This is Dina Wilson, Director of Accountability Support and Monitoring
at the Los Angeles County Office of Education. We support the addition of annual update template
and instructions of separate documents addressing the analysis of goals and actions
from the 2324 plan. To support streamlining of the LCAP, we recommend that census response to
the prompts about effectiveness and changes in the annual update address the effectiveness
or lack thereof of each of action and related changes. But this information does not again
need to be repeated in the encased or improved services section of the first prompt. Thank you
very much. Thank you. Next caller ending in 0516. Please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now. Good morning,
Board President Linda Harleen-Hammond. My name is Noemi Valdez. I am a retired early childhood
education director. I'd like to appreciate the board's efforts in the specific language
addressing long-term English learners. The inclusion of long-term English learners is a
significant and important change to the template and to the instructions. We also appreciate
clarifying language throughout the attachment three, including the notes on page 19 and
describing the new numerical significance of long-term English learners as a student group
and the language on page 36, specifically stating that within the required actions,
if LEA has more than 30 or more English language learners or 15 or more long-term English learners,
the LEA must include actions for both English learners and long-term English learners.
As an English learner myself and living in a community of many English learners
and significantly number of long-term English learners, this is a huge step in the right
direction for our community, for our children, and for our families. Thank you. Thank you.
Next caller ending in 6464. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond, members of the board, Deanna McCarty,
co-chair of the County Operated Student Programs Committee. We wholeheartedly support CD's
recommendations to streamline the LCAP. The LCAP's original intent was a strategic plan for LEAs,
but its complexity has deviated from that purpose. CD's proposed revisions aim to simplify and
enhance transparency, making it accessible for parents and communities. We endorse the
consolidation of prompts in the plan for engaging educational partner sections. The flexibility for
LEAs in measuring and reporting results, as well as the consolidation of data entry and total
expenditures tables, and also the clear formatting and wording and instructions.
Streamlining the LCAP is not merely about paperwork. It's about fostering transparency
and community engagement, allowing agencies like ours to better serve our diverse student
population. These changes will empower parents, educators, and communities to understand fund
allocation, support students with the highest needs, realign the LCAP with its original purpose,
and improve transparency for effectively addressing the diverse needs of our students.
Thank you for your consideration. Thank you. Next caller, ending in 8-3-3-5.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning. My name is Jeanie Keyes. I'm with the Los Angeles County Office of Education
in the LCAP State and Federal Programs Unit. We have two recommendations addressing the new
requirement for the LCFF equity multiplier funding. We recommend the LCAP template identify
the schools eligible for this funding, and that the template provides flexibility for LEAs to
best determine the additional support required at these schools, either in the school plan goals
or LCAP plan goals. While addressing supplementary actions in a focus goal for a single school or
small cluster of schools eligible for this funding in the LCAP may be reasonable,
addressing a separate goal for each eligible school in a large district will create an
unmanageable document. Identifying the eligible schools and including actions that supplement
services at school sites in focus goals in school plans would provide transparency and
accountability for LEAs and their educational partners. Thank you. Next caller, ending in
4-0-4-6. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts
now. Good morning, President Darling-Hammond and members of the board. My name is Corey Greenlaw,
and I'm calling to represent Dr. Michelle Cantwell-Cofer, the Fresno County Superintendent
of Schools. We are in support of the CDE's recommendations that streamline the LCAP.
We appreciate the work the CDE and the State Board of Education have dedicated to continuously
improving the LCAP template to address the needs of all students, and particularly for all
English learner, foster youth, and low-income students. As you consider further changes today,
we recommend consideration of the following. LEAs that have equity multiplier identified schools be
allowed to group multiple schools into a required goal if they have commonly identified needs
and planned actions in lieu of a separate goal for each school.
This will help larger LEAs who have dozens of equity multiplier identified schools.
Lastly, please consider developing an alternative template for county offices of education.
Thank you very much. Thank you. Next caller, ending in 0-3-0-0. Please state your name
and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
My name is Mary Phil Roman O'Cole from the Monterey County Office of Education.
Thank you for taking my comment, Chair Darling and board members. The LCAP template does not
specifically allow a district to include proven carryover as their budget is being presented in
the plan. We would suggest that allow inclusion of proven carryover either in one of the data
tables or allow it to be included in the instructions of the goal analysis section
so that the public is aware of how those dollars are being included. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, ending in 6-8-0-1. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi. Good morning. My name is Octavio Costello. I'm with the Los Angeles County Office of Education,
the Director of Business Advisory Services. I'm speaking on support of the recommendation
of the recommended changes to the LCAP template. Since its inception, one of the primary objectives
of the LCAP has been transparency between local educational agencies and their parent and community
partners. Understanding the complexities of a district or charter schools operations and
finance can be overbearing for those not entrenched in the day-to-day activities.
The revisions being proposed to the LCAP will enable local educational agencies to share
their continuous improvement plans in an understandable manner while remaining
steadfast to the LCAP's objective of transparency. As reviewers, the consolidation of the data entry
tables and the total expenditure table is logical and further aids in the analysis and assessment
of the LCAP. I strongly encourage the State Board of Education to improve the proposed changes to
the LCAP template. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 2331, please state your name
and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning, Chair and members. Laura Wasco on behalf of the Orange County Department of
Education. We would like to thank the Department of Education and the State Board of Education staff
for their partnership and engagement in revising the LCAP. We support the recommendations and the
revisions that will streamline and simplify the LCAP, and we believe that these proposed revisions
will make the template more transparent and more accessible for parents, families, and communities.
Thank you for all your hard work. Thank you. Next caller ending in 6645,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello, President Erling Hammond and members of the board. My name is Deborah Gorgulo,
assistant superintendent of Santa Clara County Office of Education. We strongly support the
recommendation to streamline the LCAP. The LCAP must be comprehensible for all community partners.
The removal of redundancy, clarifying instructions, and continuing to address the concerns of LCAP
riders will assist in creating a meaningful plan that will guide quality instruction for our
students. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 6647, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Leticia Garcia on behalf of Riverside County Superintendent of Schools. We're part of a
coalition of education management leaders in support of staff's proposed revisions to the
LCAP. We believe the changes to streamline and simplify the LCAP template are a step in the
right direction. However, we also believe that more needs to be done to further simplify the
template and return it to its original intended goal for the LCAP to be a strategic planning
document. We welcome the opportunity to move away from one size fits approaches where every
district in the state uses the same template. In Riverside County, our smallest district with 28
students uses the same template as our largest district with over 50,000 students, which in both
cases results in lengthy LCAP plans that are incomprehensible to all LEA partners. We know
that many of these changes require legislative efforts, and as a coalition of education
management leaders, we are committed to engaging with educational partners to achieve this goal.
Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 2669, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now. Good morning. President Darling-Hammond,
Vice President Glover Woods, and members of the board. My name is Karen Strong, and I'm the LCAP
director for San Bernardino County Superintendent of Schools. As you can probably guess by my title,
one of my primary responsibilities is working with local districts and developing and reviewing
their LCAPs. In this role, I have worked with district leaders in all 33 of our school districts
and in many of our 51 charter schools as they seek to provide transparent, cohesive LCAPs
focused on student needs. In a large diverse county where school districts ranges sizes from
less than 100 students to over 55,000 students, a statewide template must provide flexibility
suitable to each local context. We also recognize that the board and department must strike a
delicate balance between amending the template and maintaining statutory requirements. We applaud CDE
and LASO's efforts to listen to those closest to the work and make significant revisions to reduce
redundancy and improve clarity. We support these revisions and acknowledge that these changes
represent the voices of hundreds of educators, parents, and community members. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 9519. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning. Andrew Person with the Parent Institute for Quality Education.
As a community-based organization empowering over 20,000 families annually across the state to
support their children's education, including by engaging in their local LCAP process, we appreciate
the language included specifying the requirement for a superintendent to respond in writing to the
recommendations of advisory committees. While this language is not new, it has been our experience
that many DLAC committees do not receive this response from their superintendent and therefore
do not know whether their recommendations will be included in the final LCAP before it goes to their
board. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 4270. Please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Thank you. Good morning. Lee Angela Reed on behalf of the Small School Districts Association.
I want to echo the comments by my colleagues in education management and I want to reiterate
the statements made in our coalition letter. We very much appreciate and support the recommendations
of CDE to streamline the LCAP process. The number one goal of our districts is to be accountable to
our communities and for that to happen, the document, the LCAP must be meaningful. We must
go back to what we were the original intent of the LCAP and we look forward to working with
board and department staff to do so and if legislation is necessary to pursuing that.
Thank you again for the changes and we think it's definitely a step in the right direction.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 4369. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now. Good morning. My name is Sally Fox and I'm
calling from San Diego County. I represent the California Association for Bilingual Education
or CABE and as part of the LCFF Equity Coalition. We greatly appreciate the work that has been done
on this item. While we acknowledge and appreciate that long-term English learners are referenced in
various sections of the LCAP, we have a small request that this numerically significant subgroup
be inserted on page 8 of attachment 3 with the language, quote, including long-term English
learners, end quote, under the second highlighted descriptor consistent with the language in the
first descriptor on the same page as Josh stated in his excellent presentation. Thank you in advance
for your consideration. Thank you. Next caller ending in 8945. Please state your name and
affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
This is Suzanne Cooey from the Charter Schools Development Center. Good morning, members of the
board. We appreciate the important names of the LCAP and the excellent efforts of CDE staff to
manage the overly complex constraints of statutes. We reiterate that for small LEAs,
the process diverts far too much time from teaching and learning with no guarantee of
added value. We hope state leaders will push for legislation for a differentiated process
by LEA size and performance. We further express concerns about the availability of data
for LEAs to analyze effectiveness of specific actions. In particular, the dashboard indicators
themselves have layers of validity issues that we need to prioritize addressing. And also,
they're oriented to identifying equity gaps, not to analyzing where growth is happening.
California has tremendous opportunity to give LEAs helpful data that is oriented toward improvement.
And we need to create that information available to LEAs now. Thank you so much.
Time is up. Thank you. Next caller ending in 9449.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond and members of the board. My name is Martin Peroli,
representing the Tulare County Office of Education and Superintendent Tim Heyer.
We support CDE's recommendations to consolidate the LCAP template and instructions. Tulare County
is home to 43 school districts, of which 30 are single school districts operating under one or
two administrators and their boards. A streamlined plan will help districts with the process of
continuous improvement by unifying parts of the plan and giving districts greater flexibility
in how their strategic plans are laid out. Additionally, streamlining the LCAP could
greatly help in making these plans accessible to all community members in our county.
We believe firmly in the importance of the LCAP and more importantly, in the process of the LCAP
to ensure equity and access within our districts. Improving the template will help align the process
of strategic planning and community engagement with the original intent of the LCAP.
We strongly support CDE's recommendations. Thank you for your time. Thank you. Next caller ending
in 6832, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time
starts now. President Darling-Hammond and members of the State Board of Education, thank you for
the opportunity to comment. My name is Joshua Schultz. I'm the Deputy Superintendent for the
Napa County Office of Education. I've also had the privilege of serving on CDE's LCAP advisory
group since its inception. Napa COE strongly supports CDE's proposed revisions to the LCAP
template and instructions. Addressing the mandates of SB 114 in the LCAP instructions is the correct
approach as opposed to adding more unnecessary boxes and prompts. In addition, all the changes
made to streamline the template by removing redundancy are improvements. There are ways to
further simplify the LCAP template without losing any information. I will suggest just one for your
consideration today. Adding one column to the data entry table for the description of the action
would make the action table in the gold section of the template entirely redundant and thus it
could be removed. That one change would reduce the length of the typical LCAP by at least 20%.
Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 7721, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning. My name is Erika Cervantes and I am the Policy and Advocacy Manager for Alliance
for a Better Community. We're a Latino policy and advocacy organization located in Los Angeles.
We appreciate the genuine efforts to address achievements and equity gaps for
English learners, especially our long-term English learners. I'm here to call your attention to an
incongruence in the language on one of the items on the draft. On page 31, bullet two refers to
required metrics for LEAs to monitor the effectiveness of identified actions.
But bullet one states that LEAs are only encouraged to identify metrics for specific student
groups as appropriate, including expected outcomes that address and reduce disparities
in outcomes between student groups. In order for the two statements to be congruent,
we recommend the wording in bullet one be changed from encouraged to identify to shall identify
so that it reads LEAs shall identify metrics for student groups, which then match with the
second bullet point that requires metrics to be identified. These new LCAP requirements.
Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 1488, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning, President Darlene Hammond, Vice President Gov. Lover Woods and members of the
board. My name is Jennifer Hicks. I'm the Associate Superintendent of Educational Services
for the Placer County Office of Education. I'm calling on behalf of Placer County Office of
Education to share support of the CDE's recommendations to consolidate and amend the
LCAP template and instructions. We would like to thank the CDE staff for their thoughtful
considerations and revisions. As time has progressed, the original intent of the LCAP
has become more buried in the complexity and format of the current LCAP. These recommended
amendments help us to return to the original intent, which is to truly serve as a strategic
plan that is accessible, transparent, and understandable. As a county office who
provides support and assistance for 16 districts in Northern California,
streamlining the LCAP further supports our efforts to work in partnership with our districts
and helps them develop a comprehensive strategic plan that is responsive to student,
family, and community needs. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 0625,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning, President Darlene Hammond and members of the board. My name is Hannah Ma,
Director of District and School Support from Contra Costa County Office of Education.
I'm calling in to support the CDE's recommendations that streamline the LCAP.
We truly appreciate the thoughtful revisions that were proposed by Joshua Strong and the CDE,
which are really aimed to consolidate and reorganize the LCAP that fulfills the State
Board of Education's direction to streamline the LCAP. The CDE's proposed revisions do create
transparency, coherence, and readability for both the LCAP readers and the writers.
The revised LCAP highlights the importance of LEA's continuous improvement and community
engagement journey. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 01987,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning. My name is Linda Johnson. I'm a retired educator who has the privilege of
working with a couple of small school districts on their LCAP. I don't recall seeing the phrase
three-year LCAP cycle in statute, and yet it has become widely used. If, in fact, it's a process,
a cycle, then maybe that cycle should be year one LCAP three-year plan, year two,
annual update and effectiveness study, year three, annual update and summative evaluation
of effectiveness that becomes part of the basis for the new three-year plan.
Thank you and have a beautiful day. Thank you. This concludes public comment for item two.
Thank you very much. Lots of very informative and helpful
comment. And we're now open for board discussion.
Yes. Vice President Glover-Woods. All right. I'll kick us off. Again, thank you so much for
everyone who gave public comment. And again, kudos, Joshua and CDE team for, again, taking on
quite the large endeavor, if I should say, to really work on streamlining and still adhere
to everything that's caught on legislation. So just a couple of things that I wanted to
bring up and bring forward as suggestions as we move forward in this feedback portion.
One is, I'm going to try to go strategically through the template, but it may or may not
happen that way. In the section that is addressing educational, engaging educational partners,
I was looking at both of the prompts and I have to be honest, I was having a little bit of difficulty
discerning the difference between how is the engagement considered compared to the second
prompt, which is how engagement with the educational partners influence the development.
So if there's a way to clarify that for any of the LEAs that may be completing the LCAP or,
again, community members that might be reading, I think that can be helpful. And I'm sure there
is a differentiation because there are two different prompts. But again, it seemed the
language seemed to be very similar. And I realized that we were collapsing one of the prompts
to try to put two prompts in and address the prompt that was collapsed. The other is just
to lift up, and we've heard this in public comment, the area, and I believe it's in the
directions on page 21, where it says it's clear to say that LEAs need to identify various student
groups. It's page 21, I believe, in the directions. And then the closing statement says that they are
encouraged to identify highlights or how they're addressing. And I just want to share that I'd like
to see that change to a shall as well. It does require them to identify. It doesn't necessarily
encourage them to be specific on how they're addressing the needs with that language. And
while I know the large majority of our LEAs would put that in there, but I think we should be very
clear in the language that it's not a may do, it is a must do to do that. The last little piece
I'll say and then stop for other member comments is in relation to, again, recognizing the size
of the LCAP most definitely. It's exciting that the template itself is seven pages, but we know
the LCAP itself really turns into hundreds of pages by the time everything is in there. And I
know all efforts to streamline are taking place and we'll continue to tool that down so it is a
useful document for everyone as is desired. Thinking about the LCFF equity multiplier
goal that is listed, it kind of went back and forth over this, but I'll tell you kind of where
I'm landing right now is that if it is not required in statute, that there has to be an
individual goal for every school. It may be helpful to give LEAs the flexibility to combine
schools under a particular goal or goals with this particular caveat, which is in the directions,
it should first of all require that the goal be preceded with a statement saying that it is an
equity multiplier goal so that that's very, very clear to anyone reading the plan and that they
should also identify the school or schools that are targeted by that particular goal.
But being able to combine goals I think can encourage communities of practices across sites
within an LEA as well as provide opportunities for collaboration related to those specific
student groups and may also help with the size of the actual document itself.
I'm going to piggyback on those comments myself and then recognize others who want to add on
and by the way this is not an action item, this is a feedback item and we are in the process of
doing that and at the right time we'll get the recommendation slide back up
with respect to that. I also think that to the extent that it's possible to cluster schools
for the equity multiplier goals that would make a lot of sense if we can find out how to make that
comport with the expectation of the statute and to justify why they would be similar.
You might have a lot of schools that are not all similar and then there might need to be different
groupings where you say this is the literacy approach that we're using here or this is the
challenge that we're going to address there etc. But I agree with the intention to create both
communities of practice and to make it clear and simpler. There was another suggestion among the
commenters that there are some places where tables rather than narrative boxes might allow for the
communication of information more efficiently and I can see a couple of places where that would be
the case or could be the case so just want to lift that up for consideration as you continue the
very important work you're doing to make this doable. We also heard about the inclusion of
proven carryover which I think is an important thing to allow for. There was a question about
whether there could be an alternative for county offices and I could imagine why that might be
desirable but I wanted to get your feedback on that Josh whether the way in which they're
presenting their work is sufficiently different or the work is sufficiently different that
there would be any justification for an alternative form.
Well
originally if we go back into the depths of time back to 2013 when the LCFF was put into place
the original education code section 52064 directed the state board to develop templates
for the LCAP. In the intervening years the plurality of that has been taken away
and it is now template so 52064 currently requires the adoption of a single template
not multiple templates but that doesn't necessarily you know preclude that from changing.
I it you know I mean we we've learned a lot over the years in in terms of the LCAP.
I think that that to a certain extent it depends on the state's desire to have a consistent template
that could be that that folks throughout the state can interact with on a consistent level
versus the need the desire to tailor the template to the needs of of individual districts based on
their their size or scope. I just understand that the responsibilities of counties to be
different in some ways than than the responsibilities of the LEAs but I think your point is
well taken it's more food for thought and I love the fact that you're sort of representing a
learning organization here in a learning state. Are there other comments? Member Olken and then
member Lewis and then member Yoshimoto-Towery and then member Escobedo. What about this side
of the room? Okay member Petillo-Browns. Thank you. Thanks first of all for all the great and
inclusive work to get us to this stage. I really appreciate it in the public comment.
How much feedback there was about this proposed template streamlining
and becoming clearer because as somebody who's written quite a few LCAPs
I know how hard that is to do to try and fulfill all the requirements and also create something
that makes any sense and so I just really was pleased with all all the public comment that
we heard to that effect and so my my comments are sort of are related to that as a writer.
So sort of the way I think I would think about it is you have you know many audiences but if you
want if you want to simplify you have those who are writing and those who are reading
and they have different needs and so I sort of thought about it like
the instructions are really for the writers and the template is really for the readers
and so I think one of the things you commented on was that there was an intent
to put the types of things that may not apply to everybody in the instructions
to keep the template clear right and I appreciate that and so it makes me wonder
if there are ways in the instructions to call out the places where even more clearly
where things are different for different LEAs so like for example for those of you receiving
LCFF equity multiplier funds here's what you might want to consider or
we've allowed for flexibility for where you show where you show your metrics and these are the
three different places like rather than it so it's like you have it embedded in the instructions
but I wonder if they could also be called out a specific like here's some common things you
writers might be trying to go back because what I would do is I would go back and forth between
the template and the instructions and try you know and so so anyway I just I think
in the effort to keep it as clear and streamlined as possible there might be a way to really think
about the instructions a little bit more especially where things are different or there's opportunity
for LEAs to to make choices about how they want to present things. Does that make sense? Yeah. Thank you.
Linda Lewis. Thank you and I want to also echo the sentiments of my fellow board members on
your presentation and all the work that went behind trying to make the LCAP document more
transparent easier to read and easy to put together and I like member oak and this was
part of my life for seven years I love the LCAP because I the potential for the good that can come
out of it when it's put together well and has the input of all stakeholders to make outcomes
better for kids I just think it has all tremendous possibilities so I appreciate that maybe I
shouldn't say I love the LCAP but just a few comments based on what some of the callers said
and just some thoughts I have and I won't repeat try to go into depth and repeat anything that I've
agreed with my colleagues have said but again in line with member Olkins comments about continuing
to make the instructions and things and and differentiating between this is good for the
writer this is good for the reader there was a comment about from a county office of ed about
places maybe where you can replace the narrative responses more with tables and give more more
flexibility to the to the to the districts and doing that and I know you've done a great job
of that now kind of making the narrative more concise but if there's possibility where they
could have flexibility in using tables as opposed to the narrative that would be great also there
was comments about and I believe I read it in the agenda item about the equity multiplier
the funds not being supplantive okay but more supportive but if there's a way that you can
continue to emphasize that throughout the document seems like that would be helpful for districts
and also going back to the equity multiplier and the large districts and those that might be
has you know 15 or more schools that have to come up with goals there was something mentioned
about the single school plan for student achievement and I think you know there's
the work that goes on at the district level and the support that they provide to schools
within the district and then the work actually happens on the ground floor right so I don't know
if there's a way that without listing all those goals but maybe general support that the district
supplies to the district to the schools in terms of funding for literacy support or whatever they're
going to do in general but maybe the the actual goals could be listed somehow with the single
school plan for student achievement I don't know if there's if that goes against statute to even
allow that to happen with regards to the development but there was a comment about how long that section
and how intense it could be and you know every reader is not reading for every school they're
reading for their specific school and when they're involved in this single school plan
for student achievement at the at the local level at the school level then that could be more
fleshed out I don't know if that's possible but maybe something to to look into thank you
member Yoshimoto Tari thank you for stating that so eloquently uh board member lewis uh thank you
and again just want to reiterate the responsiveness and all the public comment
that came in thank you for that I think we're we're modeling at the state level what the
engagement process uh ought to be at at a local level um you said it very nicely board member
lewis I'm not going to repeat that I think I'd be interested in the alignment between the single
plans for student achievement at the school level and ultimately schools that would be listed
under the multiplier section to really possibly in the training aspect of the template to address
that fully so that there's that uh cohesiveness from the local schools to the local to the lea
and then also uh I do I want to take some moment and step back and
write what broaden the aperture a tiny bit because in this process of reviewing the template
it really became apparent to me why we have to have such an accessible I thought I didn't know
this before but an accessible dashboard with the disaggregated data uh for all students and and
student groups the status and the growth uh the training and professional development as well as
within a local control setting how we need to highlight processes and practices that are
exemplary across the state so that lea's have opportunities to learn from each other and also
simultaneously personalize for their own action plans so it's just needed to take a moment to
share that sort of reflection about how it how really beautifully it all fits together
is they come to board and individual action items so we don't often get to see talk about them like
holistically so I wanted to mention that and then lastly I did have a question I know we're
we're recommending consolidating the sections in the educational partner engagement
piece but there is some concern about removing the second prompt so how can you reiterate
because the robust educational partnership engagement so essential to the LCAP process
how the remaining prompts that we have in the current template proposed template
ensure that we retain that focus on partner engagement josh please so so within
the engaging educational partners section um and again you know taking into into account
um the the previous request to to provide better clarity between the instructions for prompt one
and prompt two um the the first prompt really relates to the process how the how the what
process is being used to ensure that the educational partners are being engaged
the the second prompt would be the description of how that engagement then influenced the
development of the plan and so there when when LEAs are responding to that it's not simply saying
the um the the feedback provided by the educational partners led to the development of this goal or
the inclusion of this action or the inclusion of these funds it's it's more based on
the following feedback provided by the educational partners by by our our teachers and support staff
who stated that that um we need to have more of something I don't know um take your pick
um we've included this particular action um and and so and so there's there's more
in when when we're going through our our LCAP development trainings and and um one of the things
that that's consistent we consistently refer to is what we what we call the through line
um and how there needs to be a a through line through the data through the identified needs
through the feedback that's that's showing up in the engaging educational partners section
through the rationale for why we develop the goals into the actions and and there should be
you know a consistent focus there on on providing this this line so that folks can see that the
direct causal nature of here's how we arrived at these particular actions
that would be described in the second prompt when it comes to the educational partner feedback
thank you I just think it's important to hear that reassurance as we streamline the tool
for use usability and also for that focus on continuous improvement I really like that
that added focus there thank you member Escobedo and then we have member Patil Bronson anyone else
want to be in the queue thank you once again I really appreciate all all this work is herculean
to say the least and and being able to balance all these new requirements also and and make it
specific and tangible so appreciate all that and you know one thing that I worry about this
document that was a real learning documents becoming more and more focused on compliance and
so I really appreciate though how you're trying to create more of a learning document and I was
just wondering in in the your goal analysis two of three were LEAs who have not shown improvement
after three years will have to kind of change their plans I know if there's a possibility of
having someone kind of do an analysis of all these LCAPs and finding out what have been the best
practices after all these years for these for specific groups you know if there's any way that
this can be distilled that you know the you know this this has worked in this specific
you know area in California with this specific group something you may want to look at and
compare to your actions right just just trying to figure out if there's any type of research
opportunity to look at best practices because we have had districts who've used the LCAP
and shown significant gains what we haven't had though is the ability to share these best practices
to other districts and as a result of that we've had more legislation coming down the
pike because there's certain groups that are not improving even though they've been doing
these actions over and over and over again so just just something to to to think about
is how do we create this learning document that it it that allows districts to continue to improve
and just wondered about the tables are they self-populated or can they be self-populated
now that we're looking at common forms of data which tables you're referring to the the the tables
within this this part of the template here the the word document portion of the template
or the tables here in the for the actions well I would say the the table that asks for
my understanding metric data okay
metrics that we already
you know through our dashboard through casp and so forth is there any way that some of this
information can be downloaded automatically or is this something that the district will
pretty much has to populate by there and I don't know I I mean just just
the I think the answer is it depends there there are certain so so within within the
state priorities there are four priorities number four four five and six within education code
section five two zero six zero d four five and six that that specify a number of of what we
refer to as state required metrics they include things like the the student progress on state
standardized test scores or the percentage of students that have completed a through g courses
or things of that nature with the exception of of certain indicators such as expulsion rate
or suspension rate or chronic absenteeism rate there's there's a wide variety of ways in which
LEAs actually report on those pieces of data some LEAs have chosen to meet that requirement by
tying it directly to dashboard indicators some have chosen to tie it directly to student progress
within related to standardized test scores some have chosen to so because because of the
differences that exist there in the way that LEAs just in the nature of providing a flexible document
um there's there's relatively few of these you know things like these metrics that could be
pre-populated um in in a meaningful way that would relate to all LEAs throughout the state
in order to have something like that in place there would have to be a much more prescriptive
um implementation of how each of those state required metrics was was described within the
plan and then that also doesn't include any local metrics that they're also including
such as informative assessments or things like that thank you
all right um member patilla bronson and member roscoe gonzalez and i should let you know that we
have planned for one more item before lunch um so i know this is fascinating
but maybe we can get quickly to the point um okay so i will do this rapid fire i'll
reiterate thanks um for the the balancing act that you are undertaking
and just want to underscore three points that some of our colleagues have already made
page 27 movement from encourage to shall the request for language reiterating supplement
rather than supplant and the possibility of using tables instead of narrative requirements
wherever possible what a great role model
member roscoe gonzalez and then member rodriguez thanks kim actually you just mentioned about the
shell comment so that um i just want to reinforce your comments i think i believe exactly that so
thank you josh also to your team for the revisions that improve the comprehensiveness of the plan and
address disparities and opportunities and outcomes among student groups and ensure technical
assistance eligibility with all these revisions how will the cd ensure that the lea's have
sufficient guidance and support to implement the revised out kept requirements effectively
i just want to kind of remind our lea's that the cd has a plan for that yeah um so for
i forget how many years um we've we've been doing a series of webinars um we refer to them as
tuesdays at two um but they actually occur on tuesdays at two and thursdays at three
because people remember that kind of thing and um but but for for this particular rollout
assuming that the um that the board adopts the revised template in november based on the timeline
that was already provided our plan is to provide webinars on on tuesday and thursday
with with a couple of breaks off for thanksgiving and and good behavior
for well a series of eight total webinars that start off with an introduction to lcff for anybody
that's new out there in the field then go into the template and the instructions then we spend
we'll we'll spend an entire webinar talking about the engaging educational partners
requirements and and that piece of the plan we have another one related to goals and actions
in general we'll have one specifically for the lcff equity multiplier goals and then two webinars
that are that specifically go into the requirements to increase or improve services
for low-income english learner and foster youth students and then in addition to that one we also
do one on the local indicator process as part of the dashboard since my office supports that as
well so so those will span november to december of of this coming year in addition to that
um lea's will also continue to to receive support from their county offices of education as as they
um have and the county offices will will also work would be working with them to ensure that
they have access to all of the new information and and that that's being implemented
implemented
so i also want to thank you and i want to thank our community partners who have engaged so much
in this process and i will um just echo um my support for what's already been said
but i also want to make an observation as you were going through the reflective process and
then the adding what are we going to do about it right you know like so these are the students
especially the long-term english learners which i i'm so glad to see highlighted and
get the attention that um they deserve because that's been an enigma for a lot of us how are
we going to support our long-term english learners but i was reminded of um as a national board
teacher the architecture of accomplished teaching which is a reflective process of setting goals
revisiting them this isn't working what am i going to do and coming back and back to this and so
i love the mindset of um this process of inviting our district into our classrooms
so that we can see how we can support all of our students together thank you
so in regards to the engaging educational partner section um within the instructions
i was wondering if it was possible if lea's serving secondary sites specifically
could be required to discuss how student input was incorporated within those two prompts
um and i say this because i'm in contact with many of the student board members across districts in
the state and what i hear is that a lot of students aren't aware of the l cap or that they
don't know that they have a say and oftentimes during this process students are asked for input
at the very end when decisions are close to being finalized instead of being a part of the process
and that decision making all the way through um and i i just i don't know if any students know
that they're even considered educational partners so if there could be that requirement that lea
specifically focus on student input within the educational engagement prompts um and not just
have it be generalized i think that could really help students know that they are supposed to be a
part of that process but i just wanted to bring that up just so that can be considered but i
really do appreciate all of the work that you've done and you created a very comprehensive presentation
that was accessible to me so i really do appreciate that
um
and on that oh did you want to make a comment member just briefly i know we're trying to get to the
other item thank you for all the work on this and i agree with um the comments made so far i'm also
so happy we've moved away from uh the less acceptable uh phrases of moving towards educational partners
and letting go of the old terminology of i don't even know what it is but we moved away from that
so thank you for for for doing that all right great and on that note uh we thank you very much
for all of this work uh this is a information item and an input item and so we have given you
plenty to chew on uh beyond the very important work that's already been done thank you
uh and we will uh go ahead and continue on with um our next item uh which is uh the um item on casp
uh and lpac and i've got to find my uh the california assessment of student performance
and progress and english language proficiency assessments item three uh request for approval
of the proposed 2023 california assessment of uh student performance and progress
and lpac score reports and an update on assessment program activities
this is something we have been talking about before so we hope it will be
pretty expeditious uh process of decision making and mal vang will be presenting the item
wow it's nice to see you please begin thank you
oh good afternoon uh chief deputy nicely president arlen hammon vice president glover woods
and our esteemed board members uh i'm mal vang director of the assessment development and
administration division at the california department of education under the instruction
measurement and administration branch branch
so the item before you today is an action and an information item however before i go
onto the specifics of the item i would like to just share with you an important transition
in the assessment development and administration division um here it is uh linda hooper dr linda
hooper she's our associate director uh she retired on august 31st um 2023 and she has spent uh 33
years with the state and 17 of those years were at the department of education and um she has
led the implementation of the statewide assessments um through such trying times and changes such as
when we did the transition from the paper test to the computer-based assessments uh she was
instrumental in bringing the science assessments from the conceptual stage to our operational stage
and she was always um ensuring trying to ensure and work with the contractors to make sure that
we develop assessments that are of the highest quality possible and accessible to all students
i just want to let you all know that she has made such lasting contributions to our
statewide assessments in california i would just want to give her a few words of congratulations
she couldn't be here today but you know we just want to honor her thank you and then on to my
presentation in this presentation i will cover the following um we will provide an overview
of the california department of education's recommendation for approval and then i'll go over
briefly the assessment updates for the interim assessments as well as the national international
assessments and finally we'll return back to the recommendation for the state board of education
action so there has been uh an update to the recommendation um that was provided in the item
and item three as written due to feedback from the education coalition we were able to add
some language to the recommendation to allow for the edits to be made and i will share that
next i believe that brooks may be um bringing you a paper copy because it's kind of hard to see
and to fit all on a page so the recommendation reads the california department of education
recommends that the california state board of education approve the proposed revisions
to the california assessment of student performance and progress and the english
language proficiency assessments for california or alpac student score reports or ssrs as provided
in attachment to to be implemented starting with the 2023-24 administration
that portion was what was written in the item the addition in addition the cde recommends that the
sbe delegate authority to cde staff subject to approval of the sbe executive director
to make the following types of necessary clarifying technical edits to the ssrs
such as including examples of communication modes in the alternate alpac ssrs and inserting
language in the summative alpac ssr to make the connection between the overall score combination
of two performance areas to the performance areas on the following page if feasible in multiple
languages
okay and we'll come back to that later so in this portion
i'll go over the recommended ssrs for the the casp or the california assessment of student
performance and progress and the english language proficiency assessments for california or alpac
i'm just going to highlight some of the goals of the
student score report redesign the changes and the enhancements to the student score reports
so a quick timeline overview during the july sbe meeting we shared the timeline of the redesign
effort that included a thoughtful iterative process through which the cde and our testing
contractor ets sought feedback and since the july meeting ets and cde have explored and
responded to the feedback received today i'm presenting the proposed redesign ssrs for approval
so if the board approves the proposed revisions today the cde will work with ets to implement
the redesign student score reports beginning with this year's administration the 2023-24
one of the main goals of the redesign is to improve the reporting of test results provided
to students parents and guardians and include actionable information so the redesign score
reports provide an appropriate level of information for the summative assessments
and they do not provide the granular information that perhaps uh interims or other assessments
may provide so to summarize the changes the revised student score reports include score
history section changes performance areas include that include the composite claim reporting
for the english language arts or and literacy or ela and mathematics assessments the essay
performance scores for the smarter balance ela writing or written extended response the lexile
and quantile measures are integrated into the report and the score comparisons or we'll have
the student score compared to the school average and the state average
i will show each of those revisions in the following in the formats in the next slides
so the student score history section will be available for grades four through eight for
the smarter balance ela and mathematics the california alternate assessments or caas for
the ela and mathematics and the california spanish assessment score history will be
available for kindergarten through grade 12 for summative alpac and summative alternate alpac
since um science is administered in grades five eight and once in high school the cde and ets
is looking into uh the different options to include the score history in the near future
when california began um using the adjusted test blueprint in the 2020-21
year the ela and mathematics claim scores were removed from the ssrs
smarter balance has provided the new composite claims for use with the adjusted test blueprint
for the ela and math assessments and these composite claims will be provided as the performance
areas
for the smarter balance ela and math assessments beginning with again the school year of the
2023-24 the performance areas results are reported as um above standard near standard or below
um above standard near standard or below standard
the essay performance scores for the first time in our casp program parents and students and
guardians will have additional um information such as the this one the essay performance scores
these essay um scores indicate how well students perform in the smarter balance
um ela writing response extended response so in this example the student responded to a
narrative i know it's kind of small but they responded to a narrative essay and the scores
are provided in the categories for a narrative of the genre of narrative um in the categories of
organization or purpose evidence or elaboration and conventions
lexiles and quantiles in the previous administrations a student's lexile and
quantile measures were provided in a separate report from the smarter balanced
ela and mathematics assessments with the if if the board approves these revisions the students
lexile and quantile measures will be provided within the same student score report as the
smarter balanced summative ela and mathematics test results this section will also include a
link to the lexile and quantile hub which is a resource provided specifically for families
the revised student score report format includes the state or the school and state comparisons for
the smarter balanced ela and mathematics the california science test or cast and the california
alternate assessments for ela mathematics and science so the column um your child's score shows
your child's score shows the student's score for the current administration and then in this example
it would be the 23 24 administration for the for those particular assessments the school average
column and the state average will be calculated using the average of the 20 21 22 and the 20 22
23 administrations
next i'll present the student score reports in their entirety starting with the casp ssrs then
followed by the lpac these are rather small but you'll be able to zoom out they were also
attached in the item as i mentioned earlier the ela mathematics and science results will be
consolidated into one student score report while this extends the length of the student score
report the improvements to the electronic delivery for example directly to the parent portal if an lea
chooses will accommodate this consolidation this slide includes the first four pages of the ela
mathematics and science report and all students in grades three through eight and 11 taking the
casp test will receive pages one through four and for their ela and mathematics results and this is
an example of a fifth grade student report next students who take the cast or the science test
a california science test will receive a fifth page of their ssr with their science results
and this slide shows the cast results for fifth grader
california alternate assessment student score report this slide includes the results the
scores for the alternate assessments all students in grades three through eight and 11 taking the
california alternate assessments will receive pages one through three and then students taking
the california alternate assessment for science will receive the fourth page and this example
again is a fifth grader who took the california alternate assessment for science and all the other
ones as well this slide includes the student score report for the california spanish assessment
and i'll point out not earlier but now i'll point it out in the
first page of each student score report you'll probably see this little qr code on the lower
left corner parents and guardians or students or anyone can scan the qr code with their device's
or a third-party app to access that additional information about the tests and currently the
qr code and the link point to our california's starting smarter sites that are for families
about how to understand their score reports then the english language proficiency assessments for
california's student score reports the slide represents this the student score report for the
summative lpac just two pages for fifth grader as well and then this particular one is for the
summative alternate lpac student score report two pages
and we're also providing the initial lpac student score reports which
is also consisted on two pages
and then this slide represents the student score reports for the initial alternate lpac
and due to the timeline of for the design effort the student score reports for the initial lpac
and the initial alternate lpac will be used beginning in the 24-25 administration because it
does take that test already began in july right and here we are in september so we're going to
use that current one for now for the school year and then implement it in the new school year
so that brings us to the through all the revised student score reports
and i just have one more slide and we do have a number of assessment program updates
there's some for that are happening for this school year and that includes our
interim assessments for the smarter balance ela mathematics the interim assessments for the
cast and the l path and then an update on national or international assessments
pretty much to help introduce educators to this to our state offer interims the cde has prepared
a variety of resources and professional learning opportunities and more of these information
about the interims and resources and trainings can be found in that our september item
furthermore the item also provides an update on the upcoming national assessment of student
educational progress of national assessment of educational progress or nape involving students
in grades four eight and twelve and about 800 schools in california and then there's the teaching
and learning international study or talus which is an online survey that will be provided to
principals and teachers that will be offered to about approximately 30 schools and that kind of
sums up this particular item and at this point i will pause and i'll be happy to address any
clarifying questions or would you like me to go to the to the public comment we'll put the slide
up for public comment so people can queue up while we ask clarifying questions so we'll now open the
phone line for public comment members of the public mission to provide comment may do so in person or
by calling the telephone number and using the access code provided on the slide that's shown now
um and then while we're waiting for members of the public to call in i'll ask member of osco
gonzalez she has any initial comments before me and then if there are clarifying questions
we'll get those before we go to public comment okay so thank you mao and to your team this
um comprehensive redesign and reporting enhancements to the casp and lpac students
score reports driven by valuable feedback from students parents educational agencies and partners
prioritize the clarity of test result reporting and ensure timely access to results for students
and families the revisions made to language terminology and graph graphical representations
are aimed to enhance at enhancing understanding and usability for all stakeholders furthermore the
introduction of interim assessments for the california science test and the english language
proficiency assessments represents a significant step in providing educators with valuable tools
to support student learning these enhancement enhancements will contribute to a more effective
and equitable assessment system in california ultimately benefiting our students and their
educational journey i want to really express my appreciation for the inclusion of essay performance
scores in the smarter balance ala writing extended response assessment the availability of these
scores is a valuable addition to our assessment toolkit by providing these results and detailed
information on each category scored for the genre this reports offers a deeper understanding of
student performance it not only highlights overall proficiency but also allows educators to identify
specific areas of strength and areas that may require additional attention this level of
transparency and granularity in reporting empowers educators to tailor their instruction
to meet individual needs effectively and also supports data-driven decision making
at both the classroom and the administrative levels so thank you so much for all the work
that your team and the department has done on this and i will just plus one to member
roscoe gonzalez's comments and simply as a former english teacher a high school english teacher the
elevating of the writing scores to me is extremely important writing is thinking thinking is
writing and reading and writing are interrelated very strongly so it's a very good statement to be
making that more visible in the process along with all of the other clarity and accessibility
and usability that the score reports are you know bringing for parents and the public
we have time if they're clarifying comments and then questions and then we'll go to public
comment and then we'll have discussion and address the motion any clarifying questions
all right i think we're going to go to public comment and are there any public comments in the
room somebody's getting up it looks like shelly
she's sure mine is real quick i just want to shelly spiegel colman californians together mines real
quick i just want to say a special thank you to mao who in 10 minutes pulled together a huge team
from the department of education for us to talk about the student report form on lpax
and the work we did together was exemplified by what she presented we really appreciate the time
and the sincerity that they took to the task so thank you so much great and now we can move to
any online phone comments yes good afternoon caller ending in 5596 please state your name
and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
now looks like they dropped next caller ending in 8256 you have one minute your time starts now
hi this is robert mandarin from children now i also wanted to build on shelly's comments and
thanking mao the cd staff and the and the ets staff for meeting with us on short notice
to work out language around clarifying language in the lpac and the alternative lpac
also super excited about the comprehensive process that these reports went through and
about the future of parents having access to quantile and lexile scores helping them match
their students with appropriate books over time so thanks so much for all the hard work thank you
next caller ending in 7704 please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time starts now
hello board members my name is sandy mendoza with families and schools and for over 22 years we have
been deeply invested in building the capacity of low-income immigrant families and communities of
color to navigate the intricacies of our public school system we deeply appreciate the work that
cd staff has put into developing the lpac report forms these forms play a pivotal role in ensuring
parents are kept informed they can actively participate in their child's english learning
journey and we particularly want to thank cd for collaborating with the coalition by agreeing to
make the necessary changes to the form so that parents can better understand the progress
their child is making in learning english thank you for your dedication to fostering
and inclusive and supportive educational environment for all students we look forward
to our continued collaboration in ensuring that every child has the opportunity to succeed thank
you so much thank you next caller ending in 5596 please state your name and affiliation for the
record you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon liz gian with public advocates i just want to join my partners in the lcff equity
coalition thank you dr bang and her colleagues at the department for being responsive to our
suggestions for changing the student report to help parents understand it better thank you very
much thank you this concludes public comment for item three all right i'd just like to note the
continuing theme this morning about gratitude to the cd staff for always knowing they're being
responsive to public input and open us for board discussion
and we can take a motion if you're you know if you have no questions
is there any discussion is there a motion
move the recommendation all right and is there a second all right uh thank you very much
um any further discussion of the motion all in favor say aye and raise your hand
all in favor say aye and raise your hand aye any opposed no any abstentions motion passes
yes you knew that this was between you and lunch so
we are now going to adjourn for lunch and we will reconvene at a half an hour let's say
105 give ourselves a little grace whoo i know
oh don't get too excited
live it up
all right welcome back we are now going to our consent agenda regular items four through seven
and i understand that member yoshimoto tauri will need to recuse herself from this vote
we will now open the phone line for the queue for public comment on consent items four through seven
and we need the slide up there there we go members of the public wishing to provide comment on
consent items four through seven may do so in person or by calling the telephone number
and using the access code provided on the slide that's shown now are there any speakers signed
up to provide public comment in person no speakers all right and are there any people
queued up on the telephone line there are no callers in the queue all right given that there's
no public comment i will ask for a motion on consent for items four through seven
member louis louis thank you do i have a second thank you very much show of hands for all those
in favor say aye any opposed all right any abstentions i guess not motion carries item eight
is the update on the implementation of the integrated local state and federal accountability
and continuous improvement system the action to implement the 2023 dashboard work plan and
essa amendments and updates on continuing work for future dashboards and i will let
cindy kazanis tell us what the recommendation is when the time comes because it's a really long one
and it will be presented by cindy and kimberly mundeck of the cde take it away thank you president
darling hammond and members of the board i'm cindy kazanis i'm the director of the analysis
measurement and accountability reporting division this is another long item but this is the
culmination of not only a year's worth of work but in some instances four years worth of work
and so just to give you a brief overview of what we're going to be talking about today
we have several revisions under consideration for the dashboard which will be out december 15th
so we do have new statute we are very excited that we have a date that we can all point to
and be ready for talking about how we can help schools and we can talk about the state of our
schools and our districts you heard a lot this morning about how the data from the dashboard
is used from l cap and so i'm hoping to be your throughput on the updates that we're again proposing
for for this year and work that we're continuing on some of these updates do require that we amend
our state plan for the every student succeeds act for some of you this may be the first time you've
taken action to formally amend the ss state plan it has been well over a year in the past we have
had these one-off amendments because of the covet provisions that have been provided by the u.s
department of education so we'll give you just a brief overview of those items that will that are
proposed amendments to the state plan and then we'll conclude with what we always do which is
the great work of the team to get out the word about the dashboard and opportunities to learn
more about our data and about california students so the item recommendation i think is is up to eight
eight parts or seven parts so just bear with me i'll just do this once and then in the next go
around we'll just refer to the slides so we are recommending approval of the english learner
progress indicator specifically there's three pieces that will bring this into a full indicator
first cut points for the english learner progress indicator change second we establishing our five
by five color scheme for the english learner progress indicator performance colors and third
inclusion of the summative alternative l pack in the english learner progress indicator for the
college career indicator we have a recommendation around the removal of non-registered pre-apprenticeship
measure from the college career indicator beginning with this school year and then there is a slight
update because of the college career indicator and the lack of two years of data to adjust the
eligibility criteria for differentiated assistance and then the last pieces are around adopting
objective criteria for the priority one for our teacher assignment monitoring outcomes
from this prior school year and then finally a couple of links around data that we are bringing
onto the dashboard partly because of your recommendations others because of requirements
from the legislature and we've already talked about the amendments to the state plan we always
put this language in that we recommend that you make the adoption pending the spe executive
director approval of final revisions because there sometimes are some topographical issues
and necessary non-substantive clarifying edits so with that in mind we will get started with
attachment one and you will hear from kim in in a bit but we're going to go through the english
learner progress indicator which is really really one of the most important things that we're we're
doing today for accountability and i would ask for direction from president darling hammond on
winter pause for clarifying questions because this is a bit of a long item so just to frame
the work and welcome to our new student on on the board the indicator for our english
learner progress metric looks at progress for english learner students towards achieving
english proficiency this is based on english learner students taking our our statewide assessment
the english language proficiency assessment for california or lpac which measures how will they
know and understand english so this is only for current english learners when this measure was
first adopted that the board back in 2016-17 wanted to include reclassified students and that
is was was deemed to be not in compliance with every student succeeds act so some of the things
you're going to see today we're looking back at old data that did include rfebs this current measure
does not and so that we are thankfully we're back in compliance with federal law but as a result
there are some some tweaks to that that when we're we're part of this 2017 version that are not part
of this current version so the metric uses needs two consecutive years of these lpac results to
calculate status and then a third year to calculate change so it's a very unique indicator in the
sense that we need that the three years of data so just briefly on the history again when i
mentioned 2017 is when we first had it on the dashboard and that was with our old assessment
the california english language development test or selt which has been retired and then i also
have already mentioned i mean included our reclassified fluent english proficient students
that was removed from from that metric in 2018 we shifted that assessment from the selt to the
lpac and so we had been in transition 2018 2019 2019 again formula changed to exclude those rfib
students to become in compliance with federal law so we have in 2019 produced the dashboard
had status only and then we had covid and so we had a break and reporting on the dashboard for
two years we've now had two years of data we're just having a third year this year and so that's
why we are finally bringing on change cut points so back in march when we presented our work plan
we talked about this being a part of a part of your decision points for the year specifically
where we're asking you to do today's set the change cut points for the english run of progress
indicator based on those three years of data we are using data from 2021 2022 and preliminary
data from this year so you're actually seeing data runs that we've done with a file that
incorporates students who took the summative lpac between february 1st and may 9th
so in order to calculate the english runner progress indicator and there's a couple of
different steps and so i i will not spend a bit not too long on this but just want to make sure
that we're familiar with the methodology and how we we do this this work to establish current
current status year we look at the results that we saw from 2023 and we also want to make sure
we have established we have working out the results from 2022 we calculate change by subtracting
2023 from 2022 or 2023 from 2023 you can see that in bullet two and then finally we do a
distribution of those cut points from the leas that had a minimum number of 30 students of which
we have 1149 leas and just in case you're keeping track of numbers janet this morning said we had
a thousand leas for purposes of the dashboard we consider charter schools to be leas too so really
it's it's well over 2000 potential leas that would be would have a minimum number of students
of 30 but because english learners are concentrated in certain areas we're down to 1149
so these are the distributions that were done by the team and shared not only with our technical
design group but other policy groups that you're going to hear about in just a moment
you can see the breakdown of by the percentiles of where we get to an even split at 50
looking at change from prior year to current year the proposed change levels that we are asking you
to establish today are for the five levels that we use starting with decline significantly and then
to the highest which is increased significantly and the next slide does a really nice comparison
of the 2017 change change cut points in the 2023 keep in mind the 2017 has a larger population
because we were able to include rfps or we chose to include rfps and later had to remove them
so this is very similar in keeping with what the board first established back in 2017
so as far as feedback we have been talking about this and sharing this information with educational
partners we always have several steps that we do when we engage with our educational partners
first we take it to their technical design group because it doesn't meet the design or the technical
standard if there's no use in shopping it to anybody else or sharing that with anybody else
and so the technical design group provided feedback and recommended that we adopt the
we adopt the change cut points that we presented to them which you see today we do have an english
learner progress work group and there was not consensus on the methodology but did note again
that we followed the established methodology process for setting cut points that is in line
with our other state indicators and then the californ research advisory group or cpag which
advises you the state board of education on issues related to title one was very positive
about the proposed methodology so the second part of this adoption is adopting a color scheme
for the indicator and the work plan through that work plan process we did simulations on two
different two different grids first the traditional grid which we use for the majority
of our indicators with the exception of graduation rate and academic graduation rate has a floor that
we're required to use of 68 percent so when you look at the five by five grid for graduation
it's all right at the bottom academic uses what what the board adopted back in 2017 which was the
five which is a balanced grid is what we're calling it that was adopted in part because
there was a lot of a lot of instability in the model for the traditional model and so the the
prior probably the prior board i'm trying to think if any of you were still were on that at that time
did adopt to change the color scheme so what you see for the traditional color scheme is this
sort of even distribution of of four reds at the at the bottom left hand corner and on the top
right hand corner four blues and then an even distribution of the remaining colors throughout
the five by five color scheme the balanced color scheme is is is unique in that you only see two
colors on each of the status rows so for the bottom very low you see red and orange whereas
if we go back to the prior one you see red orange and yellow and so for the balanced color scheme
especially for the academic indicator this did lead to again greater stability in the model
this is the simulated results from again the preliminary data from 2023 and then prior data
from 2022 and 2021 of what colors could potentially look like for the lp for the 2023 dashboard
so for having again 1815 in our end size we see we see the even distribution between
you know the distribution between each of these that are a little different so you
for the traditional you see a greater or you see the equal number of of districts or districts in
in the blue whereas for the red you see a bit higher almost or over double in the red
so from the the when we start at the top they're even when we go to the green you start to see
those numbers being pushed down on the traditional side to to yellow to orange and to red
we also did additional simulations to see what the impact would be on our small local educational
agencies which of which we have an end size of 631 again this includes charter schools
we also looked at non-small schools excluding charter schools and then finally small schools
excluding charter schools and this is these are the the configurations so if we go down to the
bottom 631 lea's small lea's total we see they they start off at the same with
even distribution between the two models of 114 and then end up with again almost double in
in the red on the traditional same look and comparison for our small schools with
excluding charter schools with an end size of 3876 again pretty much even distributions when
we start at at blue and then subsequently you see how things start to fall out between
green yellow orange and red
for our non-schools non-small schools comparison excluding charter schools again same kind of look
and feel with the blues being exactly the same and then the distribution changing as you get
down through the colors with red being double for our traditional five by five so what does this all
mean what we found and what the technical design group acknowledged was that both models were
technically sound they did have a recommendation to adopt the balance color scheme because it
seemed like a more stable way of of looking at schools and districts the english under progress
work group did not have a consensus on the preferred color scheme i think they were trying
to wrap their their heads around it but by the time we got to the californ patricia's advisory
group this is all in a three-week period and really the the tone had shifted towards the traditional
color scheme and specifically because it gave more weight for change on the overall performance
color and so that is what we are recommending to you today is adoption of the traditional color
scheme so with that in mind this is the traditional color scheme just as a second look at it
and the final piece of the english learner progress indicator is inclusion of our summative
alternative lpac and we are so delighted to have this very small group of students
finally being seen on the dashboard so the work plan included are looking at the data the first
time that we've had an opportunity to look at this information for potential inclusion on the
dashboard of students who took the summative alternate lpac these are our most severely
cognitively disabled students who are also english learners so these students what we needed to do
was figure out a methodology that would work to determine that a student has made progress on
or rather in english language development on the summative lpac from one year to the next
and figure out a way to incorporate the students and have them represented in the 2023 dashboard
for this indicator there were three options that were reviewed and developed the first being the
performance level method second the scale score method and third the combination of both scale
score and the performance level method so for option one we were looking at whether or not a
student simply moves up the performance level or remains at the top level which is level three
to show that they've made progress there was if you know the way that the english learner progress
indicator was established around the summative lpac they actually split levels and there was
not a recommendation to do that specifically because of a lack of data and technical
information this is a a subgroup that is you know less than 25 000 students and so we are still
learning about this test as as it's being administered throughout the years so with option
the methodology that was considered is if a student increases their score by 10 points
or remains at level three that would show that they've made progress the example that you see
on the second bullet is a student that scores 325 in 2022 and 438 in 2023 would have made
13 points in progress and would have count would then be counted as making progress
the third option and I think came as a hybrid out of these two which was to combine both of option
one and option two and what was what the recognition that option three provides is that certain
students were excluded from making progress on either option one and option two and so this gave
them the opportunity to be seen and included as being making progress so again bringing those
two options together option three shows that a student or rather includes a student who moves
up a performance level or remains at level three and then a student who has an increase
in 10 scale score points from the prior year the simulations for this these different options
show that at the very bottom for option three we have the largest percent or largest number of
students who took the summative lpac they were able to show that they had progressed
and I forgot to mention in the beginning these are all matched scores so you would have had to have
taken the test the prior year and of course the current year or prior years rather and current
year for both the summative and for summative lpac and then the regular lpac so that's why you see
these numbers as being you know just around six six thousand on the did not progress and then
the forty six hundred again these are preliminary results and so we don't have a full full file
represented here but we are recommending option three again being able to provide as many
opportunities for our english learner students who take the alternate assessment to show progress
and as far as our our educational partners the technical design group I have these out of order
from my prior slides but the technical design group did support option three because of this
two paths to demonstrate proficiency and progress the english runner progress work group didn't have
a consensus on the three options I think this was a this was a struggle for them to really wrap their
heads around and then finally our california nutritionist advisory group or cpeg
didn't didn't really provide feedback again this was I think this has been a difficult topic for
for folks to to understand understand the actual assessment and then understand
the inclusion rules so with that in mind I will turn it to President Johnny Hammond if you want
to take clarifying questions on the three pieces of this indicator from the board I do think it's
wise to take clarifications as we go along are there any clarifying questions that you did a
very good job explaining it thank you cindy I think we're all with you at this point then I'm
going to take a short break and you're going to hear from him okay
hi everyone Kimberly Montaigne administrator of the accountability development and policy
analysis unit thank you so much cindy I'm going to walk through the pile of work in our 2023 work
plan that we contributed this year for the college slash career indicator as a reminder the college
slash career indicator measures how well districts and schools are preparing its graduates on a set
of college and career measures and we'll go over exactly what that entails in a further slide and
the base of those students for the cci are the same as those that are included in our current
graduation rate indicator so that includes both students who graduated in either four years or
five years so our four or five combined rate is what compiles the students that we're looking at
and the performance of the of them in their graduating year
the measures that are included in the college career measure
consist of both college measures and career measures and you can see the lini there for
college measures presently the state board has adopted the following advanced placement exam
ib exams college credit courses a3d completion or uccsu readiness the state seal of bi-literacy
and performance on the smarter balance summative assessments additionally for career measures the
state board has adopted cte pathway completion leadership military science pre-apprenticeship
work state and federal job programs for our task schools as well as transition classroom
and work-based learning experiences for our students with disabilities
this year we set out with an ambitious work plan to continue to develop with our educational partners
new career measures and review the indicator for continuous improvement
this work actually started pre everyone who's sitting on this board right now
there is a specific request made to add additional metrics per the career side right we had a very
college heavy metric system so we were looking to see how we can introduce additional career measures
in it so specifically we explored the inclusion of four career measures we've been gathering data
on those four since 2020 which are internships student-led enterprise simulated work-based
learning as well as arm services vocational aptitude battery tests or as fab
additionally we have been ongoing and exploring this work specifically
as president harman knows around civic engagement and capturing the information that our students
are completing with regards to the seal of civic engagement as well as exploring industry
certifications and then finally what we do every year is looking through and reviewing current cci
career measures to determine if any adjustments are needed so this was all involved in this work
the work plan for this year starting with the first large task was reviewing these four new
career measures as i said which the work of collecting that data began prior to everyone's
service on the board and has been ongoing through the covid epidemic and through calpats entire time
now we need at least two years of data in order to be able to validly approve any career measure
coming into the dashboard and following the review of this work and in completing the analysis of
data we essentially come through and ask if the measure should be included in the cci is it
something that we continue want to include and following that up with that if the answer is yes
what are the prepared and approaching prepared criteria that need to be included for graduates
and since the majority of the data collection unfortunately occurred during the covid 19
pandemic the cd also asked educational partners whether an additional year of data collection
which actually just finished up in 2022-23 should be reviewed and analyzed prior test preceding
with further analysis and answering those questions and adding these measures to the cci
specifically our educational partners replied that for cdg they recommended to wait along with
the cci work group and the cpac agreed with those recommendations and to review the 2022-23 data
before making any further decisions therefore at this time we have no further action or request
of action on including these four new measures within the cci this year for the 2023 dashboard
as far as exploring civic engagement industry certifications we continue to engage with the
continue to engage in conversations with our work group and the civic engagement work group as well
as the technical design group on necessary data points necessary for us to add to further data
collections in the future so we will be proceeding with that as we move into the next cal pad cycle
and then additionally we have looked through industry certifications and have continued to
explore how we can integrate these or if we can integrate them based on feedback from lea's that
currently have these programs in in operation for their students
and then finally this is the big one and where action is is being requested
is a review of the current cci measures and after a technical review of the current measures within
the cci the career technical education practitioners proposed that they remove
non-registered pre-apprenticeships from the measure and the reason behind this came from
multiple lea's as well as staff here at cde because specifically there's no clear metric
to discern what occurs within these programs at the lea's and there's really no accountability
because these these programs are not validated by the division of apprenticeship standards
so it's essentially we're looking at a checkbox and an opportunity for folks to put that in without
anything standing behind it versus the pre-apprenticeship measures
so just as a background in september 2020 which i don't know how foggy all of us are but
the state board did approve the inclusion of both registered and non-registered pre-apprenticeships
and we approve separate criteria for both of those types specifically the differences between
registered and non-registered pre-apprenticeships are that registered are state recognized they
require a linkage agreement with existing apprenticeship programs it leads to registered
pre-apprenticeships and students actually receive a state certificate of completion which is the big
one for non-registered pre-apprenticeships there is no state recognition or approval process there
is no validity or quality assurance of any of these programs there's no required linkage of an
of a pre-apprenticeship program and there is no required certificate of completion
so
we also went through though and wanted to make sure that the data that we were receiving on
students who are participating in these programs if this was a you know very well engaged program
well adopted across the state we didn't want to take something away from a bunch of people
who you know were working through it and as you can see specifically our concern was with DAS
schools because when we adopted it we thought that this was an opportunity for DAS schools to
increase their number of career students career prepared students and as you can see from the
numbers displayed obviously there was a severe drop off in participation for both 2020 and 2021
as well as 2021 and 22 and that's obviously something we've seen across the board right
this isn't just with regards to non-registered pre-apprenticeship in general it's just career
education and opportunities for students to engage in career preparation at their school site
however we don't see a really large engagement outside of the general population across all of
our students so we even in 2019-20 we only saw 2,483 students participating in these programs
across all of our different educational partners we received recommendations from the CCI work group
and the TDG to remove non-registered pre-apprenticeships from CPAC specifically
a few members voiced concern that if we removed this measure it might remove opportunities for
schools so they requested specifically the CE make sure that these schools and LEAs that are
administering these programs at current would be able to assist them to get registered pre-apprenticeships
and we assured them that that we would be able to do so and then we also asked the alternative
schools task force if they had any feedback on this and they did not provide any at that time
therefore the CCI the recommendation for CCI is that we remove the non-registered pre-apprenticeship
measure beginning with next year so I don't know if anyone has any questions on CCI fun
I do have a quick question you mentioned that there's conversations going on around the civic
engagement and the industry certifications can you give us sort of just a little framework
how you when it when you expect to emerge from those conversations and you know when we would
be thinking about those two information on civic engagement at the student level was not collected
for the 2022-23 school year however we are engaging in conversations to be able to capture
that for 2023-24 so this present school year at the student level however we we continue to collect
at the student level however we we continue to collect general information on SEALS and
LEA participation and have that information and we'll continue to use that as well as when
we were able to grab the student level information to use that it to begin to integrate it into the
indicator or just to use it as at present we have no student level data to utilize that that's where
I got confused so so so hopefully hopefully we will be we we are in still in conversations to
be able to add it to the 2023-24 data collection at the student level so you might be able to start
collecting and what about industry certifications was that included in what you were just saying
at this present time we don't have any way to capture that but we continue those conversations
and with LEA's in order to find a way that we can not burden folks with additional data collections
right outside of things and what's the best way to collect that data I would continue to work on
that sounds like civic engagement is a little ahead of industry it is a little bit yes try to
get the time frame thank you any other clarifying questions a member Yoshimoto Tauri and then vice
president Claude Awards thank you I just wanted to reaffirm the the idea that we would be moving
towards approved pre-apprenticeship programs primarily because of the linkage right to an
apprenticeship program so there's a pathway for young people but can you reassure us that that
timeline with the 2023-24 timeline is enough to do what the CPAC recommended which is to make sure
that we don't lose opportunities for young people that might currently be in pre-apprenticeship
programs so yes so so the big clarification is that this year for the 2023 dashboard right any
students that had you know any graduates who had graduated with the understanding of you know and
LEA's who had pursued this right they they will be recognized within the current status of the CCI
yes so that will be fine and any students who have received that information and in their four-year
career they're fine for this next up through this year yes so it's it's the the next year moving
forward and we have assurances from the our career college transition division that they will be
working and we've already made a few connections as well to be able to to help folks to gain these
registered pre-apprenticeships yeah we have that data
just a quick question on the registered pre-apprenticeship programs i know we're not
looking at that data today do you happen to know if there was a drop in the number of students
in the registered pre-apprenticeship programs as well just as we've seen in the non-registered
pre-apprenticeship programs um i have not specifically looked at that information
but i do know that career measures across the board as as we've just from speaking with the
CCI work group right that opportunities to participate in those programs were just limited
during during that time period so um i i don't know if it was the same you know one quarter as
it was in the numbers that we saw um but i do know that there was an overall drop in general
let's move on oh
back to the seal of civic engagement do you have a sense of how many LEAs are rolling that out
though or how that's looking statewide i don't have numbers from this year as well but um you
know i know president darlin ham is very interested so i do make sure that when we bring back the work
plan for 2024 um we will make sure that we add those numbers and share out a report um like i
said as we don't have student level information but to show how how many LEAs are requesting
seals and what the breadth of that is
all right this this one's easy because you guys all know this all right
eligibility criteria for differentiated assistance we've got this down um so just as a reminder for
this year we are both we're going through level one with the support for all um as well as level
two differentiated assistance for any district charter school or county office of education
eligible based on the LCFF state priority areas and let me walk you through what those criteria
are so that i can clarify and clear up what we are changing or requesting that the state
board adopt for this year um we do have our 10 priority areas and each of those priority areas
has different criteria which would qualify an LEA for assistance so for priorities what areas one
two and three these are all local indicator areas so therefore the criteria is not met for two or
more years um on local performance so in specific regards for all of our local indicators that would
mean a not met last year on the 2022 dashboard as well as a not met for the 2023 dashboard
and all of our LEAs right now are submitting their local indicators so that everyone has an
opportunity to hit met um by submission of their priority areas by the end of this month the friday
the last friday of this month i believe the 29th i'll just shout that out for josh um so there we go
for priority area five we include um all state indicator under academic performance
so the criteria for inclusion is red on both the english language arts and math tests
or red on ela and or math and orange on the other assessment um and or red on the english
learner progress indicator or the lb for priority five it's also the two state indicators you can
either qualify via red on the graduation rate indicator or red on the chronic absenteeism
indicator for our k8 leas for priority area six it is a combination of both local indicators
and state indicators so it's either red on suspension rate or a local indicator not being
met for two or more years um for priority seven it's not it's a local indicator not met for two
or more years and then priority area eight in normal circumstances is a red on the college
slash career indicator um priority areas nine and ten only apply to our county offices of education
which are also local indicators um you may qualify for differentiated assistance based on having one
student group have meeting the criteria in two priority areas so for example the hispanic student
group could qualify if they are red in chronic absenteeism as well as being red in suspension
so that would be priority areas five and six so it's same student group right lowest performance
two or more priority areas you can also qualify simply by not meeting the local indicators and
that is again across two priority areas so if you fail to meet the criteria and submit your local
indicators on time for priorities one and two then you would qualify for local indicators only
on method two and then finally method three is both a combination of local indicators being not
met for two or more years as well as meeting the qualifications under one of the priority areas for
a student group i want to remind everyone that charter schools this year are once again eligible
for differentiated assistance the criteria however has changed since they were last eligible for
identification in 2019 as such the um this year's criteria is that charter schools are required to
meet in meet priority area information in two groups so while all other lea's are required
in one year to meet the criteria charter schools must meet it in two or more years
and that's either through method one method two or method three
the change we're requesting from you today specifically is due to the college and career
indicator being once again cell phone bars only and status only on the dashboard so therefore
we need to change the criteria that state board has previously adopted for priority area eight
and so currently it's red on the cci and we would like to change that to very low status on the cci
on the cci and with that are there any questions
i have a data point
it looks like in 2021-22 there were 10 000 seals of civic engagement
a year before there were about half as many so it's you know inching inching it's up it's way up
for the numbers
okay shifting the conversation to a different topic which is priority one and adopting objective
criteria for the reporting of teacher data specifically this modification is being made
to comply with education code section 52064.5 e2 and i think the the big big piece is just the
bottom couple of lines that when we have access to state state level state level data which is
reliable and relevant we the board needs to adopt objective criteria which may include but are not
limited to extent of disparities across school sites within a school district or county office
of education or performance relative to statewide data so in this recommendation today we're
capturing the bottom pieces within a school site or county office of education and performance
relative to statewide data specifically we now are able to comply with the first part of priority
one which is around the assignment of teachers so the degree to which teachers of the school
district are appropriately assigned in accordance with education code listed and fully credentialed
in the subject areas and for the pupils they are teaching it's a mouthful but it is something that
is required under education code and we have been reporting out now for two years so specifically
i wanted to talk about some considerations because this is complex data and i know that
the chair and others know this really well but for the remainder of the audience we have now put out
two years of data for our teaching assignment monitoring outcome reports which we call TAMO
and specifically for the 2022-23 school year of course the LCAP process begins well before
we have a dashboard in january and that process LEAs were guided to review their data and to
reflect on them and report out at a regularly scheduled meeting of their local governing board
the TAMO reports have seven assignment monitoring outcomes clear, out of field, in turn, ineffective,
incomplete, unknown, and not applicable each of these have their own unique definitions of which
some of those definitions this board has actually adopted and is in our state plan
under the Every Student Succeeds Act but i've given you that link and if you just did teacher
AMO California it's the top search in google so we are trending high on teacher data
so the considerations that we've been putting forward and had a really robust several robust
conversations with educational partners on this topic is that the clear definition does of course
align most closely with the the local indicator education code section which is 52060 which you
can see on the screen referenced but that definition doesn't give credit to those that
are in the pipeline those that are doing unique ways of trying to become fully credentialed
in the subject that they're teaching and the pupils which are in their their classrooms
specifically we heard about interns we heard about out of field educators we heard about
just very unique examples that i know even our own superintendent is promoting to make sure we
can get any available body who is interested in being a teacher to become a teacher so until
they become you know until they're clear this this does not give that school or that district
credit for the work that they're doing to become into that into that category so specifically
we've talked a little bit about educators who are out of field of course they have a credential
but they need to demonstrate subject matter competency in a new subject area and these
reports really were i think very enlightening for some school districts who thought that their
teachers were all clear and in second and in looking at the data a second time realized
that they they didn't have the appropriate subject area they hadn't met
their credential requirements for teaching english learners for example and then of course
interns which i know is near and dear to president darling hamans heart there it's a great group of
students who do have a degree they do have subject matter competency and they're working
to obtain that credential so they are not in the clear category either so with these considerations
in mind we do see a slight increase from year to year in the statewide data for clear we are at 84
percent this third year of data i think will be very different we have not districts have not had
an opportunity to actually reflect on these data after they were publicly released we had already
finished our data collection when we put out the second year of data so this is the the complete
complete report with the last three categories being grouped grouped together and then in terms
of what is before you today we put together a couple of alternatives for setting objective
criteria and we've added a fourth alternative after meeting with the educational partners
so i'm going to walk you through just verbally the first couple and i'm going to show you the
one that has become the preferred option so the first option being the statewide comparisons in
the chart with a narrative box for leas to enter their information keep in mind that the local
indicators exist they are adopted for leas they're not a school report that is that is by design
the second option is the teacher data only in a narrative form and the third option is the teacher
data in a narrative form with a metric being at above or below the statewide average so in terms
of feedback we have we established last year an ad hoc work group around teacher data which is
made up of very very passionate individuals who represent not only our our leas our practitioners
those that look at assignment monitors are charged with assignment monitoring from our
county offices of education but also those that represent our equity and our civil rights groups
and when we asked for feedback we did get option one did seem to be overwhelmingly
favorite by by the work group the california teachers advisory group was supportive of option
one but they also wanted to see an additional column and comparison to the statewide average
and so we did develop this extra option which we are recommending that you approve so specifically
this is using a local example and this tax city is always you know they're always large enough so
that's why we we I tend to gravitate towards them there was an article in our news clips of
a school that had one teacher and thank goodness that teacher was 100 she was 100 clear but
sex city gives us a variety of information and compared to the statewide average they are they
are doing quite well for for their teaching population at 87.3 percent compared to the
county average which is 88.3 compared to the statewide average which is 85.8 these are
teaching assignments that's the other thing I should mention about this report is you don't see
whole teachers right they're about assignments so a teacher may have six periods in a day or they
may be in a self-contained classroom and so that is why the data reflects these partial
numbers here what was what has been added as part of this option is the final column this comparison
to statewide and we missed a word we meant statewide average so we'd like to add that
but then the ability to have an optional narrative and this was really important I think you saw that
in the letters that we received as part of this item from county offices of education who are
teaching our most challenging student populations and may not have clear they may be out of field
and there's an opportunity to describe what's happening in the local context with this optional
narrative the other piece that we've added here is and it is cut off it doesn't it doesn't really
allow you the opportunity to see this but the piece about for additional information that's not
optional that would be a narrative that is at the bottom of of underneath the optional narrative
that we can provide a direct link to the tamo reports that that also lists the data by school
and so I know that there were some of the educational partners that really wanted to
see some school comparisons and that is an opportunity to get us partially there
so with that in mind I can continue to just finish I think the last couple slides if that's
okay with you President Darling-Hammond and I can return the conversation back to you
so the remaining pieces are mostly for informational purposes but they are things
that were definitely left on our to-do list so at our last meeting we spent the entire session
talking about chronic absenteeism and we presented a couple of short-term and long-term options for
discussion and so today we are trying to follow through with that guidance in which you
wanted to maintain the indicator as is the for methodology wise for the 2023 dashboard
you asked us to explore collecting and reporting granular data on reason for absence and then you
also asked us to provide for this dashboard a link to our data quest report on absenteeism by reason
so just to follow through with that last piece especially because that is a 2023 action we will
be we did we did solicit feedback from educational partners and we are recommending that a link be
placed in the introductory text on when you get to the chronic absenteeism section that will link
to that lea or school's absenteeism by reason report which is on a different website
another piece that is continuing as as information for informational purposes on the dashboard
is the information around our science assessments which is the california science test or cast
a link to those results through the dashboard there has been a lot of support especially in
the science community that this have a presence on the dashboard to recognize the importance of
science and and as a result we are taking users directly to those cast results and so we are
continuing that that practice from september of 2022 with your adoption for the 2023 dashboard
and then you will see this back on your agenda in 2024 for how it actually gets included on the
dashboard integrated in some way into an indicator or something something else and so we will have
finally the necessary years of data to start doing simulations and start having conversations
about methodology and and so on and then finally least restrictive environment was something that
was approved by the legislature several years ago and required that we the department by november
30th produce data on least restrictive environment which is for students people with disabilities on
our website we also need to link it to the dashboard and so that work is is actually
ongoing in the department we will have that report out by that deadline and the 2023 dashboard will
will link to it and just in terms of where that information comes from lea's have been submitting
this information through our student level data system for quite a long time but it puts puts
this out there and as far as with where this data comes from it is part of our enrollment collection
so this is information that we will we will have picked up in fall of 2022 we will
disaggregate it by race and ethnicity just like we do all of our reports on on data quest and
we'll provide that link from the main menu page of the dashboard one topic that you won't see on
our slide deck because we ran out of time and i know you have a one day meeting today is around
the gross model and i just wanted to mention that because this work has continued even even
through covid and we are really proud of the partnership with our testing contractor with
ets and the fine work that they've done so if you didn't have a chance to look at at the item i would
recommend looking through what the contractor has done and bringing together focus groups
and really looking at trying to develop out displays that would be useful for parents and
different audiences they went through a lot of iterations and i would say it's still still going
to be a work in progress as we move to have the board adopt the incorporation or decide how you
want to include these growth scores in in the accountability system in future dashboards so in
terms of all of these things culminating in amendments to the essa document there are a
couple of things that are housekeeping so i'm switching over to attachment two and specifically
a year ago it's probably been a year and a half actually the board adopted what was called an
addendum for the consolidated state plan which was provided this flexibility is provided by the us
department of education for the second year of covid and what that addendum provided the the
state to do is to extend our long-term goals it allowed us to for a short period of time to change
how we identified schools eligible for assistance and also to adjust our exit criteria because of
course we had competing legislation from the state legislature that told us we could only use one
year of data so what this action provides is for us to come into compliance when you pass that
addendum that addendum also had a provision saying you would bring back pieces of those to amend the
state plan so that puts us in compliance with what you've already adopted the other piece that these
amendments also allow us to come into compliance on or rather to to fully build out is the english
learner progress indicator so you would actually you will see an attachment three which is a
separate attachment because it's now 174 pages long several data tables that have been added
to reflect the recommendation from the department on adopting change cut scores on adopting the
color grid and then bringing in the alternate l pack and with that i wanted to conclude by
saying we continue to do a tremendous amount of outreach and i cannot underscore the work of the
team led by kim and then ryan lamb to just get out in front of some of these things we know the field
is once again anxious to see data to see data compared to the state can see data compared to
their their rival school district or their rival charter school i'm not sure you know there's always
there's always this interest in comparisons and so we already have our toolkit out for 2023 it is
being built out by the day but we have done several and all these work group meetings that came to to
the culmination of what you saw today we've had in-person presentations we're so delighted to be
in person and then virtual meetings with a large one in august kicking off our season with over
850 participants so we are out we're on the circuit this fall the conference circuit and really
excited to get out the word about data the dashboard and how this really helps we hope
improve the lives of our students with that i'm happy to turn it back to president darling
hammond would you like me to shift over to the public comment slide
thank you so much we're going to open the phone line for public comment
queue and members of the public wishing to provide comment can do so in person or by
calling the telephone number and using the access code on the slide that's shown now
while we're waiting for members of the public to call in i want to ask our liaison vice president
if she has any initial comments before me then we'll take any clarifying questions and we'll
go to public comment and come back for discussion thank you president darling hammond i first would
like to just start my very brief comment by saying thank you thank you thank you to cindy and her team
just again a tremendous amount of work that has gone into the work plan being responsive to the
board as well as reaching out to educational partners throughout our state when she said
they're on the circuit they're on the circuit they are everywhere getting in the feedback
and really trying to come to consensus with the feedback that's received so again cindy and team
thank you so very much the only other piece i will add before we go to public comment is that
again we have a lot of different components to this particular item that will require our our
action but as i look at everything it's in alignment with those dashboard principles
that we approved a few months a few meetings back and i think we are continuing to show
that philosophy of continuous improvement where we continue to look at
our dashboard the indicators that make up our dashboard and how to ensure that it best represents
how students are performing in our schools
and i will second that emotion and simply add that i think the other thing that we see in the work
that continues on the dashboard is the effort to really think about education in a broad way that
takes into account all the many opportunities that students are getting career in college and
civic engagement as well as you know achievement and opportunities to learn and that we see this
continual improvement both in the indicators and in the ways in which we're seeking to help them
be used so it's it is a lot of work but it's very productive that was a lot we did stop for
clarifying comments along the way or questions are there any other clarifying questions at this point
before we go to public comment seeing none we'll see if there's anybody in the room who wants to
make in-person public comment we have four individuals signed up for public comment
shelly spiegel colman followed by jessica saco andrea ball and lindsay tornatori
i think we need the microphone on or turned up or something
got it good afternoon board president linda darling hammon board members shelly spiegel
colman from californians together we support the recommendation to adopt the traditional five by
five lp given the two choices however we regret not having the opportunity to review the status
cut scores prior to this decision as exemplified by the following two examples when 45 percent
of english learners in a district are not making the expected one level of growth out of the six
lpac levels and they've declined for change that district is yellow which eliminates the need
to address them in their l cap when 55 percent of the district's el's are not making progress
and maintained without any growth also that district is yellow we are grateful for new
elements in the l pen but when informed by the dashboard many districts will not be held
responsible to improve the english language development instruction and program please
consider scheduling an opportunity to review the cut scores and its implication on the traditional
model thank you good afternoon jessica saco on behalf of children now president darling hammon
chief deputy nicely members of the board i refer you to the lcff equity coalition for our complete
comments on this item as a member of the ad hoc priority one teaching assignment data work group
i've been grateful for the opportunity to work closely with staff and consider how the teacher
assignment data might be included in the dashboard i recommend the board approve option 1a for
presentation of the data on the dashboard with three key amendments first to create five bands
to indicate if an lea's percentage of clear teaching assignments is above well above
similar below or well below to include school level data with comparison to lea and state level
data on school level dashboard pages and finally to include an equity component which at minimum
demonstrates the disparities and percentages of clear teaching assignments among schools within
an lea thank you thank you board president darling hammon board members cde thanks for the great
presentation and all the work i'm here today on behalf of two organizations first the california
association of suburban school districts the largest suburban school districts across the state
and the central valley education coalition which is the county superintendents and district
superintendents in six central valley counties both very diverse uh organizations i want to
talk on behalf of both organizations on the english learner progress indicator thank the
department and support the five by five table with the change in status scores i think this is
going to be very helpful to show the progress or the work that needs to be done to highlight that
work that needs to be done second on the teacher monitoring indicator we do support having the
data as well as the optional narrative box again this is important for schools operated by county
offices of education county superintendents as the department's presentation noted for those
teachers that are in those optional schools thank you good afternoon lindsey tornatore on behalf of
the california county superintendents we broadly support all of the cd's recommendations for this
item and refer to you to our letter where we explain how each of the recommendations will
benefit california students we would like to emphasize two elements during our comment today
lp and the teacher assignment data for the lp we support the cut points outlined in table five
because it values change and performance equally teachers need to monitor both to determine if
students are making progress regarding priority one the cd's recommendation reflects california's
goal of one cohesive state and federal system because it displays the teacher definition as
required by essa and allows la is to provide local context in the narrative box which for our
juvenile court and community schools is very important the federal definition is not the
only criteria in california for determining if a teacher is eligible to teach finally we believe
the cd's version of option 1a for the teacher for priority one meets all legal requirements required
by essa and should be adopted thank you
telephone comments okay uh good afternoon caller ending in 4544 please state your
name and affiliation for the record
okay next caller ending in 1 3 1 6 please state your name and affiliation for the record you have
one minute your time starts now good afternoon my name is valerie salazar on the behalf of the
placer county office of education we broadly support all of cd's recommendations and we are
very happy to be able to answer any questions that you may have for us and we would like to
we broadly support all of cd's recommendations for this item
and particularly we support setting objective criteria for teacher assignment data and priority
one and request the board adopts cd's recommendation we are in support of cd's recommendations
displaying specifically the teacher definition and including a narrative box to provide the
local context because it meets the essa requirements of the teacher definition
and includes the narrative box to provide the so important local context this is critically
important for county offices of education since many of our teachers in juvenile court
and county community schools feature under under a local assignment option these teachers frequently
teach in a single multi-grade multi-subject classroom and the definitions and narrative box
are critically important to serve our transparency with our educational partners related to teacher
qualifications thank you thank you next caller ending in 8744 please state your name and
affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon dr darlin hammon and board members today in a bill and
request of the association of public school administrators i have to support cd's
recommendation on healthy touch sports because it values students as well as performance it's
important to have multiple qualitative measures that showcase students ability to learn in different
ways to increase overall success additional tests also strongly support cd's recommendations to
move forward with option one a lea county statewide comparison in part form and narrative box
the priority one we believe that option 1a is the most apparent because as the chart form makes the
data add a comparison clear which allows the public and community to quickly and easily understand
the data the victim of the brief narrative allows la's opportunity to explain the circumstance
around their data we'll celebrate okay thanks thank you next caller ending in 5116
please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon connie choi the public advocate on behalf of the equity coalition
while we support the staff recommendation to maintain the traditional five by five
matrix for the lp cut scores we also recommend one aligning lp performance standards of research
expectations that even english learners with the lowest initial proficiency should be expected to
reach the specific position within five to seven years and avoid being deemed as outheld and to
avoiding masking underperformance by narrowing the range of a change ratings for significantly
increased and declined from the proposed 10 percent change to something between five to eight
percent to comport with agency approaches to other indicators for your consideration thank you next
caller ending in 7768 please state your name and affiliate and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time starts now
hi peter ahern past president of the california association of science educators i want to thank
the board for its ongoing commitment and support for having science on the dashboard we are
gratified that cde's proposed work plans includes science or dashboard we are aware that this
requires some technical decisions the science education community is excited to work with cde
in doing this the best way possible to support all california students in getting the science
education deserve a strong science education is a gateway to stem careers and majors which we know
students don't have equitable access to currently districts have under investigated in science
under invested in science and ngss and science is not on the dashboard and the dashboard informs the
l cap also going back to agenda item three we're excited to see science prominently displayed
in the casp reports and thank cde for this as well as further work on interim science
thank you next caller ending in 6557 please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon board president darlene hammon and members of the board this is
seven accountability and data literacy to the los angeles county office of education
i'm calling to express support for the cde's proposed english language progress indicators
change cut scores as well as the use of the traditional five by five color grid
in my role supporting lea's and understanding and utilizing the california ongoing continuous
improvement process i believe that the consistent use of the methodology for determining cut scores
across all indicators helps lea's to better understand how the dashboard is developed
and to see it as a valid measure of their efforts in addition the reinstatement of the traditional
five by five color scheme effectively reinforces the importance of growth in meeting the language
acquisition needs of english learners thank you thank you next caller ending in 4333
please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon you know lance representing the orange county department of education
and i thank president darling hammon vice president clever woods and members of the
board for this platform voice our broad support for cd's recommendations on this item in addition
to our overall support i'd like to specifically highlight our gratitude for the recommendation
concerning future assignment data for priority one cd's recommendations thoughtfully incorporates
feedback from county office of education by affording lea's the opportunity to provide
context for our assignment data this context is important for all lea's and particularly so for
schools run by county offices where many of our teachers are appropriately and fully authorized
for their assignments under local assignment options that are not specifically reflected in
the federal definitions this recommendation for priority one presents an opportunity to
offer clarity and transparency to our communities concerning future assignments and it helps us
achieve a goal of maintaining a coherent state and federal accountability system thank you
next caller ending in 9260 please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon angelica salazar with public advocate and the equity coalition we appreciate
the progress cd has made on the teacher priority one dashboard indicator option 1a is the most
transparent but requires amendments to fully comply with education code first this indicator
is required to encompass school level data the link offered in option 1a to the district's
annual report does not reflect any objective school level standard and does not comply with
ed codes reliable school level data has now been available for two years the equity coalition
letter demonstrates how to integrate school level data into the dashboard that is legally compliant
and that enhances user friendliness and community dialogue second there needs to be an equity
component showing interdisciplinary gaps and access to clear teachers our partners at education
plus west have developed simple mock-ups demonstrated an acceptable equity component
that can be added to this year's dashboard third straight quintiles to indicate the degree to
which a district is above or below the state average for clear teachers not just the two
blunt categories that were offered this morning thank you thank you next caller ending in 6845
please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good afternoon lucy bollinger from elk grove unified school district we support the department's
recommendation to implement the traditional five-by-five performance matrix it is important
to keep lea's accountable and have high expectations hence at the same time we encourage the board to
reconsider lp status performance standards because we feel the current lp status standards are too
low and do not align with research-based expectations as a program specialist overseeing
our district's newcomer welcome centers we recognize that it is all of our responsibility
and privilege to serve our multilingual learners ensuring accelerated success our multilingual
learners deserve high expectations quality supports and timely access thank you so much
thank you next caller ending in 0394 please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time starts now
hi good evening this is in one one rostro director of policy at california together
and i'm calling focus attention to the large change range for increased decrease significantly
that is currently on the lp it is currently recommended to be around the 10 change range
we would encourage narrowing the change level to somewhere in the five to eight percent range
for the significant change category this will recognize more lea as either having made
significant progress or experienced significant decline and give more a more equitable picture
of our district with schools to reflect on the growth or lack of growth for english language
proficiency the 10 change range that is currently recommended is would constitute the largest change
range if adopted on the dashboard for example other indicators range from a low of around two
to four percent change range for suspension rates to a high of nine percent on college
and career ready for the college and career readiness indicator again we encourage changing
the change range it would allow more lea to be recognized for the growth thank you
thank you thanks next caller ending at 8256 please state your name and affiliation for the
record you have one minute your time starts now
hi this is robert manwearing from children now i'm going to comment on the english learner
progress indicator and chronic absenteeism first on the lp i want to thank staff for recommending
the traditional method of adopting a five-by-five matrix i want to echo the comments of california
equity coalition on these issues specifically i also wanted to link this conversation to this
morning's conversation where it was noted that if you end up with a red rating you have a required
action on your l cap right now the low performing category is it allows a district that has roughly
just over a third of their their students making progress getting out of that required action
um those districts tend to have half of their english learners become long-term english learners
we're not setting the bar high enough for districts to focus attention on this group of students
for uh chronic absenteeism uh there's there's going to be additional data reported i'd like
to have there be some clarification on whether that will be reported also for high schools
that are currently not part of the dashboard in terms of chronic thank you thank you thanks
next caller ending in eight nine four five please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time starts now this is susanne from the carter schools development center
hello again we'd like to see a growth model work plan that positions growth data to support school
improvement and more robust school accountability we believe that strong state board leadership
is going to be needed to steer the ship for ground sound strategic use of growth data
our input on the lp decision reflects concern for valid meaningful data we support a balanced
five by five because it downplays change especially for small schools is volatile
partly due to the changing cohort of english learners included in the indicator from year to
year we oppose option two assignment of no progress because mixing in a participation rate penalty
undermines the validity of status we've seen this with ela and math where the participation rate
penalty has eliminated a valid status score for those lea's that have happen to have many
parents who exercise their opt-out right thank you finally okay thank you next caller ending in
nine five six three please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute
your time starts now good afternoon uh president darling ham and the board members john afel
from public advocates and the equity coalition i want to echo the comments
made by my colleagues in the equity coalition in particular i want to highlight and disagree
with the staff comments that local indicators can only exist as part of an lea dashboard report
somehow that's been fixed in stone by the state board clearly the legislature
in 2018 which code has directed that the demo data at the school level for clear
indicators should be reported on in the dashboard at the school level and we think that's
easy enough to do and in the spirit of continuous improvement it's really important to convey
clear objective criteria at the school level on school level dashboards we appreciate your
consideration thank you next caller ending in seven three two eight please state your
name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
so
hey my name is al macho and i am a local channel and i've been um somewhat disappointed with
lbsd and sort of um awesome for students so i'm in uh very local uh very much supportive of uh
parents choice i hope that you can consider uh just a petition uh to expand their
okay i'm sorry excuse me caller sorry to interrupt uh we're currently taking public
comment for item number eight can you please call back when we take up the item that you wish to
speak to thank you oh sorry about that no worries and that concludes public comment for item eight
okay um thank you very much we're now open for board discussion uh and we do um
probably want to put up the recommendation slide as well
any questions or two slides yes spilled over part two i can go to part two but we'll put up part one
and then maybe show us part two so people remember the other parts we've got so that's okay we've got
cci differentiated assistance eligibility criteria and then part two is around um the tam of data
and setting objective criteria as well as um for informational purposes the links to additional
outside data and finally your the amendments that need to be incorporated into the every student
succeeds act state plan thank you any further questions or discussion
uh and actually i think it's more of a comment than than discussion um first i definitely support
the cde's recommendation um again appreciate the work that's been done with that um i just wanted to
highlight the teacher assignment data option um thank you for again receiving the feedback that
was made by the board of trustees and the board of trustees and the board of trustees and the board of
again receiving the feedback that was given on all of that i think it's a very inclusive way
to ensure that data is accurately represented for this particular indicator as well as providing
space for adding local context as it relates to that particular um indicator so thank you very
much i am going to just say as we think about future work plans um i am interested in knowing
about the impact on the pre-apprenticeship programs for students as we've kind of moved out of the
pandemic phase and um we have students that are back in school but i do know our high schools
are now starting later so i am interested in knowing if that late start time has any impact
on students ability to participate in these uh pre-apprenticeship programs considering
when they're in school and when they're getting out of school and things along that line i
realize the start time is not within the purview of this board i want to be very clear but
i am interested on how that impacts the data that we are seeing on the dashboard itself
um the other piece um i just wanted to say is that uh again appreciative of those links to
data quest to provide those deeper dives into data and um i think that as we now have an lp
five by five grid that is representative of status and change as we think about future work plans and
what that looks like we can then consider if it's necessary to revisit the conversation on cut
scores but i felt it was really important for us to first have a status and change grid for this
particular indicator and then we can start to look at other data and see if other adjustments
need to be made down the road thank you member oaken and then member yoshimoto tari
thank you for this clear presentation of a lot of really good work appreciate it
hopefully my question will be clearer than my brain is um but so my question is about the
two different um color scheme options for the for lp um so it's sort of it's two questions um
the first one is i in the note on slide 26 it says that the that cpag supported
the use of the traditional color scheme because it gives more weight to change on the overall
performance color and i was just wondering if you'd explain why that one gives more
weight to change it's probably obvious but i'd love to just understand is it because more
i don't know i'll wait slide 26 yep
it was sort of when the change got made to
favoring the traditional as opposed to the balanced yeah
sorry i don't there's no slide numbers on this oh i think it's the next one go down one more
one more one more oh gosh it's close you're very close
it was your educational partner's feedback slide oh okay i'm sorry yes i can goodbye sorry
yeah i just didn't understand why that gives more weight to change
so sorry
i think you just want the traditional five by five there yes all right the the easiest
road to look at is high and if we're comparing traditional versus balanced right on high you see
four colors represented orange yellow green and blue so as you can see change right your
performance on change is going to drop is going to put you in one of four colors you have the
opportunity on that row right to achieve any of those colors whereas on balance if we go way back
there's only two options on the high got it your color scheme options on the balance five by five
across on the row right so status you only ever have two options so within balance with the
traditional you have up to four and on most rows you have three
okay thank you may i add a question to your question yeah yeah say one of the commenters
talked about the instability of you know growth scores for small schools and how does that factor
in how are we thinking about that correct so what in other indicators how we've factored that in is
the board has adopted a three by five grid there has not been an adoption of a three by five grid
for this purpose if there's interest in the department exploring that for the 2024 dashboard
i mean i think to member glubber woods comments this this is a continuous improvement system
and if there's things in the data that are you know not playing out that we saw in the sim that
you know we did simulations based on preliminary data happy to happy to bring those those those
back but at this point there is you know a slight impact on on small on the smalls
which inevitably means they'll get support they'll get more support for this population of students
it's they're identified
yeah thank you so my second question it's still on this just trying to get my head around it so
the traditional model puts more weight on change and it also if i looked at those
the tables how many schools are identified in each color level there's quite a few more
in the traditional who are identified in red can you just explain and if
if you're not the right well can you explain what the practical impact is of that if there are
are twice or three times as many schools identified in red i i hear from the comments
one of them one practical implication is that the this the achievement and progress of students
will have to be addressed in the l cap so i got that one are there other practical implications
such as the need for assistance for schools or anything else like that
so it depends is probably the short answer if if there's another indicator that the lea
is underperforming on under the differentiated assistance criteria for that same student group
which of course is english learners they could be eligible for differentiated assistance
at for for schools of course under the every student succeeds act we we have some slightly
different criteria and they could be identified for for support if you're a comprehensive
improvement school a csi school you could get money you have a planning process there's a support
system around you and with the htsi identification again there's a planning process as well
um based on school identification so uh you know if anything um it raises this group to
to a level that um districts and and schools are paying greater potentially greater attention to
them thanks and that that that that echoes what we heard in many of the calls so that's just
helpful to hear thank you are there other questions or comments before we get to a motion
um member yashima otari
thank you again for all the input that uh and thought that went into this um while i'm going
to support the recommendations today i i just wanted to second what vice president cleverwood
said about the the lp that we're moving a step in the right direction by adding the the change so
we have status and change um but i am i just want to mark the the couple of comments i talked
about needing to raise expectations for the lp primarily because um we we know that the impact
on young people needing to reclassify in a timely way is really important so i just asked that
in the future we wanted to do that really carefully and that we come back as a board
and revisit that when the time's appropriate because um they're
when young people get to middle school who are learning english their schedule is impacted by
whether or not they are in the english learner program or not so that adequate progress that
yearly progress is really important so just something to note for the future uh thank you
all right if there are no further questions i'd like to see if we can move towards a motion
um and we can put that recommendation back up there if you don't mind uh yes vice president
cleverwood's and and just to clarify in making the motion do i need to um articulate each of the
bullet points thank you okay okay thank you well i i move that we approve the uh the
department's recommended recommendations as outlined before us and um that is my motion
is there a second member yoshimoto tari thank you uh is there any further discussion of the
motion all in favor please raise your hand and say aye aye and are there any abstentions or
any nay any abstentions okay passes unanimously thank you very much we're going to continue on
um we're going to try to pick up a little steam here and do the waiver consent calendar
items w1 through 14 and we'll open up the phone line for public comment please
and we'll meanwhile ask for any in-person public comment if there is any and those who are
wanting to call in the please call the phone number and use the access code on this
slide are there any in-person public comments no and we'll take a little bit of wait time
to see if there are any telephone public comments
uh
while you're dating yourself looks there are no callers in the queue
thank you very much uh given that there is no further public comment i ask for a motion on
consent items waivers w1 through w14 member olken and may i have a second
number louis thank you very much uh show of hands for all those in favor
please say aye and keep your hands raised
any opposed any abstain the motion carries thank you i i do want to we are going to go
into another long item you're getting silly
oh it's that time when you know it's time for recess right but we don't really
we don't get a long recess uh we are going into a long item i want to give you a five
minute break but i really want to ask you to please stick to that five minute break we're
running a little behind our anticipated schedule but this is the moment before we get into our
next item nine
i think we are back in business great uh we're going to move on to item nine item nine is the
appeal of the denial of a petition for the establishment of a classroom-based charter
school pursuant to california education code section 47605 k2 and we are going to consider
evidence to hear or summarily deny the appeal of vista legacy global academy which was denied
by the los angeles unified school district in the los angeles county board of education
and the california department of education recommends that we hear the appeal this
recommendation is based on the cde's review of the written submission and the documentary record
which set out sufficient evidence to hear the appeal the item will be presented by nancy kim
portillo of the cde thank you nancy please begin
good afternoon board president darling hammon chief deputy nicely and members of the board
my name is nancy kim portillo and i will be presenting on item nine appeal of the denial
of a petition for the establishment of vista legacy global academy
in this item pursuant to california ed code section 47605 k2e the california state board
of education shall decide to either hear the appeal of vista legacy global academy
or summarily deny review of the appeal based on the documentary record if the sbe decides
to hear the appeal this matter will be further considered in the following item if the sbe
decides to summarily deny the appeal the decisions of the district and county
board of education will stand there will be no further hearing on this item
recommendation the california department of education recommends that the sbe
hear the vista legacy appeal this recommendation is based upon the cde's review of vista legacy's
appeal and the documentary record which included sufficient evidence to hear the appeal
at its august 8 2023 meeting the advisory commission on charter schools unanimously
voted to accept the cde's recommendation that the sbe hear the appeal
the vista legacy petition proposes a new grade 9 through 12 charter school the petitioner submitted
the vista legacy petition to the los angeles unified school district la usd or district
pursuant to ed code section 47605 a the district denied the petition on november 15th 2022 by a
vote of five to one the petitioner appealed district's denial to the los angeles county
board of education black bow or county pursuant to ed code section 47605 k1 ai the county denied
the petition on march 14th 2023 by a vote of four to three
regarding the submission of of an appeal ed code section 47605 k2 s states the petitioner shall
submit the petition to the state board within 30 days of a denial by the county board of education
the petitioner shall include the findings and documentary record from the governing board of
the school district and the county board of education and a written submission detailing
with specific citations to the documentary record how the governing board of the school
district and the county board of education abused their discretion the county denied the vista legacy
petition on march 14th 2023 the petitioner submitted its appeal to the sbe on april 13th
2023 which was within 30 days of the denial by the county board of education
the petitioner submitted the following items as part of its appeal
a written submission of its appeal which includes allegations with citations to the documentary
record of abuse of discretion by the governing board of the la usd and the lack fo vista legacies
charter petition the documentary record from the la usd which included the district's findings
in support of denial the documentary record from the lack fo which included the county's findings
in support of denial supporting documentation from vista legacy
conclusion and recommendation based on the cde's review of the petitioner's written submission
and the findings and documentary record from the la usd and the lack fo the cde finds that
the appeal presents sufficient evidence for the sbe to hear the appeal pursuant to ed code 47605
k2d therefore the cde recommends that the sbe hear the vista legacy appeal
at its august meeting the accs in alignment with the cde's recommendation
moved to recommend that the sbe hear the vista legacy appeal the motion passed unanimously
thank you president darling hammon back to you
uh and we have the public comments slide displayed we will now open the phone line for the public
comment queue this item is limited to a decision about whether or not to hear the appeal people
wishing to make comments on the merits of the appeal and whether there has been an abuse of
discretion should please wait and comment on the next item item number 10 members of the public
wishing to provide comment on this item may do so in person or by calling the telephone number
and using the access code on the slide provided in front of you and while we're waiting for members
of the public to call in i want to ask our liaisons vice president glover woods and member oaken
if they have any initial comments and then i'll ask if there are clarifying questions from board
members before we go to public comment thank you president darling hammon i just wanted to
reiterate the recommendation from cde there is sufficient evidence as we've seen in the item
to hear the appeal and i just wanted to underscore that number oaken
i guess the only thing i would add is just the reminder that this item is solely to determine
whether we will hear the appeal or summarily deny the appeal and so we're not actually
weighing the evidence we're just affirming that there's enough whether there's enough evidence to
proceed so and and it was both and as we know both the department of education and the advisor
commission entire schools are recommending that we do hear the item all right and is there any
are there any clarifying questions all right is there any comment in the room public comment in
the room we have two individuals that signed up for public comment john lemmo and lorraine richards
there we go
good afternoon john lemmo here on behalf of district charter public schools there's a valid
appeal that's been presented your advisory body the accs has unanimously recommended that you
hear this appeal your staff has recommended that you hear the appeal it's sort of a peculiarity
of the statute that you split this into two items you know an item 9 and item 10 but we
urge you to hear the appeal all the documentation is before you and we're ready to move on to item
10 thank you good afternoon state board of education members my name is lorraine richards
i'm a classroom teacher representing the california teachers association av 1505 established an abuse
of discretion standard that is most deferential standard of review under which the state board
must give difference to the decision of the governing board of the school district and the
county board of education to deny the petition despite this we continue to see charter petitions
appeal to the state board because they simply do not agree with the outcomes of robust local analysis
deliberation and governance not because of true abuse of discretion in this case there is not
sufficient evidence within the documentary record that an abusive discussion occurred the fact that
the petitioner disagrees with the local district and county board is not sufficient evidence cta
urges the board to deny the petitioner's abusive appeal thank you thank you is there any public
comment on the phone yes i will open the phone line now good afternoon caller ending in 1799
please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
in the petition
members my name is Beatriz and i'm calling it in behalf of the school because i think that
the fact that you hear the appeal is important for my kid continue
to
also for the community to have schools of good quality thank you
thank you gracias next caller ending in 2550 please state your name and affiliation for the
record you have one minute your time starts now
Hi, my name is Patricia Santillan. I am asking you to please listen to the petition of Vista Legacy.
It's important for my children, my family, and the community. It's very important
for us to have schools of high quality in our community.
Thank you for listening to my petition as a mother.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 7600 please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Paul Viera. I've been on the board since 2014. I've witnessed myself
and within the organization of the transformation and the growth with our students and the families
and the community so we ask that you would wholeheartedly hear our petition. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 9247 please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Caller ending in 9247 please begin.
Hello, my name is Maria Ramirez and I'm calling on behalf of Vista so that the board listens to
the appeal and the petition from the school because we need schools of high quality. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 6846 please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Caller ending in 6846 please begin your public comment.
Hi, my name is Paula Molina. Please listen to the petition for Vista Legacy. It's important for me
and my community to have schools with high quality. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller
ending in 7583 please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Eric Molina and I have three children in the Vista charter schools and
I've seen extremely good results. It's a very high quality school system and I hope you guys
can please listen to the petition. Thank you very much. Thank you. Next caller ending in 2799
please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Caller ending in 2799 please begin.
Good afternoon. We're asking the board to please listen to the petition of Vista because it's
important for me and my children to have this school.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 4544 please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Susan Mott with Generation Now Initiative that is at the Vista K-12 school network
and I request that the board hear out this petition as we have been working with Vista
for the past three years and have experienced excellent results in working with them. Our
goal is to prepare young people for life in the 21st century by providing them the knowledge,
skills, and experiences needed to find the solutions for the sustainability of our planet.
We have been invited with Vista by the University of California at Irvine to participate in the
launch of the ECLIP, the UC and CSU systems environmental and climate change projects
in 2023. We feel that this would be an excellent program moving forward with the Vista
public charter schools network and as they were selected to be one of their main speakers at this
past ECLIP event representing all young people of this generation who are taking action to create
a sustainable planet. Once again, please we appreciate you listening to this petition
and hope that it will receive good results. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 7771
please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Jasmine Aguilera. I am a parent of three children whom attempt Vista Condor,
Vista Heritage, and Vista Meridian. I came to know of Vista schools on a Saturday before the
school year started. My children were enrolled the following Monday. My high schooler was struggling
with basic math and reading. He is now taking AP classes in AP US history and is performing as he
should be academically at Vista. Please approve Vista Legacy Global Academy. The children in LA
also deserve a high school like this one. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 9633 please
state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
My name is Maria Lopez. I'm calling on behalf of Vista Legacy. I have kids that study here in LA
and I'm very happy about the opportunity that Legacy is offering them. My kids are in great
depression. And now, continue, please.
They've offered counseling to my kids. Also,
they offer sports and then necessary credits to finish high school. I would like to for
my kids and other kids of the community to continue having these opportunities
to study in these great schools. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 8945. Please
state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, this is Suzanne Cooey from the Charter Schools Development Center. Calling in again.
Hi, members of the board. I wasn't anticipating calling in on this until I heard a previous
caller suggest that appeals were, we just keep seeing appeals that from schools that just refuse
to accept perfectly reasonable decisions from the local authorities. This comment is not about
LUSD, LACO, and in this case, it is about this general process here about when we hear appeals.
I just want to attest, I know an extraordinary amount about the use of data, certainly in these
types of decisions and want to say that right now we have a great deal of work to do on
understanding these incredibly complex and layered decisions and not always the greatest data.
So we appreciate collaboration with some of these authorizers and into getting some shared
understandings and hopefully minimizing some of these issues. We embrace that work, but we think
we are, that caller we think is really misinformed about how appeals can come about. Thank you.
Thank you. Your time is up. And that concludes public comment for item nine.
Okay, thank you very much. We'll now open for board discussion.
Are there comments or questions from members of the board? We've heard from our two liaisons.
We can either probe further if there are questions or take a motion.
Vice President Glover Woods.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond. I move that we hear the appeal that has been presented before
us. Okay, all in favor say aye. Aye. All right, any nay? One. All right, the motion passes.
And we'll at this point go on to the actual public hearing.
So item 10 is a public hearing regarding the appeal of the denial of the petition for the
establishment of the classroom-based charter school and the decision to affirm or reverse
the Los Angeles Unified School Districts and Los Angeles County Board of Education's determinations
of the VISTA Legacy Global Academy petition. And as you know, the item will be presented by
Nancy Kim Portillo of the CDE. The CDE recommends that the state board affirm the determinations of
the LA USD and the LA County Board of Education. And I will pass the ball to you, Nancy. Please begin.
Good afternoon, Board President Darling-Hammond, Chief Deputy Nicely, and members of the board.
My name is Nancy Kim Portillo and I will be presenting on item 10, review of the
appeal and decision to affirm or reverse denial of the VISTA Legacy Global Academy petition.
VISTA Legacy Global Academy, VISTA legacy or petitioner, submitted an establishment charter
petition to the Los Angeles Unified School District, LA USD or district, and the Los Angeles County
Board of Education, LACBO or county pursuant to California Ed Code, sections 47605A and 47605K1AI
respectively. The district and county denied the petition. VISTA Legacy appealed its denial to the
California State Board of Education, pursuant to Ed Code section 47605K2E, which was clarified by
Senate Bill 114, Chapter 48, Statutes of 2023, the SBE May. Affirm the determination of the
governing board of the school district or the county board of education or both of those
determinations or reverse only upon a determination that there was an abuse of discretion by each of
the governing board of the school district and the county board of education. These clarifications
are consistent with and affirm the interpretation by the CDE as presented in prior charter appeal
items, that the SBE must find an abuse of discretion at both the district and county levels
to deny a petition. If the SBE does not take action to affirm or reverse the determinations
of the governing board of the school district and the county board of education to deny the
charter petition will stand. SB 114 also clarified the SBE's standard of review, again consistent
with the CDE's interpretation as presented in prior charter appeal items. Abuse of discretion
is the most deferential standard of review under which the state board must give deference to the
decisions of the governing board of the school district and the county board of education to
deny the petition. The SBE's review is limited to a determination of whether the district governing
boards or county board's decision to deny the charter petition was arbitrary, capricious,
entirely lacking in evidentiary support, unlawful or procedurally unfair. California School Boards
Association versus State Board of Education 2010-186, Cal App 4, 1298-1313-1314. If even one
basis for denial is supported by evidence in the record, the determination to deny should be affirmed.
Recommendation. The California Department of Education recommends that the SBE
affirm the determinations of the LAUSD and the LACBO to deny the petition to establish
VLGA pursuant to Ed Code section 47605K2E. This is based on its analysis of the documentary record
the CDE has determined that both the district and the county made written factual findings for
denial of the VISTA legacy petition that are supported by evidence in the record in accordance
with Ed Code section 47605C.
Findings for denial by the district. The district cited the following findings in its denial of
the VISTA legacy petition. Petitioners are demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement
the program set forth in the petition. Ed Code section 47605C2. The petition does not contain
reasonably comprehensive descriptions of all of the required elements. Ed Code section 47605C5.
The charter school is demonstrably unlikely to serve the interests of the entire community in
which the school is proposing to locate. Ed Code section 47605C7.
Findings for denial by the county. The county cited the following findings in its denial of
the VISTA legacy petition. Petitioners are demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement
the program set forth in the petition. Ed Code section 47605C2. The petition does not contain
reasonably comprehensive descriptions of all of the required elements. Education Code section 47605C5.
The charter school is demonstrably unlikely to serve the interests of the entire community
in which the school is proposing to locate. Education Code section 47605C7.
Next, VISTA legacy global academies written submission.
Petitioners allegations against the district. The petitioner alleges the following abusive
discretion by the district. The factual findings adopted by the district board are not supported
by substantial evidence in light of the entire record. The district abused its discretion by
acting unlawfully and in a procedurally unfair manner by using an unlawfully burdensome
definition of community impact and by imposing requirements found nowhere in the charter school's
act. Petitioners allegations against the county. The petitioner alleges the following abusive
discretion by the county. Statutory finding C2 was arbitrary and capricious in that the factual
findings are not supported by evidence in the record. The county board acted in an arbitrary
manner without evidentiary support when it adopted statutory findings, C5. The county
board acted unlawfully when it failed to provide a de novo review and relied on undue deference
to LAUSD in adopting statutory findings, C7. LACBO's hearing was procedurally infirm and unfair.
District and county oppositions to petitioners appeal.
Written opposition. Education Code section 47605K2C states the following. Within 30 days of receipt
of the appeal submitted to the state board, the governing board of the school district or county
board of education may submit a written opposition to the state board detailing with specific
citations to the documentary record how the governing board of the school district or the
county board of education did not abuse its discretion in denying the petition. Both the
district and the county submitted written oppositions pursuant to the aforementioned section.
District opposition. In its written opposition to VISTA legacy's appeal, the district states,
petitioner failed to demonstrate LAUSD abused its discretion. The LAUSD board denied the petition
consistent with the charter schools act. Petitioner failed to adequately cite to the documentary
record. The SBE must affirm the LAUSD board's decision and deny the petition regardless of
whether it affirms or denies the county board's decision.
County opposition. In its written opposition to VISTA legacy's appeal, the county states,
LACBO's finding that VISTA was unlikely to successfully implement its program was based
on its review of the evidence and does not constitute an abuse of discretion.
LACBO's finding that the petition did not contain reasonably comprehensive descriptions of required
elements was based on its review and analysis of petition and did not constitute an abuse of
discretion. VISTA's appeal fails to demonstrate any abuse of discretion in LACBO's findings
regarding community impact. VISTA's position that LACBO was unable to act on a motion that had been
moved and seconded without first voting on a conflicting motion is entirely without legal
support and would lead to absurd results. California Department of Education's review.
District and county findings. After reviewing the documentary record and supporting documentation
and supporting documentation submitted by the parties to this appeal, the CDE has determined
both the district and the county made written factual findings in accordance with Ed code
section 47605C and both the districts and the county's findings are supported by evidence in
the record. District and county findings examples of evidence. The district's finding that the
petitioners are demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the program set forth in the petition
is supported by specific facts including but not limited to the following. Details of the proposed
English language development program. Factual emissions pertaining to the petitioners existing
charter schools and governance structure and the performance and operational demands of the
petitioners existing charter schools. The county's finding that the charter school is demonstrably
unlikely to serve the interest of the entire community in which the school is proposing to
locate is supported by specific facts including but not limited to enrollment data of nearby
district and charter schools. Programs available at schools in the community.
District and county findings conclusion. While the petitioner's appeal challenged the conclusions
made by the district and the county, the petitioner has not refuted the evidence relied on by the
district or the county in their respective findings for denial. The petitioner instead argues for the
state board of education to exercise its independent judgment in reviewing the evidence in the record
which is not permitted under the abuse of discretion review standard. Review of procedural allegations.
The petitioner alleges the district's requirement that petitioners submit a community impact
assessment with their petition constitutes an abuse of discretion. Vista legacy's written submission
has not shown how the district requirement of a community impact assessment constitutes an abuse
of discretion. The petitioner also alleges the county abused its discretion in denying a board
member's request to amend the motion to deny and approve the Vista legacy charter.
The transcript and recording of the meeting in question show that county proceeded
in accordance with its bylaws and standard open meeting procedures. A comprehensive review of
the Vista legacy appeal including the districts and the county's written oppositions and the
districts and the county findings regarding the petition is provided as attachment one.
Conclusion and recommendation.
The CDE recommends that the SBE affirm both the district and the county's determinations
to deny the Vista legacy petition. Based on its analysis of the documentary record,
the CDE has determined that both the district and the county made written factual findings for
denial of the Vista legacy petition that are supported by evidence in accordance with education
code section 47605C. Under education code section 476052E, the lack of an abuse of discretion by
either the district or the county means that there is no basis to support a recommendation
of reversal of the districts and county's determinations to deny the Vista legacy petition.
Thank you.
Thank you very much. At this point, I will now open the public hearing at 3.30 p.m.
We will hear first from the petitioners. They will have 10 minutes to make their presentation.
We will then hear from the district and the county office of education.
They will have a combined 10 minutes to make their presentation.
After the presentations, we will open up the phone line for public comment from individuals
who are not part of either presentation. So we are now ready for the petitioners to begin.
Good afternoon, board. Quick procedural question, President Darningham. The CDE
presentation was 14 minutes. Do we not get 14 minutes as well?
You get 10 minutes. Thank you.
We're ready to begin. I'm John Lemmo, and I will be presenting first. First, I need to clarify
that SB 114 was not a clarification to law. It was a change in law. The Office of Legislative
Council, which advises the legislature on such things, said it was a change in law.
When we submitted this petition, the law was that you would find an abuse of discretion at
the district or the county or both. It has now been changed to you have to find an abuse of
discretion at both the district and county. We ask that you follow your precedent in prior examples
in the Evangelados case, which is to stick with the procedure as it was when we filed.
But in any event, we're going to cover abuses of discretion at both the county and district level.
First of all, the statutory presumption here is that charters shall be encouraged. The
legislative intent, even after AB 1505, is that the charters are supposed to provide vigorous
competition within the public school system. Specific findings are required by districts and
counties if they're going to deny. District or county shall not deny unless it makes factual
findings supported by facts in the record, not just conclusions. They can't just say the moon
is made of green cheese and have us all believe that. There has to be facts. You're still the
backstop to prevent abuse and ensure that districts and counties fulfill their obligations, and that's
all we want here. You review for abuse of discretion and you may reverse if you find that there's an
abuse. CDE has articulated what abuse of discretion means, and it's very broad. Arbitrary, capricious,
entirely lacking in support, unlawful, or procedurally unfair. But bare conclusions don't
count. You look at the documentary record. You need to harmonize that standard with the
encouragement of charter schools and vigorous competition. We are not asking the board here
to exercise this independent judgment. I don't know why the staff concluded that. You're looking
for an abuse of discretion. Here there are multiple abuses. We can't cover all of them in our 10
minutes, unfortunately. So I'm going to focus on the most obvious one that they didn't even
mention in the staff report. Failure to meet the standard under C7. C7 requires that the district
board make findings that detail, I quoted it for you here, details specific facts and circumstances
that analyze and consider the extent that the charter would substantially undermine existing
district services or programs. Not affect, not even adversely affect, but substantially undermine.
That means more than just some impact. It means cause to collapse, subvert, destroy in a large
considerable manner. Those are just dictionary definitions. Every charter school approval is
going to have some impact to some degree on a district. This is about substantially undermined.
It's about the magnitude. There's no facts or analysis whatsoever in the record discussing
substantially undermined. The district's evidence, the facts say they will lose 26 students to Vista
in year one and 105 at full enrollment. That's in the record, your document three at 1311.
26 one hundredths of one percent of enrollment is not substantially undermining. The loss of
8.9 million dollars spread over five years is less than one ten thousandth or one one hundredth of one
percent, not undermining in any way, barely negligible effect. CDE staff sort of conflates
these things by saying undermine slash impact. That's on page 12 of the staff report. That's
missing the point. The entire district's documentary record, the entire attachment three
do a word search. It doesn't even mention substantially undermined, not even mentioned,
even though we explained it. They cite the evidence of some impact, we concede that,
but not substantially undermining. I mentioned the conflating of the standard. There's no duplication
here of any existing LUSD program or school. They offer programs that are similar or the same at
different programs, but no single school offers what Vista offers. A student would have to
simultaneously enroll at at least three LUSD schools to enjoy all the offerings of this school.
The county, no specific facts or analysis whatsoever demonstrating substantially undermining.
It relies completely on the district staff report. In fact, the term substantially undermined
does not appear anywhere in the county's written opposition to this appeal. That's the attachment
seven that's in your report. They merely conclude without evidence that this school might cause
the closure of LUSD schools. That's a bare conclusion without evidence. The district says
they will lose 26 to 105 students to the district out of its 400,000 students. For both the district
and the county, the evidence does not support a finding that this school is demonstrably unlikely
to successfully implement the program and the petition. To the contrary, the evidence supports
the conclusion that school is likely to be successful. It's a highly successful operator.
I'm going to let Dr. Wilson explain that further. I have here findings that you can make that are
easy, easy swings to find abusives of discretion here and reverse the charter denial.
Good afternoon, honorable board. I'm Dr. Don Wilson, a superintendent for Vista Charter Public
Schools. Today, LUSD and LACOR, they're going to try to make a case that we are demonstrably
unlikely to be successful with our new high school. In their effort to prove their point,
you might hear them say that our budget projections provided in the petition are unsound. Yet,
we have 14 years of charter experience working with budgets over six different schools.
We have 14 years, I'm sorry, we have 10 million dollars in reserve and 13 years of receiving
the highest scores in our oversight visits with both LUSD and with OCDE. We have an impressive
bond rating that has helped us buy our two facilities and we are in the black year after
year. We clearly understand how to manage a successful budget and are demonstrably likely
to continue to do so. Today, you might hear LUSD try to paint our academic success in a negative
light in comparison to the state. 98 percent of our students are low income and their options are
not across the state and they're not even across Los Angeles, but they're within small city blocks
of where they live. When you look at our scores by neighboring schools with similar demographics,
the numbers tell a different story and when you compare our academic growth with the state growth,
regardless of demographics, it is impressive. We are outperforming the schools our students would
otherwise attend and in many cases by double digits. Spurgeon is literally across the street
from VISTA heritage and we outscored them by over 20 percentage points in ELA and three times more
in math and when comparing VISTA with the state, our middle schools far outpace the state's growth
of under two percent and we've seen growth of 11 percent in ELA and 10 growth in math just in one
year. Our students are demonstrably likely to continue to do so when they enter into our high
school. You may hear from our you may hear today that our partnership with UC Irvine is suspect.
The reality is that we have an MOU from 2021 and two years of pacing plans co-developed with the UCI
science project for the first ever climate change leadership pathway in the state of California.
Further, our dual enrollment program has had an astounding success with over 100 students
successfully completing a college course just last year. We are demonstrably likely to implement
the same program in Los Angeles. You might hear today that we have duplicative programs already
at LDSD schools. Our schools have a highly integrated social emotional program, innovative
mastery approach, integrated STEAM curriculum, dual enrollment, career pathways, leading to work
certificates and all on the foundation of our partnership with the international study school
network which provides our students with a proven global curriculum and an opportunity to take
action. While LAUSD might provide some of those programs at some other schools, not one LAUSD
school provides all of our programs at one site. A student would have to travel over 25 miles and
attend multiple schools which is illegal to get to the equivalent of our program. We stand firm
in our belief that both LAUSD and LACO abused their discretion. VISTA legacy will not substantially
undermine any LAUSD program, not even close. However, if you're inclined to defer to the district
then I would kindly ask that you defer to the 12 years of exemplary oversight visits that they've
given us, that you would defer to our six successful schools and repeated renewals each year
which all clearly show that we're not only demonstrably likely to be successful but we're
absolutely likely to continue to bless the lives of our students and families who call this to home
and we hope to do so all the way through graduation. I thank you for your time and
thank you for your support in advance of the vote.
And we're now ready for the LAUSD and county office representatives. Thank you.
And as noted you have 10 minutes between you. Thank you. Good afternoon board president,
Darlene Hammond, board members, a special congratulations to our new student board member
and all staff. My name is Jose Cole Gutierrez, director of the charter schools division
for Los Angeles Unified School District. I'm joined by general counsel team member Richard
Gonzalez and additional staff and on behalf of our board and superintendent we thank you for
your time and consideration today. As we review these slides, a question before the state board
of education is whether or not the LAUSD board of education abused its discretion when it denied
the VISTA legacy petition. As established in the documentary record as well as a CD staff report
eloquently presented today by Dr. Kim Portillo, we respectfully note in our answer is no and we
would ask the SBE to agree with that. LA Unified properly denied the VISTA legacy global petition.
I won't repeat the citations that Dr. Kim Portillo noted but they're here on the slides.
I will note however a few responses very briefly to some of the representations made by the
petitioners. First, by introducing renewal standards is different than a new petition
standard. Their oversight scores in recent years have included fours are accomplished as well as
twos developing ones unsatisfactory. Secondly, the petition was not addressed in in terms of
the reasonable comprehensiveness in response to the district's findings. That alone presents a
problem in terms of the abuse of discretion standard. We believe that SBE's adoption of
the staff recommendation would be consistent with that highest level of deference to the
local authority in accordance with the law. There is ample evidence and supporting documentation
in the findings as affirmed by CDE staff. The petitioner failed to adequately and specifically
cite to the documentary record to explain how the LA Unified board abused its discretion which
is required by law. And again, the appeal fails entirely to acknowledge the LA USD's board third
basis for denial that the petition was not reasonably comprehensive. This is tantamount
to a waiver of the appeal on this ground for denial. The law does not specify you to have
X number. It's one of those could be sufficient. That alone is not addressed and would disqualify
in our view the agreement the argument that the petitioners make that LA Unified abused its
discretion. Therefore, we conclude respectfully that the board properly denied the petition in
accordance with education code. It is established in the documentary record and discussed in our
written opposition and in staff's appeal review. We respectfully request the state board to uphold
and adopt staff's recommendation. I'll turn it over to the county.
Good afternoon, members of the state board of education. My name is Patrick Saldana. I'm the
deputy general counsel for the Los Angeles County Office of Education and I'm accompanied by Duncan
McCullough from our charter schools office. I'm here to present the Los Angeles County Board of
Education's opposition to the appeal of Vista Legacy Global Academy. We respectfully request
that the state board adopt CDE staff report and deny Vista's appeal in this matter. The CDE staff
report provides a comprehensive analysis of the appeal and administrative record and correctly
finds that no abuse of discretion occurred at either the district or county board level.
Staff correctly identified that the county board's findings are supported by evidence in the record
and the county board's meeting was conducted in accordance with its bylaws.
It is clear that petitioners appeal seeks to direct the SBE to reevaluate the evidence and
reach a different conclusion from the county boards which is not permissible under the abuse
of discretion standard. CDE staff correctly identified this issue in their report.
The CDE staff report provides an excellent explanation of the abuse of discretion standard
which applies to charter appeals. This is a highly deferential standard and deference must
be given to the decisions of the LAUSD governing board and Los Angeles County Board of Education
to deny the petition. Review is limited to determining whether the decision to deny the
charter was arbitrary, capricious, entirely lacking in evidentiary support, unlawful,
or procedurally unfair. Most notably in determining whether an abuse of discretion occurred,
the SBE may not exercise its independent judgment in reviewing the evidence in the record.
If reasonable minds may disagree as to the wisdom of the county board's action,
its determination must be upheld.
VISTA has failed to show an abuse of discretion by LACBO. Staff conducted a review of VISTA's
petition and information provided by VISTA. Based on that review and analysis and as explained in
LACBO's opposition to this appeal, the county board of education properly denied VISTA's charter.
VISTA now appeals that decision based in large part upon an absurd argument that the county
board abused its discretion by relying upon data and information provided by VISTA.
For example, VISTA applied a three-mile radius community definition in its charter petition
when it submitted its appeal to LACBO. VISTA never suggested that a different community should be
considered and did not propose any alternative analysis in any of the materials it submitted
to LACBO. So the petition was analyzed using VISTA's own data. With no legal support for
this position and citing a case that has nothing to do with the definition of community,
VISTA now contends that analyzing the petition based upon VISTA's own community definition and
data constituted an abuse of discretion. This position is without legal support.
It is plainly apparent from the appeal that VISTA seeks to have the state board apply its
independent judgment in the hope that a different outcome will be reached. However,
as the Superior Court of Sacramento County stated in the Maya Commons Charter case,
the state board has no authority to do so. Under an abuse of discretion review,
even if the state board feels a reasonable person could potentially reach a different
conclusion based upon the evidence, SBE must give deference to LACBO and uphold its decision
unless they're persuaded that no reasonable person could reach the decision LACBO reached
in this matter. VISTA has failed to meet that standard. The record demonstrably disproves
VISTA's allegations. This is a charter organization that has failed to perform basic functions
such as submitting dashboard data to CDE and takes issue with being analyzed upon its own
representations and data. VISTA also chose to wait until 4.50 p.m. the day before the LACBO meeting
to submit a 30-page response to the staff report and now seeks to invent a requirement that each
and every point in its 11th hour optional response had to be specifically rebutted by the board
on the following day. There is no such requirement under the Charter Schools Act.
Finally, VISTA's appeal demonstrates a lack of understanding of parliamentary procedure.
The County Board of Education has adopted Robert's Rules of Order.
Under Robert's Rules, motions to amend a motion which has been moved and seconded may be considered,
but a motion to amend cannot be adverse to the pending motion. An attempt to bring an adverse
motion in the guise of a motion to amend is improper and out of order and not permitted to
be acted upon. In this case, the record shows that a motion to deny VISTA's charter had been
moved and seconded. Vice President Chan subsequently indicated that she would like to move to amend
the motion to approve the charter. Dr. Chan's motion was unquestionably adverse to the pending
motion. Improper and out of order. The board proceeded properly by holding a vote on the motion
to deny the charter which was then adopted by the County Board of Education. This discontention on
this point is entirely without legal support and does not constitute an abuse of discretion.
We respectfully request that this appeal be denied. LACO staff is available for questions on this
matter. Thank you. Thank you very much. At this point, we will open the phone line for the public
comment. Are there any public commenters in the room? Yes, we have five signed up. Nicholas
Watson, Colin Felch, Karen Amaya, Angela Stiegel, and Carlos Machado, please line up.
And we can start whenever you're ready. Please give your name and affiliation for the record.
Good afternoon, members of the board. My name is Nicholas Watson. I'm speaking on behalf of
the California Charter Schools Association. CCSA supports VISTA legacy and we encourage the board
to approve this charter petition. The Charter Schools Act states that the establishment of
new charter schools should be encouraged. The act creates presumption of approval unless the
district or county adopts written factual findings specific to the petition. Neither LAUSD or LACO
made those findings. VISTA is a successful charter school operator that operates six schools,
including two schools in LAUSD. The district and county carry the burden of demonstrating
that VISTA legacy is demonstrably unlikely to succeed where the other VISTA schools have
been very successful. The district and the county also failed to adopt written findings supporting
their conclusion that VISTA legacy would substantially undermine existing services of the
district. LAUSD has more than 400,000 students enrolled and a 19 billion dollar budget. They
did not make a credible case that one new charter school could undermine the district.
We're not asking the state board to substitute its judgment for the judgment of the district
and county. We're only asking you to determine that the district and county abuse their discretion.
The state level appeal under 1505 has no value if the SBE affirms wrongful denials of petitions.
Thank you. Thank you.
Good afternoon, Dr. Colin Felch, Deputy Superintendent, VISTA Charter Public Schools.
I want to share a few important points. First, the Charter Schools Act clearly states the
establishment of charter schools shall be encouraged. I can tell you that never once
throughout this entire process were we encouraged by LAUSD or LACO staff. Rather, it's been a fairly
obvious witch hunt to try and figure out how to deny VISTA legacy. Second, according to LAUSD's
own numbers, the fiscal impact is one 10,000th of the district's budget and that is not going to
substantially undermine any programs. This could set a very dangerous precedent in California
that any minor financial impact can be deemed a substantial impact. And third, we have a sound
budget that we stand by based on our plan to co-locate at our current private site in LA.
We don't plan to use Prop 39, but if we did, LACO's assumption that our budget is incorrect,
LACO's assumption that our budget are incorrect, and it would actually cost us less.
LACO and LAUSD abuse their discretion. We are a proven charter operator with a high quality
charter petition. Thank you. Good afternoon. My name is Karen Amaya, Assistant Superintendent
of VISTA Charter Public Schools. I'm here to ask that you approve the charter petition for
VISTA Legacy Global Academy. Both LAUSD and LACO allege that our program is a duplicative program
at the district. While three LAUSD schools might offer one aspect, our programs have been
intentionally curated to provide a rigorous- Pardon me. I'm sorry to interrupt. Council,
can you advise, because I know we have very strict restrictions on 10 minutes for either side.
If we have VISTA representatives testifying outside of the 10 minutes,
I believe that may be out of order. Council.
Can I continue or-
Hold on. We just have Council weighing in with an opinion. Thank you.
Thank you. I think that's the second public comment from
VISTA, and it counts towards the 10 minute public hearing, so it would be out of order.
What 10 minutes? Council, just to clarify,
because we have a new question here. The distinction being, it's not being supporters,
it's when you actually are an employee or representative of the charter itself.
That's correct. I think the last two were representatives of the charter petitioner.
For public comment.
That's correct. Just to clarify, if there are representatives of either parties that are
offering public comment right now, that would be out of order.
Yeah, I was speaking as a member of the public. That's why I signed up for public comment.
You identified yourself as a representative of VISTA, right?
Yeah. Yeah, I'm an employee of VISTA.
I think we finished this public comment, and then I think we move on to the next. But
further public comments from representatives of either of the parties here today would be out of
order. Other employees can't make public comments? Okay, so I'll finish.
Both LAUSD and LACO allege that our program is duplicative of a program at the district.
While three LAUSD schools might offer one aspect, our programs have been intentionally curated to
provide a rigorous education and to meet the needs of our historically underserved students
and families. A VISTA student would have to enroll at three schools at once, three LAUSD
schools at once, which is illegal, to have access to all of our programs. And if a student wanted
to continue developing their global competence through high school, they would have to drive
over 20 miles to find another ISSN school, while still being duly enrolled in community
college classes. Board member Ms. Ayapan, congratulations on your appointment to our
state board. As someone who is already enrolled in high school while taking courses at Diablo
Valley College, you know the importance of access to a high-quality program. Board members, due to
the abuse of discretion, I ask for your approval of VISTA Legacy Global Academy Charter Petition.
Thank you. Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond and SBE members. My name is Angela Stiegel,
I'm a classroom teacher representing the California Teachers Association. As stated by my colleague
during public comment for item number nine, AB 1505 established an abuse of discretion standard
that is the most deferential standard of review. SB 114 further clarified that under this process,
the state board must give deference to the decisions of the governing board of the school
district and the county board of education to deny the petition. The documentary record clearly
outlines that the denials were the outcome of robust local analysis, deliberation, and governance
by the LAUSD board and the Los Angeles county board. Despite this, the petitioners are appealing
because they do not like or agree with the outcome. CTA urges the SBE to affirm the local decisions
of the LAUSD and LACBO and to deny the petitioner's abuse of discretion appeal. Thank you.
Good afternoon, President and members of the board. Carlos Machado with the California School
Boards Association. CSBA urges the board to give deference to the decisions by the governing boards
of the LA Unified School District and the LA County Board of Education in this matter as required
by law. SB 114, which changed the law and clarified that the state board may only reverse denials on
appeal if it determines that there was abuse of discretion by each of the local governing boards.
The bill further clarified that under the standard of review, the state board must give deference to
decisions of the governing board of the school district and the county board of education to
deny the petition. CSBA urges the state board to follow the staff recommendation to affirm the
determinations by the LAUSD and LACO to deny the petition. Thank you.
I take it that's all of the comment in the room. Would you like to move to public comment on the
telephone? Okay, good afternoon. Caller ending in 2698. Please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
We can't really hear you. Would you mind speaking up a little bit?
Good afternoon. My name is Nathan Molina. I am a student at Vista Charter Middle School. As a sixth
grade student, I love the support I get from my teachers. They are helping me academically
and motivating me to be successful in all my subjects. I want to continue studying in a high
quality program like Vista Legacy High School. Please approve Vista Legacy Global Academy.
Don't take away my option to choose the best school for me. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 0287. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Caller ending in 0287. Please begin your public comment.
I am here to ask you, as parents, to listen to our request that you approve Vista Legacy
Global Academy, as my son has had a good academic and emotional performance as a father. We like
security, preparation, and trust for our children. Please don't take away the opportunity for our
children to be better citizens for this country. Thank you.
Hello, my name is Elvia Carrillo. I'm a parent of a third grade student at Vista. As a parent,
I'm asking the board to please approve the petition. We want good academic and emotional
support for our kids and safe environments. Please don't hinder the opportunities for them.
Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 2550. Please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Patricia Santillan. I am a parent of a student in the seventh grade.
I have to tell you that Vista Middle School, I am delighted with the academic level that I have seen.
And it's been very good for my daughter. As parents, we want you to approve the school.
We are entitled to have a safe environment for our children, and I demand the approval
of the petition. As a parent, I don't get bothered by driving 10 miles a day
so that my child can go to Vista and enjoy such a great academic level.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 9247. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Thank you. My name is Maria Ramirez. I'm a parent of a seventh grader. She has an IEP currently.
She did not want to go to school before, and now she's 100% in and happy to be going there.
She is safe. She feels happy. We as parents want to continue to have the possibility to send our
kids to Vista. Please approve Vista School for us. We want to have opportunities. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 9905. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Caller ending in 9905, please begin.
Next caller ending in 6846. Please start your public comment.
Good afternoon. My name is Paula Molina, and I'm a parent of a sixth grade student at Vista
Charter Middle School. I've seen the positive impact my kid has developed for learning and
being more interested in more subjects than at his elementary school. We hope to continue
as students in LA can continue with the high quality programs of Vista Legacy
Global Academy. My plan is for my students to attend Vista Legacy. Please do not take that
choice away from my son, and I approve our Vista High School. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller
ending in 2337. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Mi nieto ha subido de nivel acadmico, grado acadmico. Esperemos continuar con los estudiantes
en Los ngeles que puedan continuar con los programas de alta calidad y de Vista
Legacy Global Academy. Les pido que aprueben la escuela Vista Legacy High School. Gracias.
Good afternoon. My name is Josefina Martinez. I am the grandmother of a sixth grader.
My grandson has been taking advantage of the high quality of the academic level,
and we ask you for the students of Los Angeles to be able to have the opportunity to have high
quality academics at Vista Legacy Global School, and I ask you to please approve the high school
associated with this petition. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 8963.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Next caller ending in 8963. Please begin your public comment.
Hello. My name is Sammy Salasoli. I am a seventh grader attending Vista Charter Middle School,
and today I'm here to advocate for my fellow peers and I to ask for a high school,
as I know that having a new high school will benefit us in many ways. Gaining sports skills
from me being in soccer team two times has shown me leadership for giving captain privileges and,
most importantly, for having opportunities to continue and grow memories with my fellow peers
until we make it a college into our next big step. One of the other experiences I had at Vista
is leadership. After school, there's a group called leadership and they teach us how to be a leader
and how to help out around the community. As we've been fighting for a chance to keep our
family together, we hope you will understand as we truly to our goals and give us opportunities
for the students and our future, future new students. Please open our high school. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 7722. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Carmen Pastor. I'm the mother of a sixth grader in Vista Middle School.
He was very low in writing and reading, but in Vista Middle he has had a great experience
and improved a lot. Please, I ask the board don't stop our kids from having this opportunity.
Please approve the petition. We want to continue studying at Vista. Thank you very much.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 2799. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Maria Espinoza. I have two children in Vista Middle School,
in grade seven and eight. They were in another school, but they always told me that they were
bad. But thank God that I changed them and I am very grateful to Vista Middle School and
their teachers, who are very professional. Now my children are in and out of school. I tell them
all their subjects and they feel more secure. Now they know that what they propose they can do.
That is why I ask you to give us the permission for the preparatory school,
Vista, so that they continue well or better every day. Thank you.
Good afternoon. My name is Maria Espinoza. I have two children at Vista, one in seventh grade and
one in eighth grade. Before, they weren't doing that well at other schools. Thank God,
we had Vista as an option and the teachers there are magnificent. Now my children
are obtaining As and A pluses in all their classes and they're of maximum quality.
Um, we ask you to please approve the proposal of having
this wonderful school available to them. Now they believe that whatever they propose
to achieve, it's achievable and it's going to be good or even better if this school is approved.
Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 3052. Please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello, good afternoon. My name is Jocelyn Miranda.
I'm a parent of two students in the middle school, one in sixth grade and the other in eighth grade.
My kids both have received lots of help, particularly in English and math. We are very
happy to have them in Vista Middle and today I'm asking the board to please approve their petition
so that they continue with this educational process. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller
ending in 6207. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Yeah, good afternoon. My name is Ana Lopez. I am the mother of an eighth grader. I like this school
very much because it makes them achieve higher standards academically.
I already have two children that went through Vista. The eldest is already at university
and the second one is in 12th grade at high school. Please, as a mom, I recommend this.
That's why as a mother I recommend this school and I implore to you to please approve this school
because that way I don't have to go around looking for a high school and I ask you to
please approve Vista Legacy Global Academy High School. Thank you. Next caller ending in 8171.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Caller ending in 8171. Please begin your public comment.
Hello, good afternoon. My name is Marta Ventura. I'm the mother of an eighth grader at Vista Middle.
I'm asking you to please let us have the opportunity to have this high school.
It's good academics and it's a safe environment. Today, I'm talking to you to again ask you to
please approve the opening of the high school for our kids' safety and success. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 8572. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, good afternoon. My name is Nico and I'm an eighth grader at Vista Charter Middle School.
The reason I would like to continue as a Vista Legacy student is because of the wonderful
experiences. Some of the experiences I've been through the school years I've been here is Baltimore,
Think Together and Leadership. Now I'm going to talk about my experiences versus Baltimore.
In Baltimore, we presented on the stray animal problems in LA to a group of important people.
After that presentation, we were able to go to important monuments, which could only be a once
in a lifetime opportunity. Next, we're going to talk about leadership. Leadership helped me
with being a leader and many fun opportunities. One of the opportunities was being able to go to
Disneyland as we were able to go to Disneyland through our hard work and it's also a leadership
conference. After that, we were going to talk about Think Together. Think Together is one of
the best after school programs. It's one of the best because of yes clubs. Some of the clubs are
basketball, football, arts and crafts. Think Together gives great opportunities to go places.
For example, two weeks ago we went to the Dodger Stadium and went world watching. Those field trips
were extremely fun and exciting. Okay, thank you. Your time is up. Next caller ending in 0127,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Sonia Rivera. I am a mother and a student in the eighth grade
of the Vista Charter Middle School. As a mother, I am proud that my daughter
continues to receive the best education in the Charter Middle School.
I demand the approval of the preparatory Vista Legacy Global Academic. Thank you. God bless you.
Good afternoon. My name is Sonia Rivera and I am the mother of an eighth grader at Vista Charter
Middle School. As a mother, I'm very proud that my daughter can enjoy a better education at
Charter, at this Vista Charter Middle School and I am demanding the approval of this high school.
Thank you and may God bless you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 5379,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hola, buenas tardes. Mi nombre es Ana y soy madre de un estudiante de sptimo grado. Mi estudiante
ha tenido muy buena experiencia en Charter Middle School y me gustara que mi estudiante
contina aprendiendo ms. Ella se ha desarrollado mucho y necesitamos que Vista Legacy Global
Academy pueda ser aprobada para que pueda mi hija seguir preparndose para poder llegar a la
universidad. Esperamos que sea aprobada. Gracias. Good afternoon. My name is Ana.
I'm a mother of a seventh grader in Vista Middle. So far it's been a very good experience for all
of us. She's learned and she's made up academic progress. I want to ask the board to please approve
Vista High School so that my daughter can continue with her academic process. Thank you. Thank you.
Next caller ending in 6814, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Nadia. I'm an eighth grader at Vista Charter Middle School.
My experience here at Vista has impacted my everyday life in terms of school and sports.
One way that it has impacted me is by playing sports because it has helped me to learn leadership
skills but also how to work as a team with other students. The teachers at Vista have supported me
in learning new academic skills and have good grades. Vista has forever been my home and I
truly believe it has helped me grow into the person I am today. With that being said,
I would love to continue to go through Vista Legacy. One last reason as to why I believe
the school will benefit myself and my peers is because I will be familiar with
the people that enroll there but also have the opportunity to be part of such a loving environment
that cares about my well-being, my community, and my education as a whole. For that reason,
I want to petition for the approval of the High School Vista Legacy Global Academy to further
my education. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 7583. Please state your
name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello. My name is Eric Molina. I have three children in the Vista Charter School system.
One child who has done the transition from elementary to middle school. I have seen
a major improvement on all three of them. An example, when you cut the process of an
athletic team or any other kind of team that is giving you extremely good results,
you undermine the potential success and the legacy of the team. I please ask you to not
undermine the success of our children over administrative issues. Thank you. Thank you.
Next caller ending in 3543. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Magda de Leon Rios. It's an honor to be here. I'm a parent of a
fifth grade student, also a student that is currently in university. She was part of this
The reason I'm here is to support Vista Legacy Global Academy. To approve the school,
it will create access community for the students. My experience has been very satisfactory.
I need for a school that are stable, safe, with a great environment. Values and of course,
high academic, which I found all at Vista. For Vista, the most important thing are their students
and their academic progress. They want to ensure that students have a bright and safe
and successful future. I'm really proud that my children are part of Vista. And for that,
I would love to see you approve Vista Legacy Global Academy. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller
ending in 6137. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now. Good afternoon. My name is Bissell and I am a proud eighth grade student at
Vista Targon Middle School. Me and my classmates are here to petition for the new Vista Legacy
Global Academy. I have never regretted the decision of joining the Vista family. The reason I would
love to continue the amazing experience is for the wonderful opportunities I have had throughout
the years. For example, I have the opportunity to present at Baltimore, Maryland. This is thanks
to the amazing leadership team and the wonderful teachers such as Mr. Kawano. I have always felt
safe and supported, never unheard. I would appreciate the opportunity to continue my education
with Vista Legacy Global Academy. Vista has made me who I am today and I will forever be a part of
this amazing family. This is why I would like to continue my journey with Vista Legacy. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 2078. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello, good afternoon. My name is Patricia Kallel. I am a mother of a seventh grade student
at Vista Targon Middle School. This is the second grade of my daughters here at this school
where I have learned. I have seen how they have advanced in such a short time,
waiting for my daughter to continue here at this school in Vista for the quality in everything
she has learned. Please approve Vista Legacy Global Academy so that we have a secondary school
for our students in Los Angeles. My plan is that my students attend Vista. Please don't take away
that option and approve our preparatory school Vista. Thank you very much. God bless you.
Yes, good afternoon. My name is Patricia Salen. I am the mother of a student in seventh grade at
Vista Charter Middle School. This is the second year that my daughter has been attending the Vista
Charter School and she's learned so much and has advanced so much in such little time.
We're hoping that she can continue in Vista and continuing to learn with the high quality
that is provided to her. Please approve for the sake of the students in Los Angeles.
My plan is for my daughter to continue studying. Please do not take away this option and approve
the Vista Legacy Global Academy High School. Thank you very much and God bless you.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 1496. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Erica Menendez and I am a current Vista Charter Middle School parent
of a student with disabilities in the eighth grade. I am calling in to demand that our high
school Vista Legacy Global Academy be allowed to open and serve my child and serve the community.
We have been waiting for this high school for many years. I am worried about my child's needs
not being met at the local high school, the high school that they are assigned to attend
because of our address and zip code. I know the local high schools and I know they will not support
my child the way Vista does. I know this because I attended the high schools and nothing has changed
since the 90s. Vista Charter Middle School has provided my child with special education services
for the past two years with no issues or concerns. They have started to shape my
child to be a global citizen and I want them to continue at Vista Legacy. I want my child to
continue with the Vista family. I want them to continue to receive the support they need
along with the love and care that the Vista Charter Middle School team has provided for the
past two years. Please allow our high school to open to better serve the needs of our community.
Thank you for your time. Thank you. Next caller ending in 3393,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Adela. I'm a mom of an eighth grader in Vista Middle School.
Vista has had a very positive impact in my child. He has straight A's and a 4.0 GPA.
We want to continue to have the opportunity to have my child in these high quality programs.
Please I ask the board to respect our decision on what is best for our kids and please accept
the continuation of Vista High School. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 1799,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Beatriz Lovera. I'm a mom of a seventh grader in Vista Charter Middle
School. This is my sixth year in Vista and all this time my children have received a high quality
education and a safe socio-emotional environment with principles based on responsibility, empathy,
perseverance and respect. I understand that around our area we have several schools,
but unfortunately they do not meet my expectations, so I ask for your support to
approve a preparatory school that promotes the same values of Vista Charter Middle School.
I consider that as parents we have the right to choose a safe school for our children
and that our postal code does not define the future and education of our young people.
I ask for your support not as professionals but as parents. Thank you.
Good afternoon. My name is Beatriz Lopez. I am the mother of a seventh grader at Vista Charter
Middle School. I currently have a child in sixth grade at Vista Middle School. I've been with Vista
with the program at Vista for six years and I've seen my children enjoy high quality schooling
in a safe environment, safe emotional environment with high standards and great values where they
teach the students to have empathy, resiliency and respect. There are many schools surrounding
my vicinity but none of them of the standards and value of Vista. Please don't allow that a zip code
can define our children's destiny and I'm not asking you this as a professional
but as a parent to please approve the high school. Thank you. Next caller,
ending in 6544, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
My name is Isabel and I am a parent of a seventh grade student at Vista Charter Middle School.
My daughter has struggled in the past with elementary school that she was before she
got to sixth grade but Vista Middle School has helped her a lot to reach her great level standards
and because of that she now has straight A's and I want to continue with the high quality
program of Vista Legacy Global Academy. Please I ask you approve Vista Legacy so we
have a Vista High School for our students in Los Angeles.
Thank you. Next caller, ending in 0818, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Sandra Jimenez. I have a son who is in fourth grade at Vista Academy.
I am worried about you not accepting this approval. My son has had a greatly positive
academic impact. He is learning excellent English and I would like to see you guys
approve the school and give this opportunity not only to my son but to the rest of the children
so that they can enjoy this type of education.
I am a firm believer of better quality and not quantity within the classroom. They receive
a lot of attention because there is no more than 30 students per classroom. I highly recommend
you approve this Vista School. Again, I reiterate, it is better to have quality and not quantity.
And what is better than children taking advantage of good education? Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, ending in 4771, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Lyla Garcia. I'm a student at Palm Lane Global Academy, part of Vista School.
I have great teachers and staff. I wish the state gives my peers in Los Angeles County
to have equality of education as mine.
Thank you. Next caller, ending in 5237, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
I am a student at Palm Lane Global Academy, part of Vista School. I wish the state gives
my peers in Los Angeles County, part of Vista School. I have great teachers and staff. I wish the state gives
my peers in Los Angeles County, part of Vista School. I have great teachers and staff. I have great teachers and staff.
I have great teachers and staff.
Good afternoon. My name is Olga Cruz. I am the mother of a student in 11th grade at Vista
Global Academy High School in Santa Ana. I want to talk about how much development I've seen,
not only academically, but in sports with my daughter. The teachers there have empowered
my daughter so much that she is taking college classes and honor classes. Not only that, she's
in the volleyball and the soccer team, and I would like for the families in Los Angeles
to have a high school so that the youth in LA have the same support and success that I've seen at Santa Ana.
Thank you. Next caller, ending in 9848, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is Ricardo Vasquez. I am the parent of a child at Vista. He's in 11th grade
at the high school in Santa Ana, and as a citizen, I can see the importance of having a high quality
school. My experience is that I've seen that my daughter has
exceeded and grown academically. It's important for the community to have these high standards.
Also, the professionalism at the school is tremendous, from the receptionist upward.
It's like a big family there. They make the students and the children feel at home.
The professionalism is outstanding, and they support the children so that they can
excel in life, and they personally motivate them to continue studying and get to the university to
continue their studies. That's the reason of my call. If you could please approve the high school
in LA. Thank you. Next caller, ending in 9349,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello. My name is Soyla. I am the parent of four students. My oldest was not able to
attend the high school that is here now, but my three other children are at the middle school and
the elementary. My first one was very sad about that, by the way. I am a proud parent. I've been
with VISTA for about six or seven years here in Santa Ana. One of my children is in special
education, and with the help of VISTA, Condor Global Academy, he went from being a non-verbal
child to a verbal child. I also would like to point out that these and more parents showed up
to the city and the county. This is why we are here, because the community spoke, and we were
not listened. They did not only deny the schools every single time that they petitioned them,
they also denied the community, as you can hear today. So I am calling in support of VISTA
Legacy Global Academy, because the LA Middle School students deserve a community school.
Thank you. Your time is up. Next caller, ending in 9352.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Caller ending in 9352.
I am calling in support of the LA School of VISTA because my children are currently going
to this school in Santa Ana, and they have helped them a lot. They have special classes.
Currently, where they came to this school, they fought a lot to find them, because they
did not find that they had the services that they needed in their IEP, or in others they did not have
enough space for more students. So when I came to see them, they immediately accepted them,
and they have helped them a lot in their studies. Thank you very much, and thank you for everything.
Good afternoon. My name is Rosario Ruiz. I am the mother of Gianluca in the 9th grade and Alexandra
in the 11th grade. They attend Santa Ana High School, and I am here to support the opening of
the LA High School. My children, they have helped them a great deal. They attend special classes.
We were unable to find services like they offer at VISTA elsewhere, either because
they didn't offer them or because they didn't have space. And when we came to VISTA,
they were accepted immediately, and they have been supported tremendously academically and
in all ways. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 9877, please state your
name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Caller ending in 9877, please begin your public comment.
Next caller ending in 3791, please begin your public comment.
Hello. Good afternoon. My name is Monica Chabon. I have a student that attends the 6th grade at
VISTA Charter School. I am asking you to please approve VISTA Global Academy High School.
My child enjoys excellent and high-quality education. I am very happy that my son can
be part of such a program, and he feels happy and secure and safe, and that's why I'm asking you to
please approve the school. Thank you. Next caller ending in 6344, please state your name
and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
It looks like the caller dropped.
And catch his name.
Good afternoon. I am a student of the 7th grade. I've had a wonderful experience. I've learned
great abilities at the school. I'm asking you to please open the school so that we can have,
all the students can have the great opportunities that I've had. They have not only helped me
academically, but they help us to learn all sorts of things, including empathy and other values.
Thank you very much. Thank you. Next caller ending in 2845,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello. My name is Susan Mott. I'm the executive director of Generation Now Initiative at VISTA
Global Academy. We have been working with VISTA for the past three years. Our goal is to provide
young people for life in the 21st century by providing them the knowledge, skills,
and experiences needed to find solutions for the sustainability of our planet.
VISTA was invited by the University of California Irvine to participate in the launch of the Eclipse
Initiative, an initiative of the UC and CSU systems, the environmental and climate change projects.
A VISTA alumni was selected to be one of the main speakers at this UC event. She represented all the
young people of this generation who are taking action to create a sustainable planet. This year
we are working with UCI and the business community to develop career paths in the sustainable pathways
that will act as a model for schools throughout California. Thank you. Your time is up.
Next caller ending in 7600, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Alviera, VISTA charter school board member. I know the big question is why. I think the simple
answer is to help our students speak higher education. Their fate and their educational
journey is at your doorstep. We know that LACO had a split vote of 4-3, which we think that
does speak volumes in relation to having three board members approve our petition. We really
do ask that you let our students continue their educational pathways so they may pave their own
legacy. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending in 5808, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now. My name is Rainbow Crew Munoz.
I'm a parent of a first grader at Tomlin Global Academy charter school in Anaheim.
My son didn't even want to come to school before. He would cry and say he didn't want to go to
school. He loves all the teachers and the staff and the principal and everybody so much. Now he
makes excuses to stay after school just to visit with everybody and stay longer because he feels
so comfortable here. Thank you. Sorry, please continue. Are you finished? Yes. Thank you very
much. Next caller ending in 0012, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You
have one minute. Your time starts now. Hi, my name is Maria. I am the sister of a student who
goes here to Tomlin. She has been coming to Tomlin since 2018 and since this has been affiliated,
she has had an immediate impact from the educators and the students in the community.
She is now a educator and she started when she was in first grade.
So she was non-verbal and extremely aggressive since she started with the elementary.
She has been able to talk and express her feelings through words and it's been a tremendous change
in her life and ours. So we support Vista and we would love to see
this high school appear for her and she would be honored to go to this school. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller ending in 8945, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now. This is Suzanne Cooey of the Charter School
Development Center. Thank you for giving your time, board members, to this item.
CSPC supports reversing the local decisions because we believe the petitioners have submitted
extensive evidence of abuse of discretion at both the district and county boards.
We believe CDE's analysis misses some important key context. Specifically, California appellate
courts have ruled that even the most deferential standard needs to be applied in the larger
statutory context. Statute mandates that the establishment of charter schools shall be
encouraged. The district and county have a burden to meet the standards such as demonstrably unlikely
to succeed. We believe the scant findings of the district and county do not meet even the most
deferential standard. CDE's analysis misses this. Your action today is important to signal the
importance of robust evidence-based decisions. Thanks so much. Thank you. Next caller ending in
6337, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts
now. Caller ending in 6337, please start your public comment.
This is Michelle Bauer. Can you hear me? Yes, please begin.
Oh, I have a different number. Thank you. I am a board member. I'm a lifetime educator with 40
plus years of experience. I am also an attorney and I agree with the conviction that the evidence
did not show that VISTA would not succeed. VISTA has a terrific success record,
astounding success record. The community wants to send their children onto the high school and I
implore decision makers to please vote in favor of VISTA continuing with the high school. Thank
you very much. Thank you. Next caller ending in 9905, please state your name and affiliation for
the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Caller ending in 9905, please start your public comment.
Hello, my name is Emmanuel Rodriguez and I'm part of the VISTA community. I'm in eighth grade and
I'm in VISTA. My experience in VISTA has been an enormous opportunity for me and for my
little sister. Ever since my little sister went to VISTA Horizon, I've been very and deeply grateful
for VISTA because before she was in another school, she was very behind and she didn't know
anything. Now that she's in VISTA, I've seen immense improvement with her and her grades.
VISTA has offered me so many things such as the Baltimore project and all it takes. These things
have helped me grow in my social skills and everything else. I'm so grateful for VISTA and
I beg you to please open VISTA Legacy because I wish that me and my little sister can have an
opportunity to go to VISTA and be in VISTA until college. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller ending
in 9877, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time
starts now. Are you able to hear me? Yes. Hi, good afternoon. My name is David Levinson. I am a
sixth grade elementary school teacher at Santa Monica Boulevard Charter School. We are about
three miles away from VISTA. I have been working at this school for 25 years. I can speak firsthand
on saying that I know practically every single middle school and high school within a 10-mile
radius. I work as part of my job with helping matriculate our students into middle schools
and for the last several years VISTA has always been my number one choice. I have several students
past and present that I am still in touch with that have attended VISTA and I know firsthand the
administration and many of the staff members there and I can tell you that it would definitely
benefit the local community if the VISTA Legacy was able to continue and move on as a high school.
I strongly support that you make a positive decision and help these students that are currently
attending VISTA to move on to the same high school. Thank you very much. Thank you. This
concludes public comment for item number 10. Thank you very much. I ask all the board members
to get ready for discussion and I will at this point declare the public hearing closed at 5.01
p.m. and I'll ask our liaisons if they want to make any public comments by Vice President
Glover-Woods and Member Olken. Thank you President Darling-Hammond. I'd first like to thank all of
the parents that called in and the students who spoke so eloquently both those who called
in from Los Angeles and those who've called in from Orange County. Thank you so much for sharing
your thoughts and your passion about VISTA. I just would like to as we get ready to get into our
discussion as a board just reiterate our role as a board as it relates to charter appeals.
Understanding that we do have two options. One is to overturn the decisions of the county board
and the school district if there is an abuse of discretion and we'll need to be clear on what that
abuse of discretion is or to uphold the decisions that were made at the district and county board
level. So that's all I'll say at this point. I'll leave it for a conversation and share more
thoughts as we move forward. Thank you. Member Olken. Thank you. Yeah I want to echo the
gratitude for those who called in and as a school leader those are exactly the types of
testimony that you just hope for and you know it's how you know you're making a difference
and so you know I appreciate those who called in and I also appreciate what we heard about
the great work of VISTA in both LA and Orange County. Just want to start with that and you know
I echo what Vice President Glover-Wood said about remembering what our role is here today
in terms of within the confines of 1505. And I do also think you know I know I have some questions
that I'd like to have some clarification on but I think it's important that we keep in mind
well both the confines of 1505 but also has been brought up on multiple occasions. The
intent of charter school law which hasn't changed which is that that charter schools
the establishment of charter schools should be encouraged and supported unless there's
period that they should be supported and encouraged as part of the public school system.
I just want to put that in as well. Thank you. I'm going to also add a comment and then hopefully
we can work with you on that. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
I move to discussion and emotion. I also very much appreciate the callers, the parents and the
students who called in. I do want to clarify that under the current law it is not our role to approve
the charter only to evaluate whether there's been an abuse of discretion. So that's I think
there's sometimes a little misunderstanding about what we are being asked to do. We are not in a
position to approve the charter in our role. Current law specifies that the state board can
only reverse a decision of the district and the county upon a finding of abuse of discretion at
both levels. That it is the most deferential standard of review that it does not permit us
to reevaluate the evidence that was considered by the district and the county boards or to
exercise our independent judgment on that evidence. So there may be tension between
the original charter law and AB 1505 and SB 114. However, it is not our role to resolve that
tension. That's something that will have to be done by the legislature. So our framework is that
we've been instructed that if there's at least one ground of denial where there was no evidence
of an abuse of discretion, the law dictates that the charter denial will be upheld.
And based on the documentary record, I believe there is at least one such ground for denial that
we are obligated under the law to uphold because the petitioner did not contend it was an abuse
of discretion. And in the record we have before us, the petitioner did not challenge LAUSD's
finding that the petition did not contain reasonably comprehensive descriptions of all 15
required elements of a charter petition under 47605. So I do believe that applying the appropriate
level of deference to the district and county's findings as required by the abuse of discretion
standard, there does not appear to be an adequate support for us to overturn the decision of the
district and the county. And while we might have wanted to approve the charter if that was our
role, that is not the decision that we have before us. And with that I'll open it to any
other questions, discussion, and eventually a motion. Yes, Member Olken.
Thank you. You touched on exactly where my question is and so thank you for teeing me up
and also for, you know, framing the discussion and what's on the table and what is not. I
appreciate that. So my questions are, I think, for the department just as a preface. And they're
intended to check and clarify my understanding of the standard of review that we are operating in.
So sort of I start with a couple of things I think everybody agrees on. So I think everybody,
I heard consistently that our review is limited to determining whether the decision to deny the
charter was arbitrary, capricious, entirely lacking in evidentiary support, unlawful or
procedurally unfair, right? Everyone agrees on that. It also seems that everyone agrees with
the idea that governing boards at the district and county must make written factual findings
if they deny. Yeah, okay. So one place where I did hear, I think, a difference in interpretation
of the law from those who presented was the point that President Darling-Hammond just made about,
well, this statement, which is in, I think it's on slide four from your presentation.
If even one basis for denial is supported by evidence and the record,
the determination to deny should be affirmed. So let me go back to,
yep, so on yours under standard of review, it's slide four. It's the last bullet. If even one
basis for denial is supported by evidence and the record, the determination to deny should be
affirmed. I definitely heard a different interpretation of the standard in the
presentation from the petitioners, and so I'm asking if you can help me understand how we got
to that understanding of the law. Thank you.
Thank you for your question, Member Olken. I'm going to go ahead and pass it over to Craig
Heimbichner. He's the education administrator for our charter schools division. Thank you.
Thank you, Nancy. Thank you, Member Olken. Maybe the easiest way to get at this one is to reference
the Maya Commons court case and the comments of Judge Chang, and Judge Chang did emphasize
that a finding could only be an abuse of discretion if it was entirely lacking in
evidentiary support. So if we turn that around, it would mean that there would only be an abuse
of discretion if there was no supported basis for denial. You unpack that one more level,
and that means that a district or county really only needs one basis to deny a petition, and
therefore it puts a burden on the petitioner to show that all findings are unsupported. So
if there's only one, that ruling said basically there's an evidentiary basis and it couldn't be
an abuse of discretion. So that would be our basic way to understand that in the light of the latest
latest court ruling on this. Thank you. This is important enough that I would, because I'm a,
I want to make sure I really get it. Can you say it one more time just to make sure I
Yes. You were clear it's just a lot for me to
Oh, I totally sympathize with all of the, you're hearing many different interpretations of
standard of review, and that can be a bit confusing. I totally understand that,
and that's why I wanted to really reference the most recent court ruling on this that applies
directly to a charter school that came before this body. And that court ruling did say that
a finding could only be an abuse of discretion if it was entirely lacking in evidentiary support.
That means that if there's one finding it's not entirely lacking in evidentiary support,
if one is upheld, if one is not addressed by the petitioner and it stands, then it can't possibly
be an abuse of discretion. That's our basis for continuing to apply the standard of review the
way we do. I hope that answers your question. I think I see maybe Council coming up to step in.
Yeah, thank you. Len Garfinkel.
Thank you. Yeah, thank you. And thank you, Craig.
What Craig said, I mean, it really ties back to in the statute in 47605C,
where it refers to the denial of the petition being supported by one or more of the following
finding. And so if the district laid out three different bases, or the county laid out two
different bases for why they were denying, if one of those bases is supported, that's sufficient.
Thank you. That makes sense. Just to push for one more second,
I could imagine a scenario in which there would be a finding that is
not, that is, that stands in essence. But there's also places that are capricious, unlawful,
total, like within, within the process. But I'm trying to stay really clear on what I'm asking.
Are you asking, Sharon, whether if there is something about the proceedings that is arbitrary
or capricious, even if there is one? Yeah, I mean, if you have a finding whether,
so if you had, if you, I mean, if you had, because
the point that you made, President Ellingham, and that about the specific finding that wasn't
addressed in the appeal, you know, was, I think makes sense and is clear. Like, I agree with you
that way. And I could envision, you know, the findings are all, the findings are based on fact,
and yet, the, you know, the process is, is unfair or, or capricious, right? And so,
and so it's, if that's the, if needing to, if anytime there's one finding that isn't
refuted by the petitioner, the petition, we cannot overturn the lower, the rulings.
I feel like we're only honoring part of what the statute says.
Well, we've read the statute in progression, right, where it says that the role is...
Lynn, can you get close to the microphone? Thank you.
The, the way the statute reads is, can affirm, or then, or...
Maybe turn it on, also.
Both of those things are important. You can affirm or deny for abusive discretion at both levels,
right? And so, when the decision can be affirmed, that, in a sense, ends that discussion. There
was not an abuse of discretion because the decision can be affirmed because the findings
were supported. I think the question may be framed a different way. Could there be a situation
where there was so significant a procedural error that, you know, it constitutes an abuse
of discretion of, you know, whether or not findings are supported? You know, I think what
we would need to do here is simply look at this case and what was found here. I know that the
CDE's findings say that, procedurally, they're not finding any abuse of discretion in any event.
So, it may be sort of a hypothetical question with respect to this case.
Yes, I think what you...
Would you like to encourage us to leave the hypothetical questions?
No, I appreciate that was, yeah, that was...
So, that was, that was, thank you. The way you just described that was very helpful,
both in that it was a hypothetical concern that I have,
and also the way you described, you, you reframed my question appropriately. So, thank you. I appreciate that.
Are there any other further questions? Any further discussion? Or is there a motion?
We have a motion for the recommendation. Member Lewis,
is there any further discussion of the motion?
All right, with that, all in favor say aye. Raise your hand. Aye. Any opposed? Any abstentions?
I'm allowed to abstain.
You're allowed to abstain. You're allowed to oppose or abstain, whatever you want to do.
All right, one abstention and the motion carries.
If you can manage it, I'd like to not take a break at this moment
and just continue on to the close of the meeting. Is that okay? All right, and if you need a break,
you know, take one individually.
We're going to reopen item one to take action on the preliminary report of actions draft July
2023 meeting minutes and report on our liaison assignments. And while we're waiting for any
members of the public to call in, we'll need that public comment up. Do I have a motion from a board
member to approve the July 2023 State Board of Education draft preliminary report of action
meeting minutes? Member Rodriguez, thank you. And do I have a second? Second. Member Glover Woods,
is there any public comment?
There are no callers in the queue. Any further discussion? All right, all in favor say aye.
And I'll show your hands, aye. Any opposed? Any abstentions? Anya.
And now we have our liaison reports and I'll just encourage people to be succinct because some folks
have travel arrangements and I'm trying to be respectful of those arrangements that they may
be trying to make. And I'm going to begin by calling on board members in alphabetical order
and I'll start, if that's okay, with our new member, Aya Pan. Of course. Can you hear me? Perfect.
So since the application for the 24-25 student board member to the State Board of Education
has been posted, I've been working with various students and student groups to get that publicized
and out to as many people as possible. I was able to share the application with more than 50
district student board members for them to apply if they're a junior and eligible
or for them to pass on that information to student advisory groups within their district
if they're interested. I've also begun collaborating with the California Association of Student
Councils who runs the Student Advisory Board and Education Conference in November and are a key
member of the selection process for the student board member role. So we've begun conversations,
they've been able to post the application through their channels of communication
and I look forward to staying in close contact with them and I have some meetings arranged
with students from across the state of California so I'm really looking to hearing those diverse
perspectives. I'll just keep it short so I'll leave it at that. Member Escobedo.
Yes, as part of my role as the Westad Liaison, I spent a few days helping with the finalists
and making a decision on the next CEO and proud to say to everyone that Janelle Kubanek
is the new CEO for Westad. She was the organization's chief executive officer,
administrative officer, she brings 24 years of experience, she's no stranger to California,
she worked as a associate vice president for school services of California as well. She was
a senior fiscal and policy analyst in our LAO so she knows California and would be great and we
say goodbye to Glenn Harvey who was a CEO for 26 years. Amazing legacy. Yeah and under her
leadership, Westad established itself as one of the nation's premier non-partisan research,
development, and service organizations and I thank my colleagues. So many of my colleagues
will be going to our NASB annual conference in San Diego on October 25th through 28th and
looking forward to seeing many of you there. Thank you. Janelle has worked, she was very
involved in the development of the dashboard and a lot of the other things that we work on today.
Vice President Glover Woods. Thank you. Just a couple of quick updates regarding the CCEE
California Collaborative for Educational Excellence. The first in-person meeting since the pandemic
took place on August 31st, we got to hear an update on the schools that are receiving direct
technical assistance from the organization. I also want to lift up that the Learning Acceleration
Systems Grant. Under that particular grant there will be the 2023-24 Literacy and Mathematics
Community of Practice. The Language Arts or the Literacy, I'm sorry the Mathematics has already
begun but educators can join. The second session of the math will take place in October and the
Literacy sessions will begin September 19th. I encourage everyone who may be interested please
go to the website to get more information and lastly just wanted to lift up that the system
of support which is another important component of our Accountability and Continuous Improvement
System is also undergoing evaluation from the CCEE from the RTI group and again more information
is available on the website. Thank you. Thank you. Member Lewis.
Just want to give an update both Vice President Glover Woods and I are liaisons in the Structural
Quality Commission so I'll just give the update for today. There hasn't been a meeting since our
last SBE meeting so the next meeting for the IEQC will be next Wednesday and for anyone
interested the agenda has already been posted. Last week there are two key agenda items for next
week and the first is just a revision of the 2024 meeting dates and then the second item is
proposed revised guidance for the local instructional materials adoptions. These were
reviewed and modified by the IEQC at the March 2023 meeting. Also at next week's meeting the IEQC
will review the edits and consider recommending the document to the SBE later on this fall.
It will be an in-person meeting and it will be broadcast via the live stream. Also the other
thing the other item and I think you mentioned this earlier there's some new member recruitment
going on the SBE and the CDE are currently recruiting four new IEQC members along with
one student member starting in 2024. We have four members who term out in December 31st and our
student terms out in June of 2024 so that's it. You are all great role models. Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Thank you. I already reported a bit so I know that in the interest of time I just want to
speak a little bit about the comprehensive redesign and reporting enhancements for the
CASP and LPAC. Student score reports will have other significant benefits to teachers in the
classroom in several ways. One of my key points is the professional development component the
availability of resources such as the interim assessment fact sheets and user guides will
support teachers in understanding and effectively using the new interim assessments. The professional
learning opportunities and training modules will further equip educators with the knowledge
and skills needed to leverage these assessments to enhance their classroom practices and overall
the redesigned and reporting enhancements of the reports and LPAC assessments will empower
educators and families with more clear more actionable and timely information.
Information these changes will enhance their ability to provide effective instruction,
track student progress, and make data-driven decisions that benefit their students academic
growth and success. Thank you and in my exhaustion I skipped right past member McQuillin.
M does come before O in the alphabet and also member Olken. So member McQuillin. I thought
we were on a different alphabet there. We're on a different alphabet. After five it's all right.
I'll be brief. My report is on the California state plan for career technical education.
There's a new plan that's rolling out and to support that implementation the CDE and the
chancellor's office from the community colleges are holding a series of meetings regional convenings
over the next six weeks. Ten of these throughout California to really look regionally how those
regions collaborate with the plan and bring bring those teams of people together on career
technical education. Those meetings are starting next week. Also under the CTIG the California
career technical technical education incentive grant round nine of those applications has gone
out and they're due back September 29th and then they'll come before us for approval
in our January 20 2024 meeting. The other part that's launching is the golden state pathways
program. This 500 million dollar program is established to promote pathways in high wage,
high skill, high growth areas and encourage collaborative between local agencies, higher
education and employers allowing students to advance seamlessly from high school to higher
ed and into their career in CTE various pathways. The program will have 10 service technical
assistance centers up to 10 and that's being launched right now and the RFPs have gone out
for that for 25 million and then LEAs can apply for that money later in the winter.
Thank you. And member Olken. Thank you. I just want to report briefly on two projects that I'm
the liaison for that because of summer had a lot going on they both are have educators who are
doing a lot of the work and so they had some time not in the classroom. The first one is
I'm the liaison for environmental literacy and specifically I was able to attend the California
climate change and environmental justice program summer convening which was groups from across the
state coming together to work on curriculum units in K through 12 that will address environmental
justice and climate change in that will be available for teachers across the state
and there's incredible convening and the work that they're doing is going to be
really exciting for our students and for teachers because it's really good work.
And then the second thing I'm involved in the statewide IEP template design project
and we did a lot of work this summer trying to draft a new
statewide IEP template that would really focus on student strengths and be really usable for
teachers in the classroom and that work is speeding up with the hope of having
a draft to start getting feedback on by late December or January. So those are my two big
things for now. Thank you. Member Patilla Bronson.
So one of my updates is around the universal pre-k mixed delivery quality and access work group
which actually has met twice since our last board meeting. That group is tasked with providing
recommendations on best practices and updates to preschools standards and it's the exciting moment
where we've dug very deep on identifying barriers and this month's conversation begins conversation
about solutions and the path forward so that's an exciting sort of next step for that group and the
final report will be coming later this year and then finalized in March 2024. The other update I
wanted to provide is that the prior conversation from the last meeting around school facilities,
the school bond bills have been put over by the legislature to resume in the new year and so that
work will continue. I think some of the conversation that I had raised previously around
low income districts and property, low property value districts, I think that
solution making will continue also in the new year. And then my last update is just a happy
coda to the California Summer School for the Arts had a successful and full enrollment
summer that wrapped up after our last board meeting over 400 students and for the first
time over 50 percent of students who attended received financial aid which speaks to a
socioeconomic mix that is the aspiration for the program. Thank you. Member Rodriguez.
Thank you. I will also be brief. So I have three items to report. One is the CTC meeting that
happened in August and two updates that I'll tell you about.
The roadmap to educational careers initiative or the roadmap to teaching was showcased and
if you have a chance, please visit the website roadmap to teaching on the CTC.
You can search CTC roadmap to teaching. It's amazing and share it with anybody that may want
to become a teacher. It is an educational career initiative and it was established by an assembly
bill AB 178 with the goal of helping to guide and explain pathways for individuals interested
in a career in education. The initiative is a direct response to the teacher shortage
affecting all parts of California and bolsters the governor's ongoing efforts to support education
in the state. So it's an amazing site. You can go in and say I'll be graduating from college and
it will tell you where to go. So please visit. It was very exciting to see that shared. Also at
the CTC meeting, LPI conducted an analysis of five years. So we had a study session. Five years of
new educators perceptions that were captured in surveys that examined statewide patterns
for the program completers. So when President Darling-Hammond and I were on the CTC in 2016,
the commission approved program completer surveys. So a teacher goes through a teacher ed program,
teacher prep program, and they complete a survey. The employer completes a survey.
So this data, 60,000 surveys were analyzed and I will, if you get a chance, you can watch the
meeting because there was information about teachers, about administrators that came out
of programs and how they feel about their preparation. But to summarize, completers of
educator prep and induction programs in California have positive perceptions of the
program effectiveness and preparedness. Clinical experiences are critical and across all surveys,
the intensity of clinical and personalized support is related to overall perceptions
and preparedness. And this was the tougher news and I don't think it's surprising based on what
we've seen. Not all educators have access to highly rated preparation experiences,
especially while supporting clinical practice and personalized support. So that was one of
the recommendations that the IPL, IP, I'm sorry, Learning Policy Institute. Stay away from acronyms.
I keep thinking of LPL Financial. It's a building I drive by.
Anyway, there were some policy recommendations, but especially to create parity among teacher
preparation because we want to make sure that all students in California have the best prepared
teachers and we know that the best prepared teachers are the ones that stay in the classroom
because we have the agency and the efficacy to handle issues that we confront on a daily basis.
As co-chair of the NASB PEP committee, we have completed our presentations,
our reports, and we should be reporting to NASB in October and present it to the public there.
And lastly, I assisted the MTSS conference in Anaheim after our last board meeting and I'm just
so impressed with all of the great work that's happening in California. There's some California
schools that were just really highlighted for all of their efforts to provide the best quality
supports, thoughtful supports, and so many sessions that modeled great teaching, what our schools
could be experiencing, and so I want to thank Jamie Parsons for the invitation and Rhonda
Marriott for all that they taught me about MTSS. Thank you. Member Yoshimoto-Tari.
Thank you. We spoke already today about civic learning, so I'm going to be extremely brief
and say the State School of Civic Engagement website does have great resources on it,
so I'd encourage everyone to look there. And in addition, in the 2022 state budget,
the legislature appropriated five million dollars a year for CDE to expand opportunities for young
people to participate in service learning. So those are great opportunities to expand
high quality service learning for our young people and there's another grant cycle coming this fall
and this winter for those interested in applying for those dollars to do so. Secondly,
our advisory commission on special education has completed their end of year report,
so I'm just going to ask all of my fellow colleagues to look for that that will be sent to us.
Shortly, it's available online, but it will be sent to our emails. That report is meant to advise
us, the state board, the legislature, the governor's office, and the CDE regarding all matters related
to special education. So there's information about mental health, the policy subcommittee,
including a section on the annual progress report, which we see usually typically in January.
So please look for that. And then finally, for community schools program,
I just wanted to say that our grantees will soon have an annual progress report
to reflect on and submit, and the State Transformation Assistance Center has gotten
a lot of feedback and multiple iterations of feedback in order to make that really meaningful,
a meaningful experience for our grantees in the California Community Schools Partnership Program.
So that will be something to look forward to. Thank you very much.
Thank you. And all of the things I was involved with have been reported on in this meeting.
I am now going to take up the last agenda item, 11, general public comment. Public comment is
invited on any matter not included in the printed agenda and members of the public wishing to provide
comment on this item may do so in person or by calling the number shown on the public comment
slide. There it is. Are there any speakers signed up to provide public comment in person?
Yes, we have one speaker signed up for in person, Lisa Ostertag. If you can please come up to the
microphone, state your name and affiliation for the record, please. Good evening, board. My name
is Lisa Ostertag and I'm the Assistant Director at Cabrillo Point Academy. We have experienced a
significant amount of complaints from one family in the last two years and are experiencing challenges
with the CDE's corrective action. While we appreciate the investigative process and understand
that it is an important component of protecting parents' procedural safeguards, we are growing
more concerned with the contradictory guidance that we receive from CDE. When the same family
continues to file the same complaints to the CDE and the CDE issues contradictory findings,
it becomes difficult for us to comply with the corrective actions. In a good faith effort to
align with the CDE, we want to ensure that there is a fair process. Specifically, we would like
these considerations. Contradictory findings may indicate there was not a thorough and comprehensive
investigation conducted. Evidence provided by the LEA should be appropriately considered and given
due weight. Specifically, if parents are interviewed and allowed to provide testimonial evidence,
the LEA should be afforded the same opportunity. When findings are issued, the guidance should be
clear and not require the LEA to make inferences as to how to move forward since there's no
mechanism provided to gather additional information regarding corrective actions or findings.
Time. Thank you. Thank you very much. And are there any public commenters in the queue on the
phone? There are no callers in the queue. All right. That means that we are now ready to adjourn
the September 2023 State Board of Education meeting at 541 p.m. Thank you very much.
Thank you.